THE SENATE EDUCATION WILL COME
TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN WRIST THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WALK ON THE PUBLIC
AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCES
PATIENT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THIS HEARING
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WE ARE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING OUT. OF THE
COMMITTEE TO BE PRESS I'M TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM AND BEGINNER HERE. ARE
WE CLEARLY DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
BUT WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
WE HAVE TEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA NONE ARE ON CONSENT
BEFORE WE HEAR OF WE'RE NOT
GONNA DO THAT SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO FIRST OFF AUTHOR CENTER
PORTANTINO WITH. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB EIGHT THIRTY
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- TODAY I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT SB EIGHT THIRTY. WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING TO LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES BASED ON AVERAGE DAILY
ENROLLMENT INSTEAD OF AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE ENROLLMENT
BASED FUNDING ENSURES EQUITY IN
OUR SCHOOLS ARE FUNDED AND ALSO
MAKES IT EASIER FOR DISTRICTS TO
PLAN THEIR BUDGETS AND
OPERATIONS. CALIFORNIA'S
CALCULATED SCHOOL FUNDING USING
THE AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
METHOD FOR MORE THAN FIVE
DECADES AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
IS ALWAYS EQUAL TO OR LESS THAN
ENROLLMENT BECAUSE STUDENTS MAY
BE ABSENT WHETHER EXCUSED OR
UNEXCUSED BESIDES CALIFORNIA IS
THE ONLY BESIDES CALIFORNIA THE
ONLY OTHER STATES THAT USED TO
TENANTS BASED FUNDING METHODS
ARE IDAHO. KENTUCKY MISSISSIPPI
MISSOURI IN TEXAS MOST STATES
BASE SCHOOL FUNDING ON THE
AVERAGE DAILY ENROLLMENT A
RAVAGER MOMENT REFERRED TO AS
AVERAGE DAILY MEMBERSHIP WHICH
IS A MUCH MORE EQUITABLE AND
STABLE BASED FUNDING METHOD IN
FACT. VOTING FAMILIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
FINANCIALLY PENALIZING THOSE
SCHOOLS REPORT TENANTS AND IT'S
NOT JUST THE SCHOOLS BUT REALLY
DIDN'T SHARE IN ATTENDANCE. THAT
ARE AFFECTED. SAM IN THESE
COMMUNITIES FAR MORE LIKELY TO
LACK RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION OR
HOUSING OR SUFFER FROM HEALTH
RELATED ISSUES FRANKLY MANY OF
WHICH WERE EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC. THEREFORE ATTENDANCE
BASED FUNDING PUNISHES STUDENTS
IN THE MOST IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
TENANTS BASED FUNDING ALSO
CAUSES ISSUES FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SINCE IT'S THEIR PLAN.
FOR OPERATION BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF A ROLL STUDENTS AS
OPPOSED TO ATTENDANCE BASICALLY
IT COSTS THE SAME TO TURN THE
LIGHTS OUT IN A CLASS OR WHETHER
YOU HAVE TWENTY KIDS IN THE
CLASS OR EIGHTEEN KIDS IN THE
CLASS AND SO. BY USING A TENANTS
WERE PENALIZING THOSE DISTRICTS
STUDENT ABSENCES ACTUALLY COST
SCHOOLS MONEY BECAUSE OF THE
DEMAND FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO TRACK DOWN ABSENT STUDENTS
AND PREPARE. A MAKE UP
ASSIGNMENTS SB EIGHT THIRTY
ATTEMPTS TO FIX THESE ISSUES BY
ALLOWING ELEAZAR TO RECEIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING USING THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEIR FUNDING
BASED ON ATTENDANCE UNDER THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
WHICH THEY WOULD RECEIVE BASED
ON STUDENT ENROLLMENT THIS
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING WILL
PROVIDE ALL ELEAZAR WITH MORE
FUNDING THAN THEY ARE CURRENTLY
RECEIVING ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT
TEND TO HAVE HIGHER RATES OF
ABSENTEEISM. NO SCHOOL RECEIVE
LESS FUNDING UNDER THIS BILL
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT NO SCHOOL
. LESS FUNDING. BILL THEY WILL
NOT BE WINNERS AND LOSERS THERE
WILL ONLY BE WINNERS. IN FACT A
RECENT REPORT BY THE POLICY
ANALYST AT THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION- CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
ALSO KNOWN AS PACE FOUND
SWITCHING FROM ATTENDANCE TO
ENROLLMENT. COULD HELP DISTRICTS
ACHIEVE FISCAL STABILITY
REDISTRIBUTE RESOURCES. THE
SCHOOLS WITH GREATER STUDENT
NEEDS AND PROVIDE MORE
FLEXIBILITY ON HOW TO SERVE
STUDENTS INSTRUCTIONAL
ADDITIONALLY SB EIGHT THIRTY
INCENTIVIZE ATTENDANCE BECAUSE
AT LEAST 30% OF THE NEW FUNDS
WOULD BE ALLOCATED AND DEDICATED
TO PREVENTING ABSENTEEISM. BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL SERVICES
AND SUPPORT THAT IMPROVE STUDENT
ATTENDANCE ADDRESSING THE ROOT
CAUSE OF CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM AND
EVENTUAL TRUANCY THAT'S
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE WE WANT THERE
TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY WE WANT
THERE TO BE EFFORTS MADE BY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO MAKE SURE
KIDS ARE IN CLASS AND SO BY
HAVING 30% OF THIS NEW
ADDITIONAL MONEY BE DEDICATED TO
THOSE SOURCES. WE THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT THE PANDEMIC HAS
DEMONSTRATED HOW VOLATILE IT
COULD BE A FUN POP. THE TENANTS
AND- WILL ENSURE THAT. SCHOOLS
ARE FUNDED EQUITABLY AND HAVE
GREATER FINANCIAL STABILITY AND
PREDICTABILITY SB EIGHT THIRTY
COUNTS. WITH STRONG SUPPORT FROM
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING THOSE REPRESENTING
STUDENTS FAMILY CIVIC BUSINESS
AND EMPLOYER GROUPS. AND LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES I HAVE HERE
TO TESTIFY WITH ME THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. HE'S ON HIS WAY
HE'S ALMOST HERE- I SHOULD HAVE
HIM ANY MOMENT- AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SUPERINTENDENT. ALBERTO CARBALLO
ON THE LINE AS WELL AS OUR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND OBVIOUSLY
WHEN APPROPRIATE I WOULD ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO WE GO TO YOUR LEAD
WITNESSES LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. LEYVA HERE LIVING
HERE OTOBO PROTESTING HERE
COURTESY HERE DALLY DAILY HERE
GLAZER GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE PAST
RECORD VERY GOOD A QUORUM IS
PRESENT- AND TO BE CLEAR A
CENTER PORTANTINO YOU ARE NOT
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CRAP NOT ACCEPTING THE COMING
OKAY AND SO JUST TO BE CLEAR TO
THE COMMITTEE I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BECAUSE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE NOT
BEING ACCEPT. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
TO YOUR FIRST LEAD SOME OF WILL
SECOND WILL GO TO MISTER ALBERTO
CARBALLO- PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. YES SIR I'M GONNA
CONNECTED MISTER CAVALLO RIGHT
NOW PLEASE HOLD THANK YOU.
NOTHING WILL BE DEAD THEN WENT
TO THE V. AND DISPENSED A NINETY
FIVE MEDIA WITHOUT BEING HIT BY
NEARLY THAT. IS FAMILY IS THE
END OF THE RIVER HAVING. WILL BE
GOOD AT THAT'S AT THE LAST FOR
THE M. BETTER THAN THREE FELLOW
TOGETHER. LINK MADAM MODERATE
I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S OUR
WITNESS LEADING ENGINE.
213-241-8363 IS NOT AVAILABLE
RECORD YOUR MESSAGE AT THE TONE
WHEN FINISHED IS. NOT MODERATE
CAN. FIND. PHONELINE GREMLINS
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE. YES CA
TT MODERATING YES WE ARE TRYING
TO GET TO ALBERTO CARVALLO IS HE
ON THE LINE. IF HIS FINANCIAL
INTERESTS EKING COOPER TELL.
PLEASE PROCEDURE OF TWO MINUTES.
I. I THANK. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LARA WILL TRY THAT. ALL
RIGHT AND WHILE WE ARE WAITING
FOR- SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN AND
MR CARBALLO LET'S GO AHEAD TO GO
GO TO ANYONE HERE IN ROUTE
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED INSULT WAIT
THERE'S THE SUPER ALL RIGHT
BEFORE YOUR IN THE I WILL CALL
ON YOU AGAIN MISTER SUPER AND-
TIMING YOU'RE UP. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER
WITNESS TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY. THANK THE
AUTHOR WHO ARE LEADING THIS BILL
AND ALL THE SPONSORS SIMPLY PUT
WE SUPPORT AND HAVE ALWAYS
SUPPORTED THE IDEA OF MOVING
FROM ATTENDANCE BASE REVENUE
GENERATION TO ENROLLMENT BASE
THIS WILL. PROVIDE FLEXIBLE AND
STABLE FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BUT THE PIECE THAT
INTERESTS ME THE MOST OF THE
REVENUES THAT WILL SUPPORT.
REDUCING CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM.
EMIGRATE DIFFERENCE FOR OUR
SCHOOLS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE SB EIGHT THREE
THANK YOU MISTER SUPERINTENDENT
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE ALL
OF METAMODEL REITER I AM GONNA
GO BACK TO YOU AND SEE IF WE
HAVE MISTER CAVALLO ON THE LINE
YES. LET ME GO AHEAD AND CONNECT
YOUR CAR NOW PLEASE HOLD THANK
YOU THANK. COLIN PRICES YOU
THOUGHT L. A. U. S. DOT NET
PLACERVILLE TESTING DONE. YES
YES WHAT IS TODAY UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MR
COVER YOU HAVE MINUTES FOR C.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- IT'S A
PLEASURE TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY
AND I'LL BE VERY BRIEF- MY
NAME'S UP ARTICLE FOLLOWING THE
PROPS ARE PRINTED ON THE FAT LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED. AND TODAY I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF- SENATE
BILL EIGHT THIRTY. THIS IS A
BILL THAT- STANDS TO ADDRESS
LONGSTANDING INEQUITIES IN THE
EXISTING EDUCATION SYSTEM
SPECIFIC FUNDING WHILE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE MORALLY AND
LEGALLY REQUIRED TO TALK ABOUT
RE RE ENGAGE STUDENTS WHO ARE
CHRONICALLY ABSENT OR
INDIVIDUALLY TORRENT SCHOOLS IS
NOT CURRENTLY WE SEE FUNDING IF
STUDENTS DO NOT SHOW UP. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TROUBLESOME FOR
DISTRICT HOURS A DISTRICT AND
SEEN THE RAVAGES OF COKE
NINETEEN WITH EXCESSIVELY HIGH
QUARANTINES INDIVIDUAL. SHOULD
WHICH ASTHMA AND OF COURSE SAID
THE REGRETTABLE PASSAGE ISSUE
THAT OFTEN KEEPS KIDS AT HOME.
LEVINE THE SYSTEM THAT EQUITY.
WHO IS FUNDING. MORE LINED THE
VAST MAJORITY OF DISTRICTS
STATES A THE- IS A REAL YEARS.
HAS COME. THIS IS A PROPOSAL
THAT DOES NOT TAKE ANY MONEY
FROM ANYONE. IT ACTUALLY
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATES THOSE
DISTRICTS WITH AN ACTUAL ACTUAL
ACTUAL AND ACCURATE RECOGNITION
OF ENROLLMENT RATHER THAN THE
VARIATION. OF AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE. SO IS BOTH WITH
PRIDE- AND MEANING. THAT I
SUPPORT CENTER PORTANTINO'S-
EFFORTS IN BRINGING EQUITY. TO
THE FUNDING PROCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. AND IS WITH
PRIDE ALSO THAT I THINK YOU KNOW
FOR THE TIME THAT YOU HAVE
AFFORDED ME. THANK YOU MUCH ARE
YOU WILL NOW GO TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE PROCEED STATE
YOUR NAME AND SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL ORGANIZATION ALSO PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS CHRIS MYERS
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. REPRESENTING MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STATE A PROUD
SPONSORS OF SB EIGHT THIRTY AND
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. AND A GARAGE ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO UNIFIED IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TRISTEN BROWN WITH CFT UNION OF
EDUCATORS ACOSTA PROFESSIONALS
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM TURN
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. YOU WERE APPROACHING THE
MAXIMUM LENGTH FOR RECORDING.
RECORDING AFTER THE TONE. A
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE MEET
THAT LINE THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED LIVVIE SANTOS ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU WOULD BE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHINGLESBEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS- PROUD CO SPONSOR REAL
MANAGEMENT FOR RECORDING THANK
YOU TO SEND THIS MESSAGE BEAR
WITH US TODAY MEMBERS WE'RE
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. WITH OUR SAP ON
THE EPISODE THE CALIFORNIA KEPT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA PROUD TO BE
A CO SPONSOR. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
SEEING NO ONE META MODERATOR
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINES CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO'S CALLED IN SUPPORT.
OF SB EIGHT THIRTY. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR FONG. AND FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY TWO
. ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONLY
ADDRESSING WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES OF A CO SPONSOR ENERGY
SUPPORT THANKS. AND NEXT TO HAVE
. LINE ONE. OKAY MOST REMOVE
THEMSELVES NINE ONE THIRTY ONE
IF YOU WISH TO STIFFY PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN. AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE. GO AHEAD. MANAGER
MEMBERS FLOOR WAFFLE ON BEHALF
OF THE GLEN DALE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY. NEXT WE HAVE BLIND
ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BRING WHITE WILL BE HALF
OF THE SOCIALIZATION OF
PERSONALIZED LEARNING SCHOOLS
AND SERVICES ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT THIRTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HEY WE HAVE PLAN ONE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS SEAN MAY SOUND REPRESENTATIVE
BUT A CLASSIFIED STAFF EIGHT
FIVE SIX FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
FACT HE- HELLO. YES YEAH. HELLO
YES WE GOT YOU WELL. I'M SORRY
NOT FALL WITHIN YOU WHAT IF SB
EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU IT'S GOING
TO BE A DAY. AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINED ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF MY NAME'S KEVIN
FROMER ON BEHALF THE COMP
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
SCHOOL EDUCATORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AT THE EIGHT THIRTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. AND
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN KILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MATAMATA
RAIDER. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
SERRA BUT CHEST WITH CALVO. AND
ALSO KATIE HARTMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
KATIE I THINK YOU'RE HERE. LET'S
GO TO YOU FIRST CENTURY HERE IN
PERSON AND THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATIE HARD ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. PTA DOES
NOT HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON
THE BILL THAT WE'VE CERTAINLY
BEEN ENGAGED IN THIS
CONVERSATION AND WE- BELIEVE
YOU'RE MOVING FROM AN AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE TO ENROLLMENT
BASED FUNDING MODEL- IS A
SIGNIFICANT POLICY CHANGE. THAT
COULD HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND OUR
LETTER THEREMIN ANY POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS WHEN MOVING TO A
NEW FUNDING FORMULA. AND I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT JUST A FEW
OF THOSE. FIRST THE BILL IS THE
WAY THE BILL IS STRUCTURE DOES
NOT FIT WITHIN THE L. C. F. F.
AND THAT STATE ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM. IF THE INTENT OF THE
BILL TO CREATE A MORE EQUITABLE
FUNDING SYSTEM THERE ARE MANY
WAYS TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL AND
THOSE SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
HOLISTICALLY IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE L. C. F. F. AN
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. SECOND SB
EIGHT THIRTY DOES NOT PROVIDE
ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION BUT REALLOCATE
EXISTING RESOURCES WITHIN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. IN
FACT IF ATTENDANCE IS NOT
ADEQUATELY INCENTIVISED THIS
CHANGE COULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT
OVERALL EDUCATION FUNDING
BECAUSE PROP NINETY EIGHT
REQUIRES THE USE OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FOR PURPOSES OF CALCULATING. THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE. AND FINALLY
THE BILL CREATES THIS ATMOSPHERE
WINNERS AND LOSERS LOSERS- CTA
SUPPORTS FURTHER INVESTMENT IN
THE L. C. F. F. TO PROVIDE A
MORE EQUITABLE AND ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- WE APPRECIATE THE
INTENT OF THE BILL- BUT WE AGREE
WITH THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED IT.
FURTHER STUDY THE END OF
ENROLLMENT BASED FUNDING AND
OTHER OPTIONS FOR PROVIDING MORE
EQUITABLE FUNDING THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT MENTAL
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP. OF MS. BOTCHES WITH
CALLASPO. GOOD AFTERNOON. HELLO
IS THERE A BUTTON FOR THE- HELLO
IT WOULD ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN OPPOSITION
OF FTA THIRTY WE DO RECOGNIZE
THE SENATOR PORTANTINO AND HIS
SPONSORS ARE INTERESTED IN
RESOLVING THE DISCREPANCIES THAT
CAN BE CREATED DUE TO THE
FUNDING BEING BASED ON EIGHTY
EIGHT AND WE ONLY A HAPPENED.
THAT EVERY STUDENT REGARDLESS OF
THEIR ATTENDANCE RECORD HAPPEN
EDUCATOR CLASSROOM SPACE
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS AND
EQUIPMENT TO ATTEND SCHOOLS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM DOES NOT PROVIDE SUCH A
RESOLUTION HOWEVER SB EIGHT
THIRTY AND NOT IN A ROMAN FEE
SYSTEM IT IS A NEW CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS CREATED USING A NEW-
ALLOCATION FUNDING. FORMULA JOHN
FORTUNATELY WE HAVE TO OPPOSE SB
EIGHT THIRTY AS IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE THINK PARKING INSURING
THAT THE FUNDS ARE TARGETED TO
THE ISSUE IT CLAIMS TO BE
FOCUSED ON CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
AND TRUANCY AND FAILS TO
DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDS IN AN APPLE
ON THE MATTER WITHOUT IT YOU CAN
ABILITY AND OVERSTRETCHED SURE.
THE BILL WHICH ADDITIONAL FUNDS
TO LEDS WITH LOWER. ATTENDANCE
RATES. WITHOUT ANY OR COUNTY ALL
OF THE- NOW IS THIS YOUR REVIEW
PRIOR TO DISTURB OF TO DO. IF
THE L. E. WITH HIGH AFTER. HAVE
PRIORITIZED AND IMPROVE THE KIND
ABSENTEE AND TRUANCY RATE PRIOR
TO THE FACT THAT CO THAT. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO CREATE A NEW
FUNDING SOURCES OUTSIDE OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
WHICH WILL COMPLICATE HOW LEDS
REPORT ALL OF THEIR AVAILABLE
RESOURCES. IN THERE- CAPS TO
ADDRESS EACH STATEWIDE PRIORITY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT SEEN
THE SPONSORS ALLOCATION DATA RUN
THEREFORE WE CANNOT PLAN IN THIS
YOUNG THAT THE FUNDS WILL BE
THERE TO. BE PART OF OUR OVERALL
FUNDING SYSTEM NOT ALL AND
LIAISE WITH PRIORITIZE CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM AS THEIR PRIMARY
ISSUE TO ADDRESS. AGAIN ANOTHER
LOST OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT
ALLEVIATES HAVE THE RESOURCES.
TO MEET THEIR STUDENTS NEEDS. F.
EIGHT THIRTY. REWARD LEN HAVE
NOW FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING CRIME
OFTEN. ISSUES DOES NOT HI THE
FUNDS TO CORRECT SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR STUDENTS AND DOES
NOT FACE BASED. ON AN APP
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION FOR THOSE
REASONS WE MUST OPPOSE. THANK
YOU ARE YOU WILL COME BACK HERE
TO ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
OPPOSE SB THIRTY IN THE ROOM
PLEASE COME FORWARD SEEING NO
ONE MET A MODERATOR WE'RE GOING
BACK TO YOU IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE. ON THE LINES
WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE SB EIGHT
THIRTY. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT THIRTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE NOW.
AND I HAVE NO ONE IN Q. OKAY
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR ALRIGHT WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING AND HEARING YES GO AHEAD
SUTTER CORTESE. THIS COMMENTS
MANAGER OF. EIGHT WE'RE I DO
VERY MUCH RESPECT- YOU KNOW YOUR
YOUR PERSPECTIVE YOUR POINT OF
VIEW. AS CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND I HAVE BEEN PRETTY STEADFAST
IN THAT REGARD. OF FOR AS LONG
AS I'VE BEEN ON THE COMEDIAN
EXPECT TO BE. SO IN THE FUTURE
SO NO KNOWLEDGE THAT- THE
AMENDMENTS DON'T DO ENOUGH FOR
ME AND I JUST WANTED TO EXPLAIN
NOT THAT I'M ANY MORE OR- LESS
AN EXPERT THAN ANYBODY ELSE BUT-
IF I CAN JUST SPEND A MINUTE ON.
OF MY OWN EXPERIENCE- GOING BACK
TO NINETEEN NINETY TWO WHEN I
WAS FIRST ELECTED SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER- AT THAT TIME- JUST PUT
THAT IN PERSPECTIVE A DELAY
EASTON WAS STOLEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN CHARTER SCHOOLS HAD
NOT BEEN CREATED YET SO. I'M
AGING MYSELF BUT THERE'S A POINT
IN THE AGING MYSELF IN THAT IS
THAT- A FEW YEARS AFTER THAT. I
STARTED BRINGING PEOPLE APPEAR
IN BUSLOADS TO SACRAMENTO TO
ARGUE FOR. A RESOLUTION TO I
THINK ONE OF THE WITNESSES
REFERRED TO AS A DISPARITY PETE
BETWEEN- BUT WROTE RELATIVE O
TWO EIGHTY AB SCHOOLS- THERE
HAVE SUBSEQUENTLY BEEN EIGHTEEN
OF THOSE BUS TRIPS UP HERE. AND
OVER AND OVER OVER OVER AGAIN
ESPECIALLY IN TIMES WHEN WE DID
NOT HAVE RESOURCES AVAILABLE IN
THE BUDGET LIKE WE DO THIS YEAR.
OF THE RESPONSE WHICH WAS
DISAPPOINTING BUT SOMETIMES
COMPELLING WAS SAID. WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY RIGHT NOW
AS A STATE- TO RESOLVE THAT
PROBLEM GIVEN THE SCALE- I FEEL
THAT. THE ULTIMATE REPERCUSSIONS
OF THIS BILL FROM A- OVERALL
FISCAL IMPACT TO EDUCATION IT
EVEN TO THE STATE BUDGET- ARE
COMPLETELY CERTAIN AT THIS
POINT- BUT I JUST CAN'T AFTER
ALL THESE YEARS- IT IN MY
OPINION PUT LET THE PERFECT GET
IN THE WAY OF THE GOOD. I FEEL
LIKE. THIS MAY BE MY ONE SHOT AS
- HONESTLY A SIXTY FIVE YEAR OLD
SENATOR AFTER ALL THESE YEARS-
IT. TO DO SOMETHING BOLD YOU
KNOW TO ATTEMPT TO REALLY MAKE
AN IMPACT HERE REALIZING FULL
WELL THAT JUSTICE MIGHT NEED TO
BE MADE IN THE FUTURE- IF THIS
DOES GET SIGNED INTO LAW. SO
AGAIN RESPECTFULLY- IN IN
RESPECT WITH OPPOSITION- IN IN
IN CAN RESPECTFULLY TWIRLING
CHAIR I JUST I JUST WANTED TO-
TO MAKE IT VERY VERY CLEAR WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT FOR ME AND YOU
KNOW WHY FROM HONESTLY FROM THE
DAY ONE WHEN I SAW THE BILL IN
PRINT- FILTER A COMPELLING NEED
TO SUPPORT IT. SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE CENTER
GLAZER. AS CHAIR- THIS IS A- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
BILLS THAT I THINK THAT I HAVE
FACED IN MY TIME ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND I KNOW-
IN APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR
FOR- DIGGING DOWN INTO THE SPACE
AND- SALON COMFORTABLE BECAUSE-
CONSEQUENCES THERE. ARE BIG ON
IT AS- MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN
JOSE AREA. HAS SAID THAT THE
PERFECT SHOULDN'T BE GOOD TO THE
PERFECT SHOULD NOT GET IN THE
WAY OF THE GOOD. AND I THINK
THAT- ARE THERE STILL SOME
QUESTIONS HERE OF COURSE THERE
ARE AND- SOME. ANXIETY ABOUT
THIS CHANGE IN UNDERSTANDING ALL
THE CONSEQUENCES OF COURSE.
THERE ARE- HI- BUT I WOULD SAY
THIS THAT- IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD TODAY I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT IT MOVING FORWARD TODAY.
THAT THIS COMMITTEE- HAS THE
ABILITY TO COULD TO LOOK MORE
DEEPLY IN THIS AREA HAVE MORE
HEARINGS. I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE- DON'T DO ENOUGH
AROUND HERE IS SLOW THINGS DOWN
AND HAVE THAT FURTHER STUDY. NOW
I THINK THAT COULD HAPPEN THIS
YEAR. I DON'T THINK IT MEANS
THAT WE STOP. A BILL THAT I
THINK IS IT IN GOOD ENOUGH SHAPE
FOR MOVING FOR BUT I THINK THAT
WE CAN. HAVE MORE HEARINGS AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT. TO
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE MORE
DEEPLY THANK AND THAT AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IF THERE
ARE ANY MORE DEEPLY WE CAN STILL
DO THAT. AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND THAT WOULD. MY
CONSTRUCTIVE SUGGESTION IN
REGARD TO SOME OF THE ANGST
ABOUT THIS CHANGE. I DID HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. SEND A NOTE
TO ALL MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS MORE
THAN A DOZEN IN MY DISTRICT ON
THIS BILL. AND GOT FEEDBACK FROM
ABOUT TEN. THAT I'VE REVIEWED
AGAIN YESTERDAY. AND FOR THE
MOST PART THEY FEEL THAT THAT
THIS IS GOING TO SERVE THEM
WHILE. A FEW SAID THAT NOT SO
SURE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GET
ANY BENEFIT OUT OF IT BUT THEY
DIDN'T SEE THE NEGATIVE- MOST OF
THEM FELT THIS. POSITIVE STEP
FORWARD IN THAT WAS COMPELLING
TESTIMONY TO MAKE. THEIR LIVES
FOR THE BILL TODAY WOULD BE
HAPPY TO MOVE IT. THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER. GOOD ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU I HAD A COUPLE
COMMENTS. UP I ORIGINALLY WANTED
TO DO A BILL ON ENROLLMENT BASED
FUNDING. BUT AFTER WE DUG IN A
LITTLE FURTHER- I DID SEE SOME
ISSUES THAT I THOUGHT WERE
PROBLEMATIC. AND I AM VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT. OF MORE EQUITABLE
FUNDING FOR OUR SCHOOLS.
PARTICULARLY WITHIN THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA- I'VE
NOW IS A GREAT TIME TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE ISSUES. OF
THAT WERE NOT ADDRESSED TO WIN
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WAS FIRST ADOPTED IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN JUST BEFORE I
WAS ELECTED. HOW WE COUNT
STUDENTS HOW WE FUND SPECIAL
EDUCATION. SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
C. T. E. AND MORE. AND THIS BILL
FURTHERS THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
HOWEVER AS IT RELATES TO FIVE.
STUDENTS ROMAN SAID A PENDANT.
BELIEVE IT. WITH CAREFUL EXAM
ALL OF THIS. AND LONG TERM
FISCAL. PROGRAMMATIC
ADMINISTRATIVE IMPACTS. TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. AND
STUDENTS. SUCH AS ARE WE AWARE
OF WHAT THE IMPACT OF NOBLE. AND
DEVISING STUDENT ATTENDANCE. OF
ALL CHIEF. WITH THIS BILL.
WINNERS AND LOSERS I KNOW THE
AUTHOR IT WOULD. I DON'T KNOW
THAT I FEEL THAT WAY. ARE THERE
ALTERNATIVES THAT INCREASED
EQUITY WITHOUT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING ENGAGEMENT WOULD
BUILDING UPON THE EQUITY PROMISE
ALREADY BUILT INTO THE L. C. F.
F. B. R. HIGHER SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION CAMPS. ACHIEVE THE
SAME GOAL. THE RECENT REPORT BY
THE POLICY ANALYSIS FOR
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION PACE.
OBSERVES THAT CHANGING THE LCF
STUDENT COUNT METHODOLOGY
CREATES TRADE OFFS AND SHOULD BE
ANALYZED AND OTHER ALTERNATIVES
FOR INCREASING FUNDING EQUITY.
SOMETHING THAT WE ALSO DON'T
THINK ABOUT IS IF WE GO TO
ENROLLMENT BASED FUNDING AND
ROMANS ARE DECREASING SO MY
WORRY ALSO IS THAT THIS IS A
SHORT TERM FIX. THE REPORT ALSO
CONCLUDES THAT CHANGING THE LCF
STUDENT COUNT METHODOLOGY WOULD
REQUIRE. THE STATE TO FIND OTHER
WAYS TO DRIVE POSITIVE PRACTICE.
PRACTICES RELATED TO STUDENT
ATTENDANCE AND ENGAGEMENT. I DO
NOT SEE A MEANINGFUL ATTEMPT TO
DRIVE THOSE PRACTICES IN THIS
BILL. I ALSO DO NOT SEE HOW THIS
BILL FITS WITHIN THE BROADER
EDUCATION FUNDING LANDSCAPE.
GIVEN THAT ATTENDANCE WAS STILL
BE USED TO CALCULATE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT. SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING LOTTERY ALL ACTIONS AND
MORE. FOR ALL THESE REASONS THE
COMMITTEE REMEMBRANCE WHAT
ESTABLISH. A PRE IMPLEMENTATION
STUDY TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR SO WE CAN CONTINUE
WITH THESE DISCUSSIONS. AND MAKE
A MORE INFORMED DECISION. WILL
BE VOTING NO ON THE BILL. THE
BILL HAS HOWEVER BEEN MOVED
CENTER PORTANTINO. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU ARE
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO
SPOKE. FOR THE BILL. OF CERTAIN
. COMMENTS FROM MY- I APPRECIATE
- THE DEEP CUTS. ABOUT THIS
CHANGE IS HARD. WHENEVER YOU
LOOK AND CONTEMPLATE MAKING A
CHANGE AND IN THIS CASE
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR FIVE DECADES- IT'S A
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION- THIS IS
NOT A NEW CONVERSATION THOUGH-
MY DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR
PASADENA UNIFIED. HAS BEEN ME
ASKING ME TO LOOK AT THIS CHANGE
FOR A DECADE- AND WHEN YOU HAVE
A SURPLUS TO THE SIZE OF THE
STATE IS. A GRAPPLING WITH THIS
YEAR I BELIEVE OUR STUDENTS OUR
CHILDREN SHOULD SHARE IN THAT
BENEFIT THAT SHOULD BE A TOP
PRIORITY AND- ARE ANALYSIS SHOWS
THAT- THREE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS OF EXTRA FUNDING OR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO K. TWELVE
EDUCATION WILL RESULT FROM THIS
BILL- AND EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WOULD SEE A BENEFIT- AND SO THIS
IS THE TIME TO MAKE THAT
STRUCTURAL CHANGE I THINK. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S COMMENTS OF HIS
FRUSTRATION THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
YOU KNOW GRAPPLING WITH. TRYING
TO GET ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION BRINGING PEOPLE HERE
HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED THIS IS
THE TIME TO MAKE THAT TO MAKE
THAT TRUCKS WILL CHANGE. THE
SHIFT TO A MORE EQUITABLE WAY OF
FUNDING EDUCATION WE KNOW THIS
IS WORKING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THAT MOST PROGRESSIVE
STATE OF FUND EDUCATION BASED ON
ENROLLMENT WE KNOW THAT IT DOES
NOT NEGATIVELY IMPACT
ATTENDANCE- WE HAVE. WE HAVE ALL
OF THE PILOT PROGRAMS WE NEED
BECAUSE WE HAVE ALL OF THOSE
STATES THAT ARE DOING THIS
EFFECTIVELY AND SELF. MY CLOSES
THIS TIME TO EMBRACE CHANGE
OBVIOUS I'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THOSE WHO HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS- MAKING SURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING NOT.
JUST REALLOCATING PROP NINETY
EIGHT BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT POINT TO KEEP MAKING
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I BOUGHT. AND HOPE THIS
CONTINUES TO MOVE THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR USER META
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B. FOR
THE MOTION TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LEYVA NO LEAVE
NO GO ABOVE. PROTEST. BY GLAZER
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PANTS WILLIE
THAT BILL- CALL FOR ABSENT ARE
YOU MISTER YOU ALSO HAVE SB NINE
OH SIX BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP
NINE OH SIX ON RECONSIDERATION
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT ARE REMOVED
THE DISCLOSURE COMPONENT OF THE
BILL- THERE FOR THE BILL WILL NO
LONGER REQUIRE PARENTS TO
DISCLOSE WHETHER ANY FARMS ARE
LOCATED IN THEIR HOME I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS ABOUT 80% OF THAT
INFORMATION ALREADY AND SO THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SO THAT PEACE. HAS COME OUT OF
THE BILL INSTEAD S. B. NINE OH
SIX REQUIRES LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
ON THE SALE OF FIREARMS ON THE
SAFE FIREARM STORAGE IN THEIR
ANNUAL NOTIFICATION IT ALSO WILL
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
WARINESS OF SAFETY PRECAUTIONS
TO HELP KEEP CHILDREN SAFE AND
IT WILL ALLOW CONCERNED TEACHERS
OR SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS TO ACT
ON A PERCIFORM THREAT BY
ALERTING LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
INVESTIGATE AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
WE SAW IN MICHIGAN WHEN IT'S
DISTRICT RECEIVED INFORMATION OF
A CREDIBLE THREAT AND THEY DID
NOT AND- WE SAW THAT WE LOVE.
PRIORITIZING THE SAFETY OF
STUDENTS. AND TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND STAFF- IS
IMPORTANT AND MAKING SURE THAT
FOLKS AT HOME KNOW WHAT THE
STORAGE LAWS ARE ABOUT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT- SO TODAY. I HAVE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY MARGOT BENNETT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WOMEN AGAINST
GUN VIOLENCE AND CHRISTIAN BROWN
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS. AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE TAKEN
SIGNIFICAN AMENDMENTS FROM
ACCESS AND OTHER INTERESTED
PARTIES AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT THE BILL. THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO I WE'RE GONNA
GO TO TRISTEN BROWN WHO IS HERE
IN PERSON YOU MAY BEGIN AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES. THE
TWO MINUTES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR TRISTON BROWN CFT UNIT OF
EDUCATORS CAUSED BY
PROFESSIONALS- WE ARE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE
WOULD LOVE TO THANK- SENATOR
PORTANTINO TO STAFF FOR WORKING
SO DILIGENTLY WITH US ON SOME OF
THE CONCERNS WE HAD. ORIGINALLY
AND NOW- WE REALLY SEE THIS BILL
SOMETHING THAT OFTENTIMES IN THE
WAKE OF THESE TRAGEDIES THE
NUMBER ONE QUESTION IS WHAT ELSE
COULD WE HAVE DONE- WE HAVE
MEMBERS THAT I HAVE. SEEN FIRST
HAND SOME- HORRIFIC EVENTS AT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND NEVER AGAIN
DO WE WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN.
AT WE- SOLUTION HOW TO PREVENT
VIOLENCE BUT THIS IS AN AMAZING
STEP FORWARD. IN BEING PROACTIVE
IN KNOWING HOW TO ASSESS
THREATS. I HAVE HOW TO BEST DEAL
WITH THOSE AND MIX THOSE WHO ARE
ON THE GROUND THOSE EDUCATORS
CLASSIFIED AND CERTIFICATED
ALIKE- TO KNOW THE BEST
PRACTICES FROM DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. AND ALSO BE ABLE TO
KNOW. OFTENTIMES A HORRIBLE
EVENT IS CAUSED BY THE ACCESS.
AND IF A PERSON IS ABLE TO GAIN
ACCESS TO A FIREARM THAT THEY
ARE ANOTHER OTHERWISE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO GET BUT- BY NATURE
JUST FINE. IN THE HOME. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW US TO SEE. THAT
SOME THREATS SHOULD BE AND OUGHT
TO BE TAKING A LITTLE BIT MORE
SERIOUSLY PERHAPS AND OTHERS- WE
DO. RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE AND
SOME BAD POLICY BUT WE THINK
THAT THIS IS A GREAT STEP
FORWARD AND- MAKING SURE WE'RE
KEEPING OUR SCHOOLS SAFE- JUST
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT AND
ASPIRIN I VOTE FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
IT WILL NOW GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES OF MADAME MODERATOR KEEP
PLEASE QUEUE UP MARGOT BENNETT.
HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
PROCEED GIVE TO YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE NO THREATS MY NAME IS
MARCO BENNETT AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WOMEN
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND ALMOST
THIRTY YEAR OLD NONPROFIT AND
VIOLENCE PREVENTION ORGANIZATION
HEADQUARTERED IN LOS ANGELES. IT
IS IRONIC TO ME THAT TODAY ON
THE TWENTY THIRD ANNIVERSARY OF
THE COLUMBINE HIGH SCHOOL
SHOOTING I'M HERE TESTIFYING
AGAIN ASKING YOU AGAIN TO PASS
SB NINE OH SIX OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. ACCORDING TO THE
WASHINGTON POST MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED NINETY TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN OUR NATION HAVE
EXPERIENCED GUN VIOLENCE AT
SCHOOL SINCE THAT DEVASTATING
MASS SHOOTING EVENTS. WE MUST
STOP SHIFTING ON TO OUR CHILDREN
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF KEEPING
THEMSELVES SAFE FROM GUN
VIOLENCE WHILE SHIRKING OUR OWN
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THEM.
WE ALL HAVE A CHANCE TODAY TO
MAKE THAT RIGHT AND TO DO
SOMETHING BOLD TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE IN OUR SCHOOLS. WE AT
WOMEN AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE ARE
GRATEFUL TO CALIFORNIA'S LEADER
ANTHONY PORTANTINO FOR HIS
EFFORTS AND WE ASK YOU AGAIN TO
PLEASE VOTE YES ON SB NINE NOTES
TAX THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED SEEING NO ONE
WE WILL GO TO LEAD OPPOSITION WE
HAVE. ONE PERSON KATHY SHEARER.
ALL I AM SO SORRY YES CORPS AND
HAVE BETWEEN- AND THEN I FORGOT
TO GET THE PHONE LINES SO SORRY.
PLEASE GO RIGHT AHEAD MAKING
BEAR WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WE HAVE OPPORTUNITY TAKE A
FORMAL POSITION YET BUT WE WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ADDRESS- ALL OF OUR
CONCERNS WILL BE TAKING US BACK
TO OUR COMMITTEE AND- JUST
WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AMENDMENTS AND EXPRESS
APPRECIATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT NOW FOUR. ONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH SIX MADAME
MODERATOR QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO. VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE OH SIX
PLATES. PART OF SB NINE. PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND
WE'LL START WITH LINE ONE FORTY
EIGHT. I CAN'T PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M AGAINST IT. OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. SKINNER LINE
NUMBER FOR THE WE HAVE ONE
PERSON IN THE QUEUE. THE NEXT WE
HAVE LINE ONE SIX EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT.
NINE ONE SIX EIGHT. JEFF FLOCK
OF REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY TO CONTEND WITH A SCHOOL
RECORD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
I HAVE BLIND ONE FOUR EIGHT. I'M
AGAINST IT THANK YOU. AND ONE
MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT FLIGHT.
THANKS WE HAVE LINED ONE SEVEN
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WE
CAN GET. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE CHAIRED MEMBERS
MANAGER YEAH I'M GOING TO DO IT
TO FALL OFF AND CALIFORNIA
THIRTEEN BIG DISTRICT I'LL BE
VERY HAPPY ALTHOUGH I REPRESENT
NEXT YEAR IN COLTON UNIFIED
DISTRICT AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE STILL INVOICE
IS IMPERATIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
SCHOOL THANK YOU DON'T THINK IN
THE NEXT YES. SUPPORT NEARLY AS
- THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ABOUT A MODERATOR ALRIGHT WILL
NOW GO TO LEAD OPPOSITION WE
HAVE KATHY SURE WHO'S THE
LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY FOR THE
ACLU- PLEASE QUEUE UP MADAME
MODERATOR MISS KATHY SURE. YES
THAT AFTERNOON- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
SURE CAN'T GO RIGHT AHEAD. GREAT
THANK YOU. I'M CAN BE SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION- I REALLY THINK WE ARE A
BIT MORE IN THE WIENER POSITION-
AND THEN OPPOSITION BUT BUT IF
ONE OF MY OUT- WHAT WHAT ARE
REMAINING CAN. OUR AND FIRST I
WANT TO THANK PLACE TO START BY
THANKING SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE TO THE BILL- WE ARE VERY
HAPPY. TO SEE THE PROVISIONS-
THAT WILL MAKE SURE THAT PARENTS
GET INFORMATION ABOUT THE
STORAGE OF FIREARMS- WE WANT
VERY MUCH TO KEEP WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET THE REST OF THIS RIGHT SO
THAT WE CAN KEEP. IT SAFE. FROM
GUN VIOLENCE AND FROM
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL INTERACTION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN MARCH
FOURTH RESPONSE IS NOT. THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE. WEHAVE
MAIN CONCERN WITH THE LANGUAGE
OF THE BILL. FIRST THE FOUNDER
FOR WHEN STUDENT BEHAVIOR IS
CLASSIFIED AS A CREDIBLE. THREAT
REMAINS VERY BROAD GOING FAR
BEYOND BEHAVIORS THAT INDICATE
THAT A STUDENT IS PLANNING TO
COMMIT A VIOLENT ACT. THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR REPORTING THE
THREATS MUST FOCUS ON ACTUAL
THREATS NOT KINDS OF EXPRESSIONS
THAT ARE TYPICAL OFYOUNG PEOPLE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE STRUGGLING WITH
DIFFICULT EMOTIONS YOU HAVE NO
INTENT WHATSOEVER TO HARMONY.
OTHERWISE WE KNOW WHO WILL
SUFFER MOST MOST BY BEING SEEN
AS A THREAT WHEN THEY ARE NOT-
AND THAT UNFORTUNATELY IS
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES. SECOND WE
BELIEVE THAT SCHOOLS NEED TO
RETAIN DISCRETION TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVOLVEMENT IS THE RIGHT
RESPONSE AND THE BEST WAY TO PUT
FILE ON. FOUR FOR A PARTICULAR
INCIDENT. WE HOPE THE SCHOOLS
WILL BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
STUDENTS WHO NEED HELP EARLIER
BEFORE THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE
RISK OF VIOLENCE. AND WHEN
APPROPRIATE SUPPORTS WILL WORK
BETTER. AND ANY POSSIBLE
VIOLENCE IN A LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATION WHAT. WE SO MUCH
APPRECIATE SENATOR PORTANTINO'S
EFFORTS OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS TO MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES THEY NEED. THOSE
RESOURCES ARE ESSENTIAL TO
PREVENTING VIOLENCE IN OUR
SCHOOLS. AND SCHOOLS SHOULD KNOW
THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO USE
THOSE TOOLS WHEN APPROPRIATE. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE SENATOR AND HIS
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT STILL
FOCUSES ON TRUE THREATS AND GIVE
SCHOOLS WITH QUESTIONS THEY NEED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR IT WILL
COME TO TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. SEEING NO
ONE MATAMATA WRITER GOING BACK
TO YOU FOR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
QUEUE UP IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE OH SIX. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE OH SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND FIRST WE HAVE
LINE. HUMPTY REMOVED HIMSELF ONE
MOMENT FOR THE NEXT NINE. AT
FIRST WE HAVE LINE ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WOULD
OPPOSITION OF THE FIELD THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE NUMBER YOU KNOW I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AND NOW WE HAVE
LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- MANAGER MEMBERS SAMPLE
REDDISH REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
OF CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL RIFLES ASSOCIATION
WE CONTINUE TO BE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE OH SIX. AND NOW WE
HAVE LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S ROOMY AND
I'M STRONGER. OF THE FIELD AT
FIFTY NINE OH SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. BILL
DEFENDER CORTESE. IF SOMEONE- I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN IN
THE COMMITTEE. THE LAST TIME IT
WAS HEARD HERE AND IT IT DOES
CHANGE MY PLEASURE TOWARD THE
BILL I- I JUST GOT FINISHED ON
THE PER BILL SAYING I DON'T WANT
TO LET THE PERFECT AT THE WAY
THE GOOD SO- I'M GONNA STICK
WITH THAT. ALTHOUGH I DO THINK
THAT THERE ARE SOME. ADDITIONAL
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE WORKED ON
HERE AND I JUST WANT TO MENTION
THEM AS I MEAN I GET ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. TO THE
AUTHOR WITH THIS REGARD IN THIS
REGARD BUT BY WAY OF EXAMPLE-
EVEN THOUGH- THERE'S- DOES SOME.
DEFINITION AROUND- DEPICTIONS OF
WORK THOSE KINDS OF EXPRESSIONS
OF NEEDING TO BE HOMICIDAL IN
NATURE. OF IN APPRECIATE THE
ROTC CAR ABOUT I THINK THERE'S-
GONNA BE OTHER CARVE OUTS THAT.
BORDER CLARITY AROUND THAT THEY
NEED TO BE- DEALT WITH NOT ONLY
FROM ULTIMATELY FROM THE FIRST
AMENDMENT STANDPOINT BUT- AS WE
ALL- ARTISTIC DEPICTIONS- WITH
THE BY STUDENTS YOUTH ADULTS OR
WHATEVER- ONE CAN ONLY IMAGINE
AND- THEN SOME OF THE- MORE
RURAL COUNTIES KIDS. GETTING
EXCITED ABOUT HUNTING SEASON OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IN. BEING
ASKED TO DEPICT. YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO AN
ARTISTIC EXPRESSION BY ADJUSTING
SOME WORK IS GOING TO NEED TO BE
DONE THERE SO WE DON'T- HAVE
SOMEBODY FEEL LIKE IT'S A
MANDATED REPORTER- WHEN IT'S
SIMPLY. AN ARTISTIC EXPRESSION
FOR EXAMPLE- INSTANCE SECONDLY
I'D I DON'T. YOU KNOW
PARTICULARLY LIKE THE IDEA OF-
IS SENSUALLY. TURNING IT
PERCEIVED THREAT INTO A JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IN KOREAN IN A SEARCH
OF YOU KNOW IN WORST CASE EVERY
BACKPACK IN THE SCHOOL- JUST
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
TRAUMATIZING STUDENTS AND SO
FORTH BUT- I DO KNOW IN MY OWN
COUNTY AGAIN NOT THE HEART
CONTINUALLY HARKING BACK ON MY
OWN EXPERIENCE BUT- IT. BEFORE
COLUMBINE- IN FACT TWO DAYS
AFTER COLIN COLE BY NOT KNOWING
THAT THAT WAS GONNA HAPPEN WE
RAN THE PURSE OF CODE RED DRILLS
THERE WITH A NATIONAL AUDIENCE
IN. CERTAINLY I'VE ALWAYS FELT
THERE FOR THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ERR ON THE SIDE OF WHO COMPLETE
ADJUSTING TO IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT- YOU KNOW EACH ISSUES
AROUND CIVILLIBERTIES SADDAM
EVEN THOUGH EIGHT I DO BELIEVE
THAT THAT MUCH OF THE WORK THAT
YOU CALL OUT HERE- WOULD BE
STANDARD PRACTICE IN A IN A LOT
OF THE COUNTIES OF. A JUST NOT
SO SURE. THAT'S WHAT EVERYBODY'S
DOING IN ALL THE COUNTIES AND
THERE CAN BE AN ARGUMENT FOR THE
BILL THE NEW CAN ALSO BE AN
ARGUMENT- THAT THAT THE BILL
NEEDS TO BE AS- AS FALSE AS
POSSIBLE IN THAT REGARD SO. SO
WITH THAT I'M AN AYE VOTE- THIS
TIME AROUND IN THE- THAT
HOPEFULLY YOU. YOU KNOW IF YOU
WERE ALE TO DO THIS MUCH WORK-
IT JUST A FEW DAYS OF HOPING
THAT WOULD HAVE REMAINING WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE- THERE'S PLENTY
OF TIME. TO RAISE THOSE ISSUES-
FOR BEFORE THE BILL COMES BACK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE CENTER GLAZER. I SPOKE
PREVIOUSLY WHEN THE BILL WAS
AND- AND AT. DIFFERENT FORM THAT
I THOUGHT WAS APPROPRIATE. I SAW
MAKE MY COMMENTS BRIEF- YOU
CAN'T. HEAR A BULLET HAS BEEN
FIRED OUT OF A GUN YOU CAN'T GO
PUT IT BACK IN. AND I THINK THAT
WHAT I WOULD RATHER ERR ON THE
SIDE OF GOING A LITTLE FURTHER
AND FINDING WAYS TO- TO BRING IT
BACK IF THAT WAS NECESSARY OR
APPROPRIATE BUT THE WHOLE IDEA
HERE IS TO STOP THESE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS FROM
HAPPENING BECAUSE YOU CAN'T. PUT
THE BULLET BACK IN THE GUN AND I
APPRECIATE CENTER PORTANTINO'S
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THE SPACE
IT'S AGAIN NOT AN EASY THING TO
LEGISLATORS- BUT YOUR HEART AND
YOUR HEAD IN THIS LEGISLATION IS
TOTALLY IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BUILT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS CENTER
PORTANTINO WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK- KRISTEN'S COMMENTS AND
MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS ARE ARE
RIGHT ON. YEAH YOU DON'T KNOW
WHEN YOU PREVENT SOMETHING YOU
JUST KNOW YOU DO- AND- AFTER
THERE'S A TRAGEDY YOU NEVER WANT
TO SAY. I WISH WE WOULD HAVE
DONE MORE- AND THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO WIN POWER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN. TO MAKE.
THE SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT SAFE I
MEAN. OUR CHILDREN SPEND A BIG
PORTION OF THEIR LIVES THEIR
TEACHERS AND- ADMINISTRATORS AND
STAFF SPEND A BIG PORTION OF
THEIR LIVES ON THESE CAMPUSES-
AND THEY SHOULD GO TO WORKING.
FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO COME HOME YOU KNOW NO
GRANDPARENTS. SHOULD HAVE TO
READ IN THE PAPER ABOUT. THEIR
BRANDLER GRANDSON BEING SHOT ON
A CAMPUS BECAUSE- THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT DIDN'T INVESTIGATE-
WHEN THEY KNEW THERE WAS A
CREDIBLE THREAT. AND WE SEEN
THAT THAT IS A PROBLEM PEOPLE
OFTEN SAY WHILE YOU'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM. WE SAW IN
MICHIGAN THAT THERE WAS AN
INACTION- IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE
THAT A PRINCIPAL MIGHT SAY THAT
WON'T HAPPEN HERE. OUR WATER FOR
WRONG- LET'S BE CAREFUL IT'S YOU
KNOW THIS. ERROR IS ON THE SIDE
OF CAUTION- AND WHATEVER YOU ARE
ON THE SIDE OF CAUTION THERE'S
GOING TO BE CONCERNS AND SO.
WE'RE TRYING OUR BEST TO ADDRESS
THEM- AND WE THINK WE'VE GOT A
LONG WAY AND THEN WE THINK THIS
WILL MAKE OUR CAMPUSES SAFER
FOR. FOR THOSE FOLKS WHO SPEND
THEIR TIME ON THE SCHOOL
CAMPUSES AND SO RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO I WILL HAVE TO AGREE
WITH CENTER CORTESE- WE DO NOT
WANTTO LET. PERFECT GET IN THE
WAY OF THE GOOD I APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK YOU DID ON THIS BILL I
THINK THERE'S STILL WORK TO BE
DONE BUT FOR ME IT IS
SUPPORTABLE TODAY. IT HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER GLAZER MAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. NINE
ZERO SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
LEYVA. HI LEYVA HI- TROUBLED.
COURTESY COURTESY I DELI. DELI
NO GLAZER. GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
YES. THANK YOU BETTER CONSULTANT
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO WILL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. REMEMBER WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
SENATOR SKINNER SB NINE OH FIVE
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU MADAM. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ARE CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW
REQUIRES CEMENT. MANUFACTURING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO BECOME
CARBON NEUTRAL BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. IN ORDER FOR THOSE
FACILITIES TO STAY I
CALIFORNIA. AND BECAUSE- THERE
ARE CARBON EMISSIONS AS PART OF
THE PROCESS OF SMITH'S WE'RE NOT
TALKING JUST THEIR POWER ON THE-
THE POWERING OF THE
MANUFACTURING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ACTUAL EMISSIONS IN
THE PROCESS BECAUSE OF THE USE
OF LIMESTONE AND SUCH. THAT ONE
OF THE ONLY WAYS WE'RE GOING TO
ACHIEVE THIS IS THROUGH A CARBON
CARBON CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTRATION. SO WHAT SB NINE
OH FIVE DOES IS ALLOWS
CALIFORNIA KIDS CAST CARBON
CAPTURE TECHNOLOGY IN THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE OF CARBON BY
PILOTING CARBON CAPTURE FOR A
SMALL NUMBER OF CAL A CEMENT
FACILITIES. NOW THE REASON THE-
THE BILLS BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
IS BECAUSE- SINCE THIS OF THE
PROP. SORRY TO PROJECTS ALLOWED
IN THIS BILL OUR PILOTS YOUR
CASTING A TECHNOLOGY. M. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE SOME
RESEARCH ASSOCIATED WITH IT AND
SO THE BILL DIRECTS CARD NOT
ONLY TO ESTABLISH ONE TO THREE
PILOTS THAT DO THIS CARPENTER
CAPTURE BUT ALSO SEQUESTRATION
IN UNDERGROUND FACILITIES BUT
ALSO ADDRESS CARD TO PARTNER.
WITH A YOU SEE A CSU OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO CREATE A
RESEARCH AND INNOVATION HUB TO
PROVIDE RESEARCH BOTH AND
ANALYZING THESE PROJECTS AND
SUPPORTING THESE PILOTS. ON IN
WITHOUT I'D LIKE. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT DOCTOR SONYA CHRISTIAN
ANSEL THE KERN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND DOCTOR CHEN
SPRINKLES OR FROM THE LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LAB. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER MADAME MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP DOCTOR
SONYA CHRISTIAN AND JEN'S
RECALLS ARE PLEASE I WILL LET
YOU. DECIDE WHO GOES FIRST. I'M
A PLANTER OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
SURELY FIND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE UNTIL YOU CHRISTIAN
CHANCE AT THE CURRENT COMMITTEE
COLLEGE DISTRICT DISTRICT
REPRESENTS MORE THAN ONE MILLION
RESIDENTS ACROSS TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES IN FIVE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA'S SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY WE ARE WORKING ON
CREATING AN INNOVATION RESEARCH
AND WORKFORCE HAS THE CARBON
CAPTURE AND SEQUESTRATION WE
WORKERS WITH VENICE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON EDUCATIONAL
PATH. TO LIVE UNDER A FULLY BEEN
UNDERREPRESENTED WORKERS JOBS
DURING THIS TRANSITION OF OUR
ENERGY ECONOMY EQUITY IS AT THE
CORE OF EVERYTHING WE DO WE
SUPPORT SB NINE OH FIVE AND LOOK
FORWARD CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THE WILD WEATHER LAND CONTROL
ASPECTS CAN REMAIN WITH THE KERN
COUNTY IS CURRENTLY THE LEADING
PEOPLE. SEVERAL GEN THE BILL TO
CREATE ONE TWO THREE PART THAT
THE STORE THE CARBON THE SKY. WE
APPLAUD THE BILL'S GOT. THAT THE
PRICE CAN INCREASE AND FOR. IN
LOCAL CAN LIKE OUR- WHICH WOULD
THEIR- WHAT THAT'S SEEMS. K. FOR
AT TO IN OUR REGION THE CARD
WHICH CAN. TO GRADUATION OUR
SERVICE AREAS FOR ITS- AN
INTEREST TO STORE CARD DIOXIDE.
THE CURRENT THE COLLEGE THIS
MORE WITH LABS BEEN H. K. OUR
LOCAL. ABOUT OPPOSITION FOR OUR
REGION CLEARLY ROLE IN. CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS. FOR THE MORE KERN
COUNTY RECEIVED. JUST AND-
TRANSPORTATION THE HIGHLY. THE
PARK OF ENERGY CAN AND CRIMES SB
NINE OF WILL ACCELERATE IS
WORKING INDUSTRY AND I HAVE THE
COMMITTEES THANK YOU THE YOU
WILL GO NEXT- LEADS TO JEN'S
HOLD PLEASE PROCEED YOU'RE READY
. YEAH THANKS INVITING ME TO
OKAY CAN YOU ME WE CAN QUITE
UNDERSTAND BURKE ALSO BECAUSE
SERVICE THE APPROACH LAUGHTER.
FOR A NUMBER SCIENCE WITH THE
MARCH THIRTY NASH OUT. WE HAVE A
FIVE HUNDRED WE STAFF IN THE-
WITH EXTRA IN CLIMATE FIVE GSR
AND CARBON. MY TESTIMONY AS MY
OWN AND NOT PLEASE OF PUTS OF
THE S. R. OF ENERGY OF ABOUT.
COULD YOU COME SECRETARY ACROSS
OF CARE CO CAP FORM SOURCE LIKE
PLANTS ABOUT AND THE FACT OF THE
STOCKS WHERE CAN AND THE FIRST
FIVE. SIXTEEN AYE BERKELEY
WORKING ON THE SITE BUT THE
BECAUSE FOR MORE THAN FOUR
YEARS. ON TEST THE HOURS YOU WE
HAVE BROUGHT. MONITORING HOW IT
. MIGRATED FROM THE DEEP
UNDERGROUND OF PROVIDING IT BY
HOW TO PAY REGULAR PROJECT SO
THE LETTER. FOR I'M GOING TO
WITH THE- WITH.
GEOLOGY THE SCOTSMAN CHECK THAT
IN THE STATE FORMATION WOULD BE
TRAPPED IN VARIOUS PLACES DOES
NOT ASK. CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT OF
FAMILY KIANA SECRET SHOPPING
GRANT COUNTY BUT CRIMINAL
CONSECRATION FALLS IN THIS IN
THE STATE. MY TEAM AND I
PROBABLY WORKING ON OF THE
REMAINING SCIENTIFICALLY RELATED
TO THE QUALITY OF OUR
CONSECRATION MUCH GREATER SCALE
THAN IS CURRENTLY DONE ACROSS
THE WORLD. WE NOTICED A LARGE
WILL BE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN
THE FUTURE EVEN WHEN THE WORLD
HAS STOPPED USING FOSSIL FUEL.
TO DECARBONISING POLICIES THAT
ARE HARD TO BATES LIKE CEMENT
PROJECT PRODUCTION THE TOPIC OF
THIS BILL ALSO. TO PROVIDE
STORAGE OPTIONS FOR CALL.
CORRECTLY FROM THERE ARE TO
CHOOSE NEGATIVE FROM. WHICH MAY
DECIDE TO LEAVE THIS MESSAGE
JANET. BUT THE BUILDING AFTER
LARGE SCHEDULE CARBON
SEQUESTRATION I LIVE IN THE
STATE ALSO BY COOPERATE
STRATEGIES BUT REDUCING
REFLECTIONS. WAVES ABSOLUTE THE
MEASURE. SB OH FIVE WILL
ACCELERATE. GEOLOGICAL UNSERVED
OF SMOKE OR AS PHYSICAL OPTION
POLITICAL CALL CALIFORNIA. IT'S
NOT A VITAL TO WIN MOVIE PER
REQUIREMENTS YOU IMPLEMENT
PLEASE REFORM. WELL I'M SURE
THAT KIND OF LEVER WE AND IT'S
GOOD INSTITUTE TO DEVELOP X. TO
CONDUCT THE SIGNED OF SAFETY
SUPPRESSION COMICS GET THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU VERY. OKAY WILL
COME TO ROOM TO ONE HUNDRED FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SHOW
THERE'S FOR S. B. OH FIVE.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY CHAIR MIKE MADIGAN ON BEHALF
OF THE NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND
WOMEN IN MEN IN THE- HELLO STATE
BUILDING AND COULD. DON'T IN
ROUTE THIS Q. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
BOB PROJECT TWENTY THIRTY X. TOO
MUCH SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. HI DIæN DECEMBER PROJECT
TWENTY THIRTY STRONG SUPPORT AND
ALSO CONVEYING THE SUPPORT OF
THE CLIMATE CENTER GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YOU CAN GO AHEAD
OF IT EFA YOU'RE A TWEENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS PERSON YANNI ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA SUSTAINABLE CEMENT
MANUFACTURING THE ENVIRONMENT WE
REPRESENT. A THROUGH THIS
ASSOCIATION ALL THE CEMENT
MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY LAST YEAR
WAS SENATOR BACK DURING HIS
CARBON NEUTRALITY BILL IN THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF ACCEPTED A
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOAL BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. WE ARE GOING THROUGH
THE SAME PROCESS WITH SENATOR
SKINNER ON THIS BILL WE HAVE
SOME AMENDMENTS WE HAVE SOME
MEETINGS PLANNED- BUT WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE- TEST VERY
HAPPY WITH YOU GAVE ME. THE
SENATOR SO WILL PRINT CARDS THAT
CONTINUE TO MOVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO WE HAVE. OPPOSITE WELCOME.
ONE IN OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
PLEASE PROCEED NO LEAD OFF THE
MAY TWO MEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MANAGE YOUR MEMBERS AND I WAS
ACTUALLY GOING TO ASK IF I COULD
ACTUALLY SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ON
THE BILL UP WITH YEAH NOT TO GET
OUT OF LINE WITH TWO MINUTES DO
YOU THINK- SO VERGE WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CARBON
CAPTURE COALITION WE'RE- LABOR.
SURE IT'S EASIER. TART
CALIFORNIA. EFFORTS TO REDUCE.
GAS EMISSIONS. 101% SUPPORT
CENTER SCANNERS- RECOGNITION THE
TEETH US TECHNOLOGIES HAVE TO BE
PART OF THE EQUATION THE FACT IS
WE WILL NOT ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
GOALS IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT DEPLOYMENT OF CCS
TECHNOLOGIES. THAT'S SCIENCE AND
THAT'S MATTHEW OUR CONCERN HERE
IS THAT- FALL CEMENT IS
ABSOLUTELY ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
APPLICATIONS FOR THIS TECHNOLOGY
. IT IS TOO NARROW AND THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF OTHER SOURCES AND
ECONOMIC SECTORS THAT WILL.
BENEFIT FROM APPLICATION OF CCS
TECHNOLOGIES- COLLECTIVELY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT UPWARDS OF SIXTY
MILLION TONS A YEAR WHICH IS A
HUGE CHUNK OF WHAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO ACHIEVE ITS CARBON
GOALS. SO OUR CONCERN AGAIN IS
THAT THE BILL'S FOCUS ON CEMENT
IS TOO NARROW AND WHAT WE NEED
IN CALIFORNIA IS AN ACTUAL BROAD
POLICY FRAME THIS GONNA SCALE CC
THAT THE COPPER JEEZ. CROSS THE
WHOLE SPECTRUM OF. WHERE THEY
ARE. OKAY THANK YOU FOR MUCH YOU
ARE WELCOME. ALSO IN THE
OPPOSITION ZACH LARRY ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY WE
TAKE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SEE
NO ONE ELSE MEDHA MODERATOR
GOING TO GO TO THE LINES COULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN THEM UP FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO. EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION TO SB NINE OH
FIVE PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
FIRST WE HAVE LINE ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
PREFER THE WRONG THE BILL. NO
PROBLEM PROCEED WAITING. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE HAVE BLIND ONE
SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
PITCH FOR A COMPANY TO
CONSERVANCY CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATOR SKINNER'S SB
NINE OH FIVE I BELIEVE YOU
CALLED FOR OPPOSITION BUT AND
WE'RE CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF FIFTY. FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I
AM ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT AND I
DIDN'T HEAR ANYBODY CALL VOTE ON
THAT MY NAME IS CHERYL KUNIO I'M
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CHAPTER OF THE CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT AND WE'RE SURPRISED IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU YOU'RE RIGHT I THINKI
FORGOT TO CALL FOR SUPPORT SO
ANYONE CALL YOU IN FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION IT IS A CUFFLEY
DAY FOR THE CHAIR. PLEASE
PROCEED BETTER MONITOR. YES WE
HAVE LINE ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO PLEASE PROVIDE.
YES HELLO VERSION OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE
HAVE LINE ONE SEVEN NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON HEARING
MEMBERS ELENA ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ACTION FUND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A FORTY CONCEPT THE FOR THE
REASONS OUTLINED IN OUR- THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND THEY REMOVED HIMSELF NEXT WE
HAVE LINE ONE TWO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE TWENTY FOUR. ARE
NOT CHRISTIAN LOPEZ NUMBER YOU
KNOW- POSE. THANK YOU. AND THAT
IS ALL I HAD TO KILL GREAT
EMENTA MODERATOR I'M ASK ONE
MORE TIME FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL SINCE I DIDN'T
OFFICIALLY DO THAT IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES WHO
WISH TO SIT EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE OH FIVE.
PLEASE QUEUE UP NOW. CATHAY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO. ONE
MOMENT FOR FIRST LINE.
AND FROM MY NUMBER ONE FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GENESIS
TEN ON BEHALF OF CLEAN AIR TASK
FORCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FIVE. HANNAH WE HAVE
ANOTHER LINE HEARING UP ONE
MOMENT.
NINE ONE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS CAITLYN REGNER
CENTER FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND THE FORTY NINE
OH FIVE IN CONTACT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THAT IS ALL I HAD
A JOB THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
OKAY WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. CENTER
CORTESE IN FAVOR GLAZER I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL AND THEY-
I HAVE JUST ONE SUGGESTION GOING
FORWARD AND I'M NOT EVEN SURE IF
IT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
PRESCRIBED IN A BILL BUT- OF THE
RESEARCH AND INNOVATION HUB.
WELL- APPRECIATING THAT THE
BROAD LANGUAGE IN THERE AS TO-
YOU KNOW HOW THAT MIGHT WORK IN
THAT. YES FOLKS BEING INVOLVED
WITH IT I WOULD- IT JUST JUMPING
OUT AT ME BASED ON SOME OF THE
EXPERIENCE- SO FAR WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN WITH- THE
COMMITTEE THAT I CHAIR TRYING TO
COME UP WITH METRICS IN TRYING
TO COME UP WITH. ANYONE WHO'S
ALGORITHM CAN REALLY PULL DATA
TOGETHER EVEN JUST ON THE WORK
FORCE TRANSITION TO THE BONE-
YOU KNOW EVERYTHING IT'S SORT
COLLUDED HERE IS SAID- YOU KNOW
THE ONE UC CAMPUS- THAT MAY BE A
PARTNER WITH OTHER CAMPUSES- IT
MAY QUITE A SENSE WOULD BE TO
SEE SAN DIEGO WITH SUPERCOMPUTER
CENTER BECAUSE- I JUST DON'T
THINK THAT KIND OF WORK IS
CAPABLE OF BEING DONE. THE END
OF. DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TO
PRESCRIPTIVE BE IN A IN A- BUT
MAY BE WORTH AT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE CENTER
GLAZER. THANK YOU- I WILL NOW
WITH SOME IRONY THAT THIS IS NOT
THE TYPICAL ISSUE THAT WE WOULD
DEAL WITH YOUR EDUCATION
THROUGH- AND SO THIS OULD NOT
BE CONVERSATION I WOULD
TYPICALLY BE A PART OF AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE IT WITH. YOU CENTER SKINNER
ON THIS BILL- I KNOW WE HAVE THE
SAME SHARED GOALS- GHG
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS ARE
PLAYED A SERIOUS PROBLEM- THE-
FOSSIL FUELS ARE A PART OF THAT.
PACKAGE CONTRIBUTING
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THAT PROBLEM-
AND- YOU KNOW WE HAVE- DIFFICULT
CHALLENGES AHEAD TO DO WHAT'S
NECESSARY. BEYOND THE BROADER
GOALS THAT WE HAVE SET AS A
STATE IN WHICH I HAVE SUPPORTED.
ON THE CHALLENGE THAT I'M
HAVING- IN THIS BUDGET BILL INTO
GRANTED BY THE WAY YOU KNOW YOUR
FOCUS ON CEMENT GOT IT GOOD
REASONS. A LOT OF GOOD CAN COME
OUT OF THAT WORK THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING TO DO IN THE BILL-
THE- SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
I AM. STRUGGLING WITH IN REGARD
TO THE BILL IS THE NARROWNESS OF
IT- JUST FOCUSING ON THAT. SPACE
THERE'S LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT AT THAT TO EXCLUDE TO KIND
OF REVIEW AND RESEARCH. ON
FOSSIL FUELS. AND HOW THAT COULD
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION- THERE'S
A RECOGNITION. OF THE AT LEAST
IN THE ANALYSIS OF THE
PREVENTING PROBLEMS THAT- THAT
WE SEE. IN THE ANY KIND OF
APPLICATION. WITH DELAYS OF
FIVE. TO BE ABLE TO. TRY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CARBON CAPTURE AND
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT THAT HAS-
I HAVE TO SAY THAT WHEN I LOOK
AT. THE CRITERIA THAT HAVE BEEN
SET UP IN THE BILL. IT IT
REMINDS ME OF OUR HOUSING CRISIS
. WHY IS WHY IS THAT BECAUSE WE
SAY WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS IN
THE STATE AND THEN WE CREATE ALL
THESE CRITERIA AND ALL THESE
GOOD VALUES THAT WE HAVE. THAT
HAVE TO BE IN PLACE FOR US TO
SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS AND
THEN AT THE END OF THE DAY GOOD
PLUS GOOD PLUS GOOD EQUALS BAD
WE DIDN'T REALLY GET THE
PROBLEM. AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE OF CARBON CAPTURE AND
THE POTENTIAL THE POTENTIAL THAT
IT AS I SEE THE START OF THAT IN
IN THIS BILL. THERE'S PARK
MENSEN PRIORITIES THAT ARE SET
THAT HAVE GOOD VALUES AND
REASONS FOR THEM BUT THE END OF
THE DAY ARE THE GONNA LET US
THIS PROBLEM. THE SOLVE. AND THE
WAY IN BECAUSE WE KEEP PILING ON
A THE GOOD THAT WE WANT SEE AND
HOW IT'S DONE IN THEN WE DON'T
REALLY SUB. AND SO THOSE ARE THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE BEING WITH
THE BILL THAT I KNOW COMES A
GOOD PLACE THE NARROWNESS OF IT
AND- HIS IS. PART OF IT THAT.
HAS ME CONCERNED. ONE DIRECTION
THE CARE YES OF COURSE I'M. I
WAS IN STE SENATE HE Q. THIS
MORNING WE HEARD AND PASSED THE
BILL BY SENATOR CAFIERO ON MUCH
BROADER- EMPOWERING A. R. B. SIX
TO DO A MUCH BETTER. I PURCHASE
A OF CARBON SURE IN STORAGE.
HELLO THIS BILL IS SPECIFICALLY
IN EUROPE NOT GOING BACK MISS
CARD CABALLERO SPILL CENTER
CAREER SPELL IT DOES NOT
AUTHORIZE ANY PILOTS. AND THERE
IS. FOR ALL PRACTICAL PURPOSES
THERE'S NOT REALLY ANY VIABLE
COMMERCIAL CARBON CAPTURE IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW. FIND ONLY
WORLDWIDE IN A FEW PLACES. SO
PERSONALLY I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE I
WANT TO SEE IT. BUT I ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE'S LOTS OF PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT THERE WE TAKE
THE GEO SEQUESTRATION WE KNOW
FOR EXAMPLE ONLY SO CANYON WAS
IN EFFECT- A- GEOLOGIC CAP-
PLEASE HOLD. BUT CERTAIN GASES
RATE IN THE ESCAPED AND IT
CAUSED PROBLEMS NOW CARBON
ESCAPING WOULD NOT BECAUSE THAT
TYPE OF- PERCEIVE NEW AIR
POLLUTION BECAUSE CARBON ME YES
IT'S BAD FOR THE CLIMATE BUT
IT'S NOT TOXIC PER SE BUT THE-
BEING IS THAT. WE BOTH DO NOT
HAVE THE GROUP WILL. YOU KNOW
PUT IT'S NOT ALREADY
COMMERCIALLY VIABLE WE HAVEN'T
HAD. SO THE PURPOSE OF MY BILL
IS TO GET US TO START THAT. IN
ITS NARROW. TO YOU KNOW HAVE
HOPEFULLY A SUCCESSFUL
EXPERIENCE THAT WE CAN THEN
BUILD ON. WHILE THE TECHNOLOGIES
ARE DEVELOPING WORLD MARKETS
DEVELOPING BEYOND WHILE
CONFIRMING THAT SENATOR COPIERS
. MOVES AND I SUPPORTED IT HARB
ALSO DEVELOPS RULES OR- OR
PRIORITIES FOR MUCH LARGER. SO I
UNDERSTAND THE- OPPOSITION WOULD
LIKE MY BILL DO EVERYTHING BUT A
SINGLE BILL CAN'T DO EVERYTHING
AND IT IS GETTING US AT LEAST
GETTING CALIFORNIA THE
EXPERIENCE OF CAPTURING SOME
CARBON AND STORING IT WHICH WE
DON'T HAVE YET SO THAT POINT OF
VIEW I THINK IT'S A IT'S A GOOD
MOVE FORWARD IMPORTANT MOVE
FORWARD. AND IT ALLOWS US THEN
TO HELP US WAY SOME OF THE FEARS
ABOUT THIS TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE
I'M OPTIMISTIC WILL PROVE THAT
IT WORKED IT DIDN'T HURT THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO STORAGE
GEOLOGICALLY. GO AHEAD CENTER
GLAZER WHAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT EXPLANATION AND I DID
WATCH THE HEARING THIS MORNING.
ON THE COPIER OF BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- YOU AND OTHERS
ARE INVOLVED IN A BROADER
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE- COM.
BROADER AND FACE- AND I THINK
THAT HELPS ME TODAY BECAUSE IT
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM WHO
IS HERE IN ISOLATION I WOULDN'T
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT GOING
FORWARD BUT I THINK GIVEN THE
CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATION THAT'S
GOING ON RIGHT- I WOULD JUST
ONLY CAUTION ALL OF US SAY TO
ALL OF US THAT. THAT IF WE SAY
THIS IS A BIG PRIORITY CLIMATE
CHANGE WELL THEN SOMETIMES WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GIVE UP SOME OF
THOSE GREATER VALUES THAT WE
ALSO HAVE IN OUR SYSTEMS FOR HOW
WE DO OUR WORK BECAUSE WE NEED
IT RESPOND TO THE CRISIS AND
THAT MEANS THAT EVERYBODY GETS
THEY WANT BECAUSE WE'RE
RESPONDING TO THE CRISIS AND IF
WE'RE GONNA SAY WE'RE IN A
CRISIS LET'S ACT LIKE WORK BASIS
. I THINK THAT THAT THE GOAL
THAT OF YOUR WORK HERE. THIS IS
. I HOPE WE KEEP THAT AT THAT
THE POOR. OF THAT CAN HOPEFULLY
WE WON'T HAVE TO DO THAT GIVING
UP BECAUSE WILL PROVE THAT IT
WORKS AND IT'S SAFE. INDEED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BOTH ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE
A MOTION FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
CENTER CORTESE CENTER'S GONNA
MAYBE TAKE THAT MEASURE CLOSE
YES EXCELLENT VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR CORTESE MENTAL
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE
ZERO FIVE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THAT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA HI. LEYVA HI- TELEVOTE.
WHICH WILL KNOW CORTES. AYE
COURTESY AYE DALLI. DALLY NO
GLAZER. LATER AYE MCGUIRE PAN
WILL KEEP THAT BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER ALL
RIGHT NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM FOR
SENATOR DORADO SB ELEVEN SIXTY.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THE AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT GREAT DAY TODAY YES WE THE
PASSED MY BILL. THE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO THE STAFF FOR WORKING ON THIS
BILL- AND WITHOUT YOUR TIME YOUR
STAFF'S TIME WE WOULDN'T GET
THIS FAR- AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED OUTLINED ON
PAGE SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS THANK
YOU SENATE BILL ELEVEN SIXTY.
WILL ALLOW DEPENDENT VISA
STUDENTS THAT MEET EXISTING-
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS TO PAY
IN STATE TUITION. AT
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. OVER TWO DECADES
AGO AB FIVE FORTY WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW AND ALLOWED ANY STUDENT
WHO MET- ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS TO PAY IN STATE
TUITION TO ATTEND OUR STATE
COLLEGE PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. WHILE THE PASSAGE
OF AB FIVE FORTY HAS PROVIDED
GREATER COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
FOR MANY STUDENTS. THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WITH QUOTE UNQUOTE
NON IMMIGRANT VISAS WHO ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO BENEFIT FROM THE
NONRESIDENT TUITION WAIVER EVEN
IF THEY MEET THE REST OF THE
CRITERIA. THIS BILL WILL INCLUDE
DEPENDENT VISA STUDENTS WHO ARE
CHILDREN OF LONG TERM VISA
HOLDERS. CHILDREN WHO GROW UP
WITH LEGAL STATUS IN THE U. S.
BUT WILL AGE OUT AT AGE TWENTY
ONE ONE THIRD DEPENDENT VISA
EXPIRES. AND THEY BECOME
UNDOCUMENTED. THIS GROUP OF
STUDENTS HAVE GROWN UP IN
CALIFORNIA AND HAVE ATTENDED THE
MAJORITY IF NOT ALL OF THEIR
PRIMARY EDUCATION IN THE STATE
HOWEVER. WHEN THE STUDENTS APPLY
TO COLLEGE THEY MUST APPLY AS AN
OUT OF STATE RESIDENTS AND PAY
INTERNATIONAL FEES AND TUITION
SIMPLY DUE TO THAT PARTICULAR
IMMIGRANT STATUS. IN ADDITION
STUDENTS ON DEPENDENT VISAS ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL OR
STATE FINANCIAL AID SCHOLARSHIPS
OR PUBLIC OR PRIVATE STUDENT
LOANS AND DO NOT HAVE WORK
AUTHORIZATION TO EARN MONEY ALL
WHILE THE PARENTS HAVE PAID
CALIFORNIA TAXES FOR DECADES
ABOUT YEARS AND DECADES. ANOTHER
ISSUE IS THIS. THESE SOUT AND
CHANGES THEIR STATUS OF. OF MOST
UNIVERSITIES CHANGE THEIR
RESIDENCY STATUS AND MAKES THEM
START PAYING INTERNATIONAL
TUITION RATE STUDENTS REAL GROWN
UP IN CALIFORNIAN WOULD
OTHERWISE MAKE RESIDENT
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS ALREADY
THEY HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
NAVIGATING THIS IMMIGRATION LAW
ALL SEEN AN INCREASE IN SUBURBAN
DURING THE MIDDLE OF THEIR
COLLEGE YEARS SO THIS BILL SEEKS
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES INCREASE
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY FOR A FEW
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRANT
STATUS. I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
IMMIGRATION ISSUES FOR MOST OF
MY ADULT LIFE AND WHEN WE SAY
THE IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IS BROKEN
IT IS BROKEN PERIOD I DON'T
THINK ANYONE CAN GET THROUGH
LIFE AND NOT KNOW SOMEONE WHO
HAS IS TREATED UNFAIRLY BY THE
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM. HERE'S ONE
SLICE THAT I HOPE THAT WE CAN
CORRECT SO WITH ME TODAY ARE TWO
WITNESSES- EVEN SEEN HER. THE
CAT OF FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
OF IMPROVE THE DREAM SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND SOK SHEAVES OF
BARLEY A MEMBER OF IMPROVE THE
DREAM AND THE STUDENT AT SON WHO
SENT STATE UNIVERSITY CENTER
COURTESY. THANK YOU SENATOR TO
RAZA. IVERSON HA ARE YOU HERE GO
AHEAD AND START. YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES. HELLO MY NAME'S EVA
SAID HAT AND A RECENT GRADUATE
OF UC SANTA BARBARA. I'M ALSO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIAISON
WITH THE DREAM AND NATIONAL
YOUTH LED ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS AND ADVOCATES FOR
CHILDREN OF LONG TERM VISA
HOLDERS ALSO KNOWN AS DACA
DREAMERS. TODAY I'M REPRESENTING
OVER FORTY THOUSAND DOCUMENTED
DEALERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I FIVE EIGHT SEVEN I
IMMIGRATED WITH MY FAMILY
ALONGSIDE MY TWIN SISTER FROM
INDIA SAN FRANCISCO. GOING UP IN
THE STREETS OF RICHMOND DISTRICT
I HAD A FAIRLY NORMAL AMERICAN
CHILDHOOD AS I AND I UNDERSTOOD
MYSELF AS AMERICAN EVERY SENSE
BUT ON PAPER. LITTLE DID I KNOW
THAT MY ADULTHOOD BEING GROSSED
FROM IMMIGRATION STATUS WHICH
WILL LEAD TO UNQUANTIFIABLE
EMOTIONAL AND FINANCIAL BURDENS
. WHATEVER TO GET INTO UCSB I
WAS CONSIDERED AN INTERNATIONAL
STUDENT AND WAS WITHOUT ACCESS
TO CRUCIAL A SUGGEST FASTER
PROGRAMS FEDERAL AND PRIVATE
LOANS. MY FAMILY WAS BURDENED
WIH TWICE THE FINANCIAL COST
BETWEEN MY SISTER AND I. SO MY
PARENTS TOOK A PRIVATE LOAN
AGAINST THEIR HOME EQUITY THE
STAFF COSTS AND CHARLIE BY LACK
OF AID SO MY FAMILY BACK BY
YEARS. I FELT CONFUSED AS GET
PAY TAXES THE CONTRIBUTED
DIRECTLY STATE FINANCIAL AID
BUDGETS AND EVEN MORE CONFUSED
RIGHT CURRENT PLIGHT CALIFORNIA
ACT. SOLELY BECAUSE I WAS NOT
UNDOCUMENTED. UCSB'S FINANCIAL
AID OFFICE EVEN RECOMMENDED THAT
I WOULD LET MY STAFF WENT OUT
AND BECOME UNDOCUMENTED IN ORDER
TO QUALIFY. LATER I LEARNED I
WOULD AGE OUT ASIA TWENTY ONE
AND COULD FACE UP DEPORTATION. I
TOOK MY COURSE WORK I SPENT A
YEAR WITH IMMIGRATION LAW AND
TALKING TO LEAVE OFFICIALS. TO
ENSURE I CAN CONTINUE MY
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA. MY ONLY
HOPE. I SWITCHED TO AN
INTERNATIONAL STUDENT VISA I
MANAGE SECURE IN STATE TUITION
ICSE. EVERY EVERY YEAR FIVE TO
TEN THOUSAND COLLEGE AGE
DOCUMENTARIES ON IS THAT THE- AS
ARE OFTEN QUITE TO PAY OUR STATE
TUITION WHEN THEY- ACQUIRE A- F.
ONE VISA. I'M ASKING COMMITTEE
TODAY TO LEAVE EARLY SOME OF THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN THE ACCESS TO
IN STATE TUITION AND EIGHT.
COMMITTEE SHOULD KNOW THAT NOTE
THAT SB ELEVEN SIXTY AS AMENDED.
DOES NOT MEAN TO EQUITY AS IT
WILL LIMIT THE SCOPE OF BENEFITS
COMPARED TO THE CURRENT EIGHTY
FIVE FORTY POPULATION. TO BRING
TO EQUITY DOCUMENT INDIVIDUALS
WHO OTHERWISE MAY REQUIREMENTS
IF YOU EQUAL BENEFITS. THEY'RE
HAVING TO CONSIDER THIS IN THE
OFFICE I SPOKE WITH A BENEFIT.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY FOR A SENSE
OF REGARDLESS SB SIX IS AMENDED
IT'S A GREAT PREVENT THAT WOULD
BENEFIT THOUSANDS URGED ME TO
PASS TODAY. ALSO DOCUMENTED AND
UNDOCUMENTED OKEY CLUB TT TO
ACCESS COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND NEXT UP IS. SUCK
SHEETS. OF OLLIE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AS WELL. HELLO MY NAME
IS SAKSHI FILING AND THE CURRENT
SENIOR STUDYING MOLECULAR
BIOLOGY AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY. I AM ALSO A DOCUMENT
A DREAMER AND A MEMBER OF
IMPROVE BETWEEN. MY BIRTHPLACE
IS MUMBAI INDIA THE CITY I CALL
HOME IS CENTER MON CALIFORNIA. I
WAS BORN IN INDIA IN TWO
THOUSAND BUT MOVED TO THE BAY
AREA IN TWO THOUSAND NINE. I
HAVE BEEN LIVING IN THE BAY AREA
AND I'VE GONE TO ELEMENTARY
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
SAME COMMUNITY FOR OVER TEN
YEARS. IN HIGH SCHOOL ONE ALL MY
FRIENDS WERE BEGINNING THEIR
FIRST JOBS OR INTERNSHIPS. I WAS
LEFT WONDERING HOW TO GET BACK
TO MY COMMUNITIES IN WAYS THAT
DON'T REQUIRE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER WHICH IS A LUXURY TO
DEPENDENT VISA STUDENTS. AT
NINETEEN AND IT WAS WITH. SINCE
I BEGAN APPLYING TO COLLEGES.
THE TIME CAME TO DECIDE WHERE TO
START THE NEXT PHASE OF MY
ACADEMIC JOURNEY. I HAVE TO
CONSIDER THE SCHOOLS THAT WERE
WILLING TO ACCEPT ME AS A
DOMESTIC STUDENTS. AND CHARGE ME
IN STATE. NONE OF MY FRIENDS.
WORRIES NONE OF THE- SEMINAR I
ATTEND AS A HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR.
ADVICE FOR STUDENTS ON DEPENDENT
VISAS. MY VISA STATUS WAS NOT
ENOUGH FOR ME TO QUALIFY FOR
FASTER AND MANY SCHOLARSHIPS.
BUT I WAS OVER QUALIFIED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT AND
PROGRAM. BECAUSE I WAS NOT
UNDOCUMENTED. LIKE MOST FAMILIES
MONEY IS AN IMPORTANT FACTOR
WHEN CONSIDERING UNIVERSITIES
ACROSS ALL THE SCHOOLS THAT I
APPLY TO IN CALIFORNIA MOST OF
THEM CONSIDERED ME AS AN
INTERNATIONAL STUDENT AND
APPLIED THOSE HIGHER FEES. I
CHOSE TO GO TO ASSIST YOU AS IT
WAS ONE OF THE SCHOOLS I WAS
WILLING TO CHARGE ME RESIDENT
THESE WHICH IS MUCH MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR MY FAMILY.
HOWEVER AS AN H. FOUR DEPENDENT
VISA HOLDER ASIAN OF STATUS WHEN
I TURNED TWENTY ONE AND MY ONLY
OPTION WAS TO TRANSITION TO AN
F. ONE IN ORDER TO STAND STATUS.
MY SCHOOL NOW CONSIDERS ME AN
INTERNATIONAL STUDENT AND IS
CHARGING ME HIGHER FEES. NOW I
PLAN TO ATTEND GRADUATE SCHOOL
AT THE SAME UNIVERSITY AND I
WILL BE REQUIRED TO PAY OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FEES. MY STATUS
IRONICALLY IF I WERE TO LOSE MY
DOCUMENT IS. ONLY WOULD I BE
ELIGIBLE. TUITION IT ALSO GRANTS
MY STATE. TODAY I AM ASKING FOR
THE LAW TO BE CHANGED FOR
STUDENTS LIKE ME BECAUSE
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT BE CHARGED
INTERNATIONAL FEES TO ATTEND
SCHOOL.
I IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT. FOR SB ELEVEN SIXTY.
YOU CAN SUPPORTIVE SB ELEVEN
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL START
ONE EIGHTY SIX SO I HAD. OKAY
THEY WERE IN THERE ONE MOMENT.
IF I HAD. NINE ONE EIGHTY SIX.
HELLO YES MY NAME IS RAVI GOOD
SIDE- THE MEMORABLE- THE GROUP
OF PEOPLE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
IT YOU COULD- SIXTY. THANK YOU
AND THAT WE HAVE LINED ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS J. SRI
RAMA MOORTHY GUIDE THREE I AM A
MEMBER OF INCLUDES THE DREAM AND
I SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SIXTY. NEXT
WE HAVE LINED ONE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS THREE RUSSIA AND I'M
A MEMBER OF THE GROUP THE DREAM
AND A STUDENT I UC BERKELEY I AM
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SIXTY. THANK YOU. NEXT HEADLINE
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I AM WHERE SHE AND I
BACKGROUND- WHAT THE DREAM AND
I'M GOING SUPPORT OF. FIFTY ONE
SIX FIFTY. WE HAVE LINED ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DEV SIMON THERE
OF IMPROVE THE DREAM AND I MEAN
FOR AT SB. ELEVEN ONE SEVEN
SIXTY. NEXT WE HAVE LINED ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME THE
OCULUS AND I'M IN FAVOR OF-
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINED ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MD
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA I AM A
MEMBER OF FOR INCLUDING ON THE
I. SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SIXTY.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE NINE ONE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS PROMOTION AND I
AM A MEMBER OF A GROUP OF THREE
AND A SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SIXTY.
NEXT HEADLINE ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO OF MONEY
BECAUSE THE MEMBER FROM THE
GREEN A SUPPORT AT THE ONE ONE
SIX DEAR. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE
HAVE LINED ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
BRIAN I AM A MEMBER OF IMPROVE
THE DREAM AND I SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN SIXTY. AND I HAVE NO
NOTHING TO FEAR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY WE HAVE NO ONE IN LEAD
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE
MADAME MODERATOR WE WILL GO TO
YOU COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN SIXTY. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN SIXTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. HAND ONE MOMENT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH BY LAW
THIS CAN OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU METAMODEL WRITER
ALRIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SEEING
NONE CENTER GLAZER YOUR WORK IN
THE ROOM WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
IF YOU WANT TO SAY SOMETHING YOU
HAVE A QUESTION. I'M ASKING.
THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA I WAS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AN ELEMENT
OF THE BILL THAT WAS UNCLEAR TO
ME- IN THE TESTIMONY FIRST OF
ALL I'VE BEEN A BIG SUPPORTER OF
THE DREAM ACT AND- PROVIDING
THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR. THAT THAT
CLASSIFICATION WHICH WE HAVE
ENACTED AND IT'S A WONDERFUL ONE
WHAT WHERE I'M STRUGGLING WITH
ON THIS BILL IS THAT DICK THAT
TESTIMONY HAS BEEN ABOUT LONG
TERM. AS IDENTS GROWN UP HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S CERTAINLY THE
WONDERFUL SPEAKERS THAT WE HEARD
A FEW MINUTES AGO VERY
ARTICULATE- ABOUT THEIR OWN
CIRCUMSTANCE AND HOW LONG THEY
HAVE BEEN HERE. BUT I I'M TRYING
TO MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND THE
BILL. THE ELIGIBILITY ELEMENTS
IN REGARD TO TIME SPENT IN THE
STATE. I CERTAINLY AGREE THAT-
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN HERE A LONG
TIME UNDEFINED. FAMILY PAYING
TAXES THAT THAT THIS IS A- A
PATHWAY WE SHOULD PROVIDE EVERY
YOU KNOW EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE FOR. AND I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE POTENTIAL IS NOT
ANYTHING I'M SURE THE AUTHOR
ONCE OR ANY OF US WANT. BUT THE
PENT POTENTIAL FOR SOME VIEWS.
OF A ISN'T- HENCE OF DIAPERS
QUESTION WOULD BE- IN REGARD TO
HOW THE HELL TIME IS DEFINED IN
THIS BILL IN TERMS TO BE
ELIGIBLE UNDER THE PROVISIONS.
YES THEY WOULD HAVE TO SATISFY
OF THE CURRENT REQUIREMENTS- TO
ESTABLISH THE- IN STATE TUITION.
AND THERE'S- IN THE- IN THE
ANALYSIS OF THERE'S A WHOLE
EXPLANATION OF THE SATISFACTION
OF THE REQUIREMENTS- AND IT IS
THREE OR MORE. YEARS IF YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THE TIME FRAME BUT
THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD APPLY
TO ANYBODY. RIGHT LONG AS YOU
HAVE THREE YEARS AND YOU MEET
AND THOSE OTHER REQUIREMENTS
IT'S NOT JUST THAT THREE YEARS
BUT IT'S- THREE YEARS PLUS THESE
OTHER REQUIREMENTS. SO IF YOU
LIVE IN COLORADO AND YOU CAME
HERE. THAT WOULD BE THE SAME
THING- IN OTHER WORDS THIS IS
WHAT THIS IS WHAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR AB FIVE
FORTY THAT WOULD APPLY TO
ANYBODY REGARDLESS OF WHERE THAT
CAME FROM. SO I'M I'M OF. IN ANY
. BUTENE THAT WE DO WE WANTED TO
MEET THE SAME STANDARDS AND NOT
CHANGE THE STANDARD. OKAY
BECAUSE WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
IF- YOUR FAMILY A AN AFFLUENT
FAMILY FROM OUT OF THE COUNTRY-
THE POVISIONS OF YOUR BILL AS
YOU PROPOSE IT THAT YOU'D BE
ABLE TO COME TO CALIFORNIA AND
AS LONG AS YOU WERE HERE FOR
THREE YEARS AND UNDER UP A BILL
THAT I THINK I VOTED FOR EARLIER
THIS YEAR WOULD MOVE IT DOWN TO
TWO YEARS BUT- YOU WOULD THEN
GET THAT SUBSTANTIAL FINANCIAL
BREAK I MEAN THAT WITH YOURS-
CHILD SAID TO USE D. I BELIEVE
THE BREAK OUT OF THAT THEY GET
UNDER UNDER. THESE PROVISIONS IS
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
LESS IN TUITION SO IF YOU CAME
HERE FOR TWO YEARS OR THREE
YEARS CENTER FIVE FORTY. YOU
COULD BE SAVING YOURSELF EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS BY MAKING THAT
MOVE TO CALIFORNIA THAT THAT'S
MY READING OF IT UNDER WHAT YOU
HAVE TOLD ME THAT TO MY MIND
UNDERSTAND THAT WRONG. WELL-
OKAY THANK YOU YEAH PLEASE
PROCEED SO- THE KERN AB FIVE
FORTY WILL STATES YOU'D HAVE TO
HAVE THREE YEARS OF HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION- IN CALIFORNIA OR- FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE EDUCATION SO IT'S NOT
JUST THREE YEARS LIVING IN THE
STATE IS DID YOU GRADUATE FROM
HIGH CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL. AND
RIGHT NOW IF YOU DON'T HAVE
STAFF. ANY GUY WHO CATHOLIC HIGH
SCHOOL YOU ELIGIBLE. FOR IN SITU
ALL THIS IS THIS WOULD ADDING A
- YOU HAVE A STATUS YOU DID
GRADUATE FROM CATHOLIC HIGH
SCHOOL. AND NOW I WOULD BE LYING
TO PAY IN STATE TUITION. RIGHT
SO OF BASED ON YOUR TESTIMONY
THAT THAT WOULD MEAN THAT YOU
STILL HAVE TO ENROLL YOUR CHILD
IN THE SCHOOL EXACTLY TO MEET
THE TEST. METHOD AND MAYBE OUR
CONSULTANT MENTOR THE ANSWER
THIS AND THAT AFFECTING OTHERS
TOO. BUT A TO ESTABLISH
RESIDENCY IN OUR STATE TODAY-
AND BE ELIGIBLE FOR IN STATE
TUITION IS AT A SINGLE YEAR IF
YOU ESTABLISH RESIDENCY. YES I'M
HEARING A YES FROM THE
CONSULTANT SO. REALLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A CLASSIFICATION
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT. SEEN AS
RESIDENTS CITIZENRY RESIDENTS
RIGHT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO FIVE
THREAD THE NEEDLE THROUGH- AND-
SO THAT'S A PART OF THE BILL
THAT HAS ME A LITTLE A LITTLE
CONCERNED THAT ABILITY FOR IT TO
BE EXPLOITED I THINK THAT YOUR
GOALS ARE ADMIRABLE. AND HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT. THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE USED IN THE RIGHT
WAY AND THAT'S WHAT I'M STILL
STRUGGLING. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS CENTER DOLLY I WASN'T
GOING TO ASK A QUESTION BUT YOUR
COMMENT ABOUT OUT OF STATE. SO
HOW DOES THAT RELATE TO WHAT
SENATOR GLAZERS ASKING ABOUT THE
ONE YEAR. TUITION BREAK. WELL
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S
AN OUT OF STATE PERSON. OF WOULD
BE WE HAVE TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AB FIVE FORTY
AND EIGHTY FIVE FORTY SAYS THREE
OR MORE YEARS OF FULL TIME
ATTENDANCE. OF CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOLS YOU KNOW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL. RIGHT.
DOES THAT THAT'S ONLY IF THERE.
NONCITIZEN IF THEY WERE IF THEY
WERE A CITIZEN. IT'S ONE YEAR
RIGHT NOW CORRECT. YOU'RE
WELCOME ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER TROUBLE SO I
JUST WANTED TO LET IS IT EVEN.
NOW UCSB GRADUATE SO YES GO
CHARACTERS ON THAT AND JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT BUT I AM- SO I SHARE
THE SAME CONCERNS I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO YOU DECIDE
WHAT THE- PROPER- I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT I
THINK. THE CONCERN IS THAT MY
COLLEAGUES ARE ASKING IS.
THEY'RE VERY FAIR- I ACTUALLY
SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS YES WE
DO WANT TO MAKE IT- EKEROT GONNA
HAVE PURITY- BUT WHEN YOU'RE- A
HIGH SCHOOL YOU KNOW. ONE A
RESIDENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SOMEONE THAT MOVES FROM OUT OF
STATE- SOMEONE WHO HAS A VISA
RESIDENT VERSUS THE NON THE LAST
THING I WANT TO SEE AN IN KIND
OF CURIOUS THAT THEY TOLD YOU TO
EXPIRE OF YOU SAID BEFORE YOU
KNOW SO THAT YOU CAN GET IN
STATE WE DON'T WANT TO PROMOTE.
YOU KNOW. ILLEGAL YOU KNOW- OUT
BALANCING COMPONENT SO. I I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THE DIFFERENCE IS
BUT I THINK. AS FAR AS YOU KNOW
WHO DECIDES WHAT. TIME IS TO
ACCOMMODATE THE FINANCIAL-
BENEFITS THAT MAKES IT YOU KNOW
PRETTY. FARE BETWEEN A CITIZEN
SOMEONE WHO IS- IN IMMIGRANT OR
MIGRANT TO THE TO THIS COUNTRY
AND WHEN THAT COMES THROUGH THE
VISA AND SO FORTH BUT- I THINK
IT'S THREE YEARS YOU SAID FOR
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES TO YEARS
OF. COLLEGE A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND THEN IF YOU'RE A US CITIZEN
COMING FROM OUT OF STATE IT'S
ONE YEAR CORRECT SO YOU'RE STILL
PAYING KIND OF A LITTLE BIT
MORE. IN GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN I
AM I'M JUST GONNA HERE'S TO KNOW
WHAT THE THOUGHTS ARE OF MY
COLLEAGUES AS FAR AS- DO THEY
FEEL THAT THAT SET A FAIR. MAKE
UP THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS.
YEAH I MET YEARS I'M AM I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
KEEPING IT MOVING- SENATORS RAZA
THAT WHAT I WORRY ABOUT IS THE
EXPERT IN BY SOME WEALTHY FOLKS
FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY AND THE
PALACES TALKS A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHERE ARE ARE STILL STUDENTS ARE
COMING FROM BUT- THAT. USE
VISIONS THIS ULTRA REALLY
EXPLAIN SYSTEM. OF ADD TO THE
NOT THE EMPIRE FOLKS DINO HE
CARED ABOUT WE ALL CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT THE THESE ARE POTENTIALLY.
AFFLUENT FAMILIES THAT ARE GOING
TO JUST TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
TYPE OF A PROVISION. TO GET A
VISA COME HERE HAD. HAVE TO
ENROLL THEIR KIDS IN IN SCHOOL
FOR TWO OR THREE YEARS AND THEN
GET THAT ENORMOUS FINANCIAL
BREAK. THAT THAT'S WHAT WORRIES
ME ABOUT THE BILL OKAY AND I'M
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO KEEP IT
MOVING BUT I HOPE THAT YOU LOOK
AT THAT. AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT THAT PROVIDE THAT.
SORT OF ABUSE BY THOSE WHO HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO PAY THE FULL
FREIGHT. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE THAT WAS A FATHER MY
MIND AS WELL. WHEN WE CONSIDER
THIS AND ONE- THE YOUNG. MEN AND
WOMEN CAME TO MEDIATE ABOUT THIS
THAT WAS A CONCERN OF MINE-
BECAUSE THAT. THE BEFORE IS THAT
THEY WERE REALLY- LOW INCOME
UNDOCUMENTED LIVING HERE ALL
THEIR LIVES- SO IN CONSIDERING
THIS I ALSO BEGAN TO GET INTO
THE WEEDS A LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW
THERE'S TWENTY TWO CLASSES OF
MISSION IMMIGRATION ADMISSIONS
INTO THIS COUNTRY IT'S EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED AND THIS GROUP AND
BELIEVE ME YOU KNOW THEY OF.
BECAUSE THEY A FULL I'M CLASSIC
. BUT THEY ALSO DON'T WANT TO BE
SEEN AS OKAY HERE ARE OF WEALTHY
PEOPLE COMING INTO THIS COUNTRY
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR EDUCATE
. THAT'S NOT ARE ALL ABOUT-
SOUL. WE AGREED TO THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT REALLY NARROWED
IT DOWN TO JUST A FEW OF THE
CLASSIFICATIONS AND AT AND YOU
KNOW THEY BELIEVE. ARE AS THEY
SHOULD THAT THERE ARE FAR FAR
MORE MANY STUDENTS WHOSE
FAMILIES ARE HERE WORK HARD
REALLY CONTRIBUTING BUT JUST
STUCK IN THIS TERRIBLE TERRIBLE
PLATE IN THE IN THE IMMIGRATION
LAWS. WE DID OF ON THE
COMMITTEE'S ADVICE WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WE NARROWED IT DOWN.
JUST LIFE SO I BELIEVE THAT WITH
THIS WE'VE CAPTURED BASED ON THE
VISAS THAT WE SELECTED- AND THAT
THEY HAVE TO BE DEPENDENT- HAVE
DEPENDENT VISAS THAT. IT'S A
REASONABLE IT'S A GOOD THING TO
DO AND IT'S NOT OPENING IT UP TO
EVERYBODY TO EXPLOIT AND THEY
HAVE TO WORK WHILE THEY'RE HERE
THEIR PARENTS DO ANYWAY. THANK
YOU CENTER DRIVE CENTER- DOLLY
SO I WAS PREPARED TO VOTE
AGAINST YOUR BILL AND SINCE
THERE'S BEEN SOME GREAT DEBATE
I'M ONLY OFTEN TRY TO LEARN A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT. WHAT WAS
ACTUALLY HAVING. I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S- LOOK IF YOU'RE PAYING
IN YOUR WORKING CALIFORNIA I
THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT WE SHOULD. YOU KNOW IT
CONTINUE THAT BUT IF YOU'RE ABLE
TO SO I MEAN ANYWAY I'M GONNA
LAY OFF A YOUR BILL WHAT IS IT
BY WE WERE IS IT IS GOING
STRAIGHT APPROPRIATIONS AND THEN
TO THE FLOOR. IT IS- BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS YEAH. WELCOME
OKAY ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ALL RIGHT BEFORE I ASK
YOU TO CLOSE SENATOR ALSO I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT I THINK IT'S
ALWAYS A WORRY AND THEY'RE
ALWAYS PEOPLE THAT WOULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF. ANY SITUATION BUT
WE CAN'T WORRY ABOUT. A FEW
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT TAKE ADVANTAGE
THE SITUATION WE WERE
POTENTIALLY GOING TO HELP
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS. OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE THE
MEANS TO GO TO COLLEGE MANY
YEARS AGO WE OPENED A FOOD
PANTRY. AT MY LOCAL UNION THAT I
RAN AND I TOLD THE STAFF I SAID.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE 5% WHO ARE
GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
SYSTEM WORRY ABOUT THE 95% OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE HELPING
EVERY DAY BY FEEDING THEM. SO I
WOULD JUST GIVE THAT AS AN
EXAMPLE WE WOULD LIKE NO ONE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ANY SITUATION
EVER. BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S
JUST NOT LIFE FOR ME I LOOK AT
THE BIGGER PICTURE. THAT WILL BE
HELPING REALLY NEEDY STUDENTS
AND DISTRICT DESERVING STUDENTS.
OF THAT SURPRISE I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE WELL I PRETTY THE
CONVERSATION I THINK THEIR EXACT
. THE ISSUE WE HAD TO DROP WITH
OLD. I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THEM
UP AND IF THERE'S A WAY OF. A
SCENE THE- WE WILL. TO DO THE
BUT- I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
OPEN. AT SENATE WE WILL HAVE.
BUT YOU MIGHT WITH SOME OF THE
STUDENTS SO YOU CAN. IT EVEN
BETTER THANK YOU ALL AND URGENT.
HE DID WE HAVE A MOTION. SIR OF.
THE K. CENTER. AZ OR DID YOU
MOVE. BUT ACCORDING THE MOVE
BILL. MAN COULD. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM. FOUR SB HELLO
SIX. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON A PER.
PATIENTS LEYVA. I SHOW ABOVE HI
THE TROUBLED HI COURTESY.
COURTESY I DALY. GLAZER THESE
ARE ALL RIGHT MCGUIRE PAN. VERY
GOOD WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
ALTHOUGH DOES HAVE ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WILL BE A FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS
UP EVERYONE YOU'RE VERY WELCOME
UP NEXT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
THE SENATOR CABALLERO S. B.
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB THIRTEEN
OH EIGHT RICHARD SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. AND PROTECT CALIFORNIA
JOBS BY CLARIFYING AND
STRENGTHENING BUY AMERICAN
POLICIES FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGE MEAL PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY IS THE LARGEST IN THE
COUNTRY AND PRODUCES MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED DIFFERENT
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITIES. OVER
ONE THIRD OF THE COUNTRY'S
VEGETABLES. AND TWO THIRDS OF
THE COUNTRY'S FRUITS AND NUTS.
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WORK IN CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY. IN THE-
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY FROM
FARMERS FARMWORKERS TO WORKERS
IN FOOD PROCESSING AND
CANNERIES. UNION JOBS IN
CALORIES IN FRUIT PROCESSING
PROVIDE GOOD WAGES BENEFITS AND
RETIREMENT SECURITY TO HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF WORKERS. WE HAVE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST LABOR
STANDARDS AND WORKER PROTECTIONS
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO ORGANIZE.
CALIFORNIA AND U. S. GROWN
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES ARE
PRODUCED UNDER THE STRICTEST
REGULATIONS TO ENSURE FOOD
SAFETY. REDUCES ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS CAREFULLY MANAGE
PESTICIDE USE. AND CONSERVE OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES. THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH ACT INCLUDES BUY
AMERICAN PROVISIONS THAT REQUIRE
THE SCHOOL FOOD AUTHORITIES THE
SFA'S. TO PURCHASE DOMESTIC
PRODUCTS TO SERVE MEALS IN
SCHOOLS TO. THE BILL AND- D. A.
REGULATIONS SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN
BYPASS THE EXISTING BUY AMERICAN
REQUIREMENT AND PURCHASE
IMPORTED FOOD PRODUCTS IF THEY
BELIEVE THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
COST DIFFERENTIAL NOTS THAT
LANGUAGE IN THE IN THE BILL.
BETWEEN DOMESTIC AND IMPORTED
FOOD PRODUCTS PRODUCTS HOWEVER
IT THERE'S NO DEFINITION OF WHAT
SIGNIFICANT COST DIFFERENTIAL
MEANS THAT ALLOWS THE SCHOOL TO
BYPASS THIS REQUIREMENT. EIGHT
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REVIEW OF
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAMS BY THE
STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT MOST OF
THE SIX SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
THEY REVIEWED HAD ADEQUATE
POLICY HAD INADEQUATE POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES TO DOCUMENT
DISCOUNT. DIFFERENTIAL ALL SIX
HAD PURCHASED FOREIGN SEUSS
SOURCED FOOD ITEMS BUT DID NOT
HAVE THE DOCUMENTATION TO
JUSTIFY THEIR PURCHASES
NATIONALLY OVER 80% OF THE APPLE
JUICE PURCHASE PURCHASED BY
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IS FROM CHINA.
AND 60% 62806270% OF THE FISH
STICKS SERVED IN SCHOOLS AND YOU
REMEMBER FIFTY FISH STICKS IT
SCHOOLS I'M SUREARE MADE. YOU
ARE MADE FISH ON RUSSIAN BESCH
VESSELS AND PROCESS IN CHINA.
SCHOOLS IN MORE THAN HALF THE
COUNTRY ALSO HAVE PURCHASED
CHINESE CANNED PEACHES AND WE
GROW PEACHES RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AS A RESULT OF THE
BUY AMERICAN LAXITY CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS PURCHASE LOWER QUALITY
FOODS PRODUCED UNDER LESS
STRINGENT WORKER HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS DESPITE
LIVING IN THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL REGION OF THE
WORLD. THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
HAS FELT THE IMPACT OF OVERSEAS
COMPETITION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SENECA FOODS A PRODUCER OF PEACH
AND FRUIT COCKTAIL PRODUCTS
SHUTTERED ITS MODESTO PLANT
PERMANENTLY LAYING OFF TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE FULL TIME
WORKERS. AND ONE THOUSAND
SEASONAL WORKERS THE COMPANY
CITED IMPORT COMPETITION FROM
OVERSEAS CHINA AND EUROPE AS A
REASON FOR THE PLANT CLOSURE IN
THIS HAD A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON
THE COMMUNITY. SB THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT WILL CLARIFIED AND
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S BY
AMERICAN POLICY BY URGING ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES. TO
PURCHASE THE PRODUCTS GROWN
PACKAGED OR PROCESSED IN THE
UNITED STATES UNLESS THE PRICE
OF THE FOREIGN PRODUCT IS MORE
THAN 25% CHEAPER. SB THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT DOES NOT MANDATE WHAT KIND
OF PROJECTS SCHOOLS MUCH MUST
PURCHASE ONLY THAT THE PRODUCTS
ARE MADE IN THE UNITED STATES
THE BILL PROVIDE SCHOOLS THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO ADJUST MENUS AND
PROCUREMENT TO AVOID INCREASED
COSTS AND GIVE THEM A SAFETY
VALVE VALVE IF THERE IS NO
ALTERNATIVE AFFORDABLE DOMESTIC
PRODUCT AVAILABLE. THIS UP BUY
AMERICAN POLICIES ENSURE
CHILDREN CONSUME FOOD OF THE
HIGHEST QUALITY AND SAFETY IT'S
REFLECTIVE OF OUR VALUES BY
SUPPORTING LOCAL FARMERS JOBS
AND THE ECONOMY AS WELL IT IS
REINFORCING CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT. AS A WORLD LEADER ON
CLIMATE CHANGE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFEGUARDS AND LABOR PROTECTION
SO I KNOW THAT THE STAKE.
HOLDERS HAVE RAISED SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES- ABOUT THE BILL
AND HOW IT WORKS AND I
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK AND THE
SCHOOL NUTRITION DIRECTORS IN
WORK WORKERS DO EVERY DAY TO
FEED. OUR KIDS HEALTHY AND
NOURISHING MEALS M. NO THAT I
CAN I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS NOT
OVER OVERLY BURDENSOME- AND-
CONTINUED AT TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND I WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE THERE IS SOME. CONCERN
EXPRESSED AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT
- WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. IS
ADAM GROW FOR THE PAST BECAUSE
PRODUCERS. HE IS HERE IN PER AS
IT ACTUALLY OF RADO FOR THAT
TEAMS UNION LOW ACTS. ACTUALLY
IS ON ON THE PHONE TEAMSTERS
UNION LOCAL. EIGHT FIFTY SIX THE
FOOD PROCESSING PROCESSING
DIVISION DIRECTOR AND SECRETARY
TREASURER OF THE TEAMSTERS
CANNERY COUNCIL. THANK YOU
CENTER CABALLERO ALL RIGHT MR
SCHROEPFER GOING TO GO TO YOU
FIRST YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. FOR
LABOR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I'M
ADAM STROKE DIRECTOR OF EMPLOYEE
AND LABOR RELATIONS AT PACIFIC
COAST PRODUCERS. BOARD CHAIR
PRODUCERS ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA
AND CO CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNING INDUSTRY LABOR
MANAGEMENT COOPERATION COMMITTEE
. BECAUSE PRODUCERS AS A FARMERS
COOPERATIVE THE PACKAGES ARE
CANS CALIFORNIA GROWN PRODUCE
FROM ELEVEN COUNTIES IN SEVEN
STATE SENATE DISTRICTS THE
COOPERATIVE IS A MEMBER OF
PRODUCERS ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA
AND- SEE ASIAN THAT REP. GOOD
PRODUCERS ON LABOR SPECIFIC
ISSUES. I'M HERE TODAY TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR S. B.
THIRTEEN AWAIT BY SENATOR
SENATOR CABALLERO THE BILL
CLARIFIES BY AMERICAN COMPLAINTS
BY RESTRICTING PUBLIC SCHOOLS
FROM PURCHASING AGRICULTURAL
FOOD PRODUCTS NOT GROWN OR
PACKED DOMESTICALLY UNLESS THE
COST OF THE NON DOMESTIC PRODUCT
IS MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. LOWER THAN THE PRICE OF
THE DAY. AS AN EXAMPLE FOR THIS
BILL. TWO LARGE FRUIT CANNERIES
IN KINGSBURG AND MODESTO
EMPLOYING THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS CLOSED IN THE PAST
DECADE CITING IMPORT COMPETITION
AS A PRIMARY REASON. INDEED IN
REAL VOLUME PERCENTAGE OF
IMPORTED FOOD SERVICE CANNED
PEACHES HAS BEEN AS HIGH AS 40%
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY IS MEETING EXCEPTIONAL
STANDARDS TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF WORKERS PROVIDE
FARE A COMPETITIVE OMPENSATION
ENSURE FOOD SAFETY REDUCE WATER
USE BOOST ENERGY EFFICIENCY
FULLY MANAGE PESTICIDE USE AND
IMPLEMENT CLIMATE SMART AG
PRACTICES. SB THIRTEEN AWAIT
REFLECTS THESE CALIFORNIA VALUES
BY. DOLLAR TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
PURCHASE FOOD PRODUCTS WHICH
MEET THESE HIGH STANDARDS IT
DOES NOT PREVENT THE PURCHASE OF
FOREIGN SOURCED FOOD. RATHER IT
WILL ENSURE BY AMERICAN
COMPLAINTS FOR UP 225% A 25%
COST DIFFERENTIAL. INDUSTRY
EXPERIENCE EVEN PRE PANDEMIC HAS
SHOWN THE ANYTHING BELOW THAT
THRESHOLD IS NOT ENOUGH TO AVOID
DISPROPORTIONATE PURCHASE OF
FOREIGN SOURCED FOOD. FOR THESE
REASONS I URGE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO HELP STRENGTHEN BUY AMERICAN
PROCUREMENT POLICIES AND SERVE
AS A MODEL FOR OTHER STATES TO
FOLLOW BY SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE I THANK SENATOR
CABALLERO. WELL AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES MADAM MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN PLEASE QUEUE UP MS
ASHLEY ALVA RADO AND SHE MAY
TESTIFY FOR TWO MINUTES AS WELL. AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU ARE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LEYVA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND I THINK YOU ARE
SENATOR PUBLIC YET- FOR OUTDOOR
UNIT IS VERY IMPORTANT BILL. MY
NAME IS ASHLEY ALVARADO AND I AM
THE LOCALLY FIVE SIX COMPOSITES
AND DIVISION DIRECTOR AND THE
SECRETARY TREASURER OF THE
TEAMSTERS CANNERY COUNSEL
REPRESENTING TEN THOUSAND UNION
MEMBERS IN CALORIES IN
CALIFORNIA. MISTER MEMBERS
PREPARE IN CAMP PEACHES PEARS
AND OTHER FOODS TO PUT ON
GROCERY STORES. THE THIRD IN
SCHOOL MAY. UNION JOBS IMPROVE
PROFITS PROVIDE GOOD MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS WITH HEALTH COVERAGE
AND RETIREMENT SECURITY FOR
WORKERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA OUR
LOCAL WHO IS PART OF THE CANNERY
COUNCIL ALSO REPRESENTS
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WHO
SERVE MEALS TO STUDENTS IN WEST
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY DISTRICT
SCHOOL. THEY SEE EVERYTHING OF
TRICIA PROGRAMS FOR KIDS AND
THEIR FAMILIES CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS DESERVE THE HIGHEST
QUALITY FOOD IN THEIR SCHOOL
MEALS CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
FOLLOWS STRICT CAL GOOD CITY
SPEAK AND INVITED HIM. SEVEN HE
IS QUITE HIGH SCHOOLS. WHEN
SCHOOL IMPORTED PRODUCTS
STUDENTS ARE A GUARANTEE THE
SAME INPUTS SEE. THESE ARE THE
PROTECTION IN THE CANNERIES
SUPER PLANTS THAT ENSURE OUR
SHEETS HEALTH HEALTHY AND SAFE
SCHOOL. WHEN SCHOOLS BY CULTURAL
AND FOOD FROM FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES CALIFORNIA LOSES GOOD
UNION JOBS. FOREIGN OUTSOURCING
HURTS WORKERS AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT DEPEND ON THE
AGRICULTURE AND FOOD PROCESSING
INDUSTRIES TO SUPPORT LOCAL
ECONOMIES. SB THIRTEEN OH EIGHT
CLARIFIES AND STRENGTHENS
EXISTING BUY AMERICAN
REQUIREMENTS BY PROHIBITING
SCHOOLS FROM BUYING NON AMERICAN
PRODUCTS ON THIS THERE IS A 25%
OR MORE. PRICE DIFFERENTIAL.
DARKTRACE TOLD THANK YOU IF YOU
CAN WRAP UP PLANS SUPPORT JOB TO
IMPORTED PRODUCTS PRODUCTS WITH
YOUR LABOR HEALTH AND FOOD
SAFETY STANDARDS. NOBODY OF
MINISTRATION HEALTH NEEDS FOR
YOUR PASSION FOR TWO MINUTES IF
YOU COULD WRAP UP PLEASE. HE IS
A ORDER- HAPPENING IF
REQUIREMENTS THE R. AGENT BY.
THAT BEING SAID YOU DON'T HAVE
ACTIVE OF THE FEDERAL TO
STRAIGHTEN AMERICA FOR SCHOOL.
FOR THE REASONS I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
ARE YOU WILL COME BACK TO ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUH FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR SB THIRTEEN AWAIT. YOUR NAME
AND YOUR SOME. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TRISH
GARINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. HELLO KATHY MANZINI ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. GOOD AFTERNOON XIN GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THAT AND
SHARE MEMBER SERAPH LOCKS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CANNERY INDUSTRY
LABOR MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP-
COOPERATION COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT
. WELL SAID THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MADAME MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB. THIRTEEN OH EIGHT. SPEAKING
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT THIS PRESS ONE
THEN ON YOUR PHONE. AND ONE
MOMENT WE GET BY NUMBERS.
AND WE HAVE LINE TWO ZERO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBEKAH BACK IN BOMBAY
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FIRST THE FIFTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA APPLE BLUEBERRY
COMMISSION. IN A STATEMENT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. AND THAT IS
THE ONLY LINE I HAD IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEANT A MODERATOR
WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE HERE ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED WHO JUST TO OPPOSE
BILL. IN NO THAT'LL ROUTE TO YOU
. PLEASE ANYONE WHO WILL TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTY
EXCUSE ME SB THIRTEEN. YES WE
CAN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
ZERO EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HOW THE AND
ONE MOMENT WHILE I GET MY
NUMBERS.
THREE NINE WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
NOT ENSURING MEMBERS WE ENJOY
THE REALITY HAVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NUTRITION
ASSOCIATION THE ESTIMATED
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR STAFF
WHICH WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
BUT WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
GROUND FOR. A COUPLE. STRONG OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE SCHOOL ARE
PROGRAMS HOWEVER IN TO CHECK
ADDRESS THE ISSUE UNRELATED TO
MEAL SB THIRTY NO OUT I DON'T
THINK IT BUT NEGATIVE COMP. FOR
UP. THAT FEDERAL BY. ALL.
GROWERS WE FEED THEIR CHILDREN
AND THOSE THEIR INCOME WILL BE
THERE BEEN SIX ONE AND QUALITY
LOT OF THEIR BECAUSE WE RECEIVED
PROGRESS WEATHER AND PROCEDURE
WE MUST FIRST OUT OF OKAY THAT'S
WHY WE ARE TO THE BY THE COURT
YOU RECOGNIZED WITH CALL MEDICAL.
WHAT'S THE WEEK SOMETIMES DUE TO
A LACK OF TRANSPORT BUT THE
GENERAL ORDERS ARE FILLED WITH
WHAT IS AVAILABLE OR NOT AT ALL
THERE'S NO LOTUS ORCHARD MORE
REQUEST THAT YOU. WE MUST TO
MAKE BECAUSE BETTER FROM THE-
THANK YOU MISTER. JOURNAL OF
SOCIAL GOING SAID A CONSTANT. IS
DOUBLE. TO COPY FOR OF WITHOUT.
WELL THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE HAS
WE NEED AND- THREE DOLLARS AND
NOW NINE CENTS PER MEAL. THE
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE 25%
CHANGES TO RESTRICT THE LOCAL TO
ALL NON DOMESTIC PURCHASES. BUT
WOULD BE UNABLE TO PROVIDE BUILT
ON THE RECORD CALIFORNIA I'M
GOING YEAH. WHEN IT. THE DEBT.
BY THE LOCAL BUT WHAT AGENT FUND
THAT'S CREATING ADDITIONAL
BURDEN ON SCHOOL THE IS A FORM
WHILE IDENTIFICATION. FINALLY SB
THIRTY EIGHT FIVE FIVE ONE ON
MY- IMPLIED FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
WITH APPLY THE ADMINISTRATOR
WITH CONDUCTED OF EVERY L. YEAH
HOLD WE CAN'T. OR SBP IT ALREADY
SEVEN DAYS AND EXTREME OVER. THE
WEEK IN SEARCH OH EIGHT GREATLY
TO THE PER ON YOUR TAKING STAFF
AWAY YOU'RE AT TO ME. ONE IN
PLACE TO PREVENT A KNOWING TO.
WE IN CHANGING THE CONGRESS WITH
THE HELP OF THE EXHIBITION WE
BRING AN MOVED TO A NEW POSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE FOR CAN
WE HAVE TO THINK LINE TO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HERE WELL
NUMBER ONE. OF THE- CONVENTION
OR- ALONG WITH OF THE WITH THE
FIRST ON AND OFFICE ALL. WELL
YEAH THANK. AND I NO ONE IN. THE
YOU VERY MUCH MATAMATA WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE CA.
SENATE ALI. THANK YOU FOR
READING THIS ORDERNUMBER GIVE
YOU OFFER REALLY ME TO SOME OF
THE THAT TO PROVIDE UP IN THE-
PERSON IT WAS UP TO BUT I WANTED
TO SAY FOR. AS A WHO FARMS IN IS
REGULATE. IN CAL HEAVILY. THAT
WE PRODUCE THE SAFEST THE MOST
SECURE FOOD SOURCE IN THE WORLD
QUITE FRANKLY WE HAVE. A LOT OF
DIFFERENT VARIETIES AS WELL SO I
HAVE A HARD TIME MAKING IT- YOU
KNOW REPORTING IS GOING TO BE A
BETTER FOR OUR SCHOOLS THAN IT
IS TO BUY LOCAL AND TO SUPPORT
THOSE. FOLKS IN AG THAT TO. HAVE
TO PAY HIGHER COSTS FOR FUEL AND
HIGHER COSTS ELECTRICITY AND ALL
THOSE OTHER THINGS SO- I SUPPORT
THE BILL. I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
ADDRESS MAYBE SOME CONCERNS
IT'S- ABOUT TIMING BUT I AM
ASSUMING THAT WE RAISE ENOUGH
STUFF IN CALIFORNIA THAT MEETS
THE DEMANDS. THANK YOU CENTER
DOLLY WAS RESTING YOUR CALL A
COUPLE. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I CAN DO IT IN THE IN MY
CLOTHES OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
CENTRO CHOI BOGUE. THE SO. IN
MERRITT I ABSOLUTELY I MEAN I
SUPPORT THE BILL I THINK IT'S
GREAT THAT WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING
ON SOMETHING SIMILAR THAT HAS TO
DO WITH OTHER JUST DENTAL AND
LOCAL COMPANIES WHEN IT COMES
TO. OUR BASED COMPANIES ARE
WORKING CALIFORNIA FOR- THE VISA
. YOU KNOW UNDER THE CITY
EMERGENCY BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE
AS- SOMEONE WHO COMES WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE FACTORY- AND THEN VERY
SUPPORTER OF SMALL BUSINESSES IN
IN CALIFORNIA OUR CULTURE FOR MY
DISTRICT. JUST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT I. I BELIEVE IT I'M I'M
JUST KIND OF CURIOUS ABOUT- ONE
HOW DID WE COME UP THE 25%
BECAUSE WITH INFLATION AND
EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT
NOW. AT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT-
IMPACT IS THAT. IS THAT GOING TO
COVER ALL OF THE COST.
ASSOCIATED IN TRYING TO KEEP
EVERYTHING WITHIN CALIFORNIA AND
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH THAT
FIGURE AND NUMBER TWO. HOW HOW
WE STUDY OR HAVE HAS THERE BEEN
ANY FEEDBACK WITH REGARDS TO THE
IMPACT IT WILL HAVE WITH- OUR
ABILITY TO EXPORT. OUT PRODUCE
TO OTHER COUNTRIES AND- IN OTHER
STATES IF WE DO THIS AND
IMPLEMENT THIS BECAUSE IT'S-
SORT OF GOES ALONG WITH THE
NOTION OF THE SHOP LOCAL AND I
REMEMBER BACK YOU KNOW EIGHT OR
NINE. WE START HAVING ALL OF
THE- LOCAL CITIES ARE PROMOTING
SHOPPING OR NOT I ALL I COULD
THINK OF IN MY HEAD WILL FALL
SHOPPING LOCAL THEN YOU KNOW
WOULD. WITH IT WHEN YOU GO.
SPORTING COMMUNITIES AND IN SO
FORTH I WAS MORE OF A- HOW ABOUT
WE ALL JUST SHOP. AND WHO IN THE
IN THE REGION TO HELP ALL OF OUR
OUR COMMUNITY SO I'M JUST GONNA
TREES OF THE- OF. THE POTENTIAL
CONCERNS OF THE IMPACT IN OUR
ABILITY TO EXPORT. IF WE
IMPLEMENT SOMETHING OF THIS SORT
HEARING IN CALIFORNIA. MANAGER
WOULD YOU PER WHAT WOULD YOU
ALLOW. ME TO ENTER THIS WINTER
OKAY SO THE- THE SH THE SHOP. IN
REGARDS TO THE SHOP LOCAL FOR
THE PURCHASE BY AMERICAN OR OR
BY BY CALIFORNIAN IT'S A BUY
AMERICAN SO IT'S ANY ANYWHERE IN
THE UNITED STATES. BUT OBVIOUSLY
WE PAY SO MUCH OF IT THAT IT
WOULD HELP OUR FARMERS NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT IS- IT WOULD
NOT AFFECT ANY OF OUR TRADE
AGREEMENTS AND WE HAVE A TRADE
AGREEMENTS WITH. ALL OF THE-
FACT IT OR TRADE AGREE AND
THAT'S REALLY THE LEGAL- ISSUE
THAT- THAT- YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHICH IS. WHICH IS ON. IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT IT DOESN'T AFFECT
THAT THE 25% BASICALLY WAS
ARRIVED AT BY- BY A- TAKING A
LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE PUT ON OUR
FARMERS- THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REQUIREMENTS THE- LABOR
REQUIREMENTS THE- SAFETY
STANDARDS THAT BET THE REQUIRED
THE RIDICULOUS TORY FRAMEWORK.
AND THAT NUMBER WAS- WAS A
NUMBER THAT WE DECIDED WAS
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH SO THAT YOU.
ARE ARE- LOCAL. AG COMPANIES
COULD COMPETE ON THE WORLD
MARKET- AGAINST OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT DON'T HAVE ANY OF THE
PROTECTIONS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
THE REASON THAT THEY'RE SO.
INEXPENSIVE TO BUY IS THAT THE
QUALITY IS NOT S HIGH- AND
THAT'S- THAT'S JUST THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS THAT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST QUALITY PRODUCE- FRUITS
AND NUTS INCLUDED OF ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD BUT THERE'S A COST
THAT COMES WITH IN THEIR ALSO A
FOOD. AT THE HIT THE- BECAUSE
JUST DOESN'T MEET THE QUALITY
THAT WE EXPECT IN ORDER FOR IT
TO GET TO THE MARK- AND SO.
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT WE FIVE
CAME 25% CAME FROM IS THAT- IT
IT IT PUT SET UP. IT IT PUT THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BY
AMERICAN PRIDE OF PRODUCTS
DOESN'T HAVE ANY NUMBER AT ALL
THEY JUST BASICALLY SAY-
REASONABLE- AND WE- PICKED UP A
NUMBER SO THAT WAY WE COULD.
MORE ACCURATELY ON TO- THAT WHAT
IT IS THAT ON THE DATE BUT
PRODUCT MIGHT. THAT NUMBER THAT
THAT WE WANT PEOPLE DO IT AT
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ACHIEVE
IS THAT WE WANT THEM TO BUY
LOCALLY OR NATIONALLY PRODUCED
FRUITS VEGETABLES AND NUTS- AS
LONG AS THE MARGIN IS NOT MORE
THAN 25% LESS- THE MARCH. TWENTY
MORE. FULLER QUESTION TO THE
CHAIR- SO THE OTHER- BUDGIES THE
OTHER COMMENT THAT I WAS GOING
TO HAVE WAS WITH REGARDS TO YOU-
I KNOW SENATOR SKINNER HAD A
BILL LAST YEAR WERE WHERE YOU
CAME TO UNIVERSAL MEALS FOR ALL
OF OUR KIDS- K. THROUGH TWELVE
BASICALLY IF I'M NOT MISTAKING
KEITH IS RALPH. IN AND ONE OF
THE COMMENTS THAT STRUCK ME ON
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WAS
THAT- WE WEREN'T TAPPING ALL OF
THE FEDERAL FUNDS- THAT WERE AB
THAT CALIFORNIA WAS ENTITLED TO-
WHEN HE CAME TO THE MEAL. WE
JUST HAVE. THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
. USING IT UP FOR OR UTILIZING
AND THAT'S WHY SHE'S SORT OF A
MADE THAT POINT WITH IN SUPPORT
OF HER BILL I END UP SUPPORTING
THE BILL BECAUSE I THOUGHT WELL
IF WE ARE NOT TALKING A LITTLE
SPECIAL FUNDS THEN PERHAPS WE
COULD. SUPPORT THIS BILL SO THAT
WE CAN GET THOSE HANDS WITH THIS
WITH THIS SPELL. IF WE WERE TO
NOT SURE WHERE THAT BELLE IS IF
WE PASS IT OR NOT THEY WOULD
HAVE SAID YES IS FUNDED SO- WITH
THAT. HELP KIND OF PAY FOR THIS
INCREASE OF 25% OR THIS IS COME
OUT OF CALIFORNIA. TAXPAYERS
BUDGET. SENATOR HOWEVER THE-
THERE THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
THINGS ONE IS THAT WE GET MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
ALSO GET FOOD SUBSIDIES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND THEN.
ALSO TRIBUTE TO ITIN TERMS OF
THE FOOD PROGRAM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS A U. S. D. A.
PURCHASING AGREEMENT AS WELL AND
THEY SEND A FOOD TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AS I UNDERSTAND- AT
AND SO WE'VE EXCLUDED THAT FROM
THIS DISCUSSION BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOMETHING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS TAKING
CARE OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T DESERVE YOU. THEY'RE NOT
WE DIDN'T FEEL IT WAS
APPROPRIATE FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO WORRY ABOUT THAT- SO- THIS
THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE PAID FOR
WITH FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL AS
STATE FUNDS THAT'S WHERE THEY
GET THEIR MONEY FOR THE FOOD.
OKAY RIGHT THE- THANK YOU
SENATOR CHOI BOGUE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE CENTER
DOLLY RESTATE HIS QUESTIONS AND
SET A GOAL LONGER THAN I THOUGHT
I THINK I THINK I GOT IT UP IF
BEEN TO ME MORE TO COME. I I'M-
SO IN RE TO THE CORE THAT THERE
THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED ON A
NUMBER OF THE OF THE ISSUES AND
BEEN DEALT WITH BY AMENDMENTS IN
THE BILL- I'M IN IN PARTICULAR
THE ISSUE ON THE U. S. D. A.
FOOD THAT IS GIVEN TO THE
SCHOOLS WE TOOK AN AMENDMENT TO
EXACT- THE FOOD THAT'S PREPARED
FOR ME WITH A FROM THE 25% AND
SAYS. AT TO ISSUE ABOUT- AT SOME
. FOOD PRODUCTS NOT BEING
AVAILABLE- WE M. TOOK THAT WE
MADE IT WE BASICALLY COPIED THE
LANGUAGES IN THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM- WE DON'T PRODUCE
MANGOES ARE BANANAS AND FRANKLY
I DON'T THAT THAT MAKES A WHOLE
HECK THIS INTEREST TWO WEEKS BY
PRODUCT. THEY CAN BUY THEM FROM
FOR A FULL AND- PRODUCE. I'M AND
THEIR ARE TIMES OF THE YEAR AS
YOU KNOW WHERE- IT'S VERY HARD
TO GET DOMESTIC. FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T
PRODUCE SOME HERE IN THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS SO- WE'RE
BLESSED WITH SAID AND WEBER-
BECAME DO SO. STONE COMMODITIES
. DURING A PERIODS OF THE YEAR
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT TO GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE- LETTUCES GROWN
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND- AND SO AND
SO IF YOU GET STRAWBERRIES IN
THE WINTER YOU'RE NOT. IN THEM
FROM FOREIGN AND- WHENEVER WE
HAVE SNACKS OUT AND THERE'S THAT
FRUIT FRESH. CALIFORNIA CERTAIN
TIMES IN AND SO WE NEED TO A PRE
THE FACT THAT- WE DO PRODUCE A
LOT OF- THE MAJORITY OF ALMOST
EVERYTHING BUT DURING CERTAIN
TIMES A YEAR YOU CAN'T. AND SO
THIS ALLOWS THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS. YOU JUST
HAVE. THEY'RE NOT AVAILABLE-
DOMESTICALLY AND YOU CAN GET IN
FROM FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE SO
WE'RE WORKING ON NON REALLY
TAKING OFF THE ISSUES THAT THAT
ARE OF CONCERN- WELL THIS MAY
THIS COST MORE YES IT PROBABLY
WELL ADMITS IT. HOUSE MORE TO
PRODUCE THE HIGH QUALITY OF OUR
OF OUR- THAT'S A BUDGET ISSUE WE
CAN LOOK AT THAT- DOWN THE ROAD
BUT- THIS. AND IT'S FOOD THING
IN THE STATE HELLO- IT
SIGNIFICANTLY AND THE FACT THAT
WE CAN FEED- ARE ART OUR OUR
STUDENTS AND- STUDENTS ALL THE
WAY UP TO COLLEGE HAVE BILLY YOU
DO IT HAVE A HIGH CALL IN STILL
INVESTED IN A COP IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. IT WOULD READ. BACK
THE BATHROOM. THANK YOU SO
CABALLERO JUST BE WE GET TO THE
VOTE I- YOU ACKNOWLEDGED IT WHEN
YOU FIRST SPOKE- I SUPPORT THE
BILL- BEFORE IT TODAY I SUPPORT
BY CALIFORNIA I AM- BUT I EMPATH
IS WHAT SCHOOL OF. BUSINESS'S
YES. THESE IN MY DISTRICT AND
THEY JUST WANT TO FEED KIDS AND
THEY LOVE THEIR JOBS AND THE
THINGS THAT THEY ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT IS ALL THE PAPERWORK AND
ALL OOPS THAT THEY HAVE TO JUMP
THROUGH EXITS MUCH HARDER THEIR
JOB THE BILL. JUST CONTINUE. WE
OF TO A REALLY GOOD JOB MAKING
HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO DO SO-
WHICH ONE MAKE SURE THOSE LUNCH
LADIES CAN CONTINUE TO FEED OUR
STUDENTS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR CABALLERO. MAN OF THE ROTH.
NUMBER FIVE IS THIRTEEN EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HI LEYVA AYE OCHO
ABOVE AYE BOBOC AYE CORTEZ THE
DALLAS. DALY I. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PANTH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE MILITARY OUT YOU'RE
VERY WELCOME WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE ABSENT
ALL RIGHTS ARE ALLEN IS RUNNING
A LITTLE BIT LATE BUT I MISSED
I'M- IS. SENATE ARE YOU AND I'M
SEVEN S. FOUR ONE FIRST READY
THANK YOU MADAM.
IN PARTICULAR- ATHLETES IN
SPORTS TO GENERATE A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF REVENUE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY'S. FIRST LET ME THANK
THE COMMITTEE- STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF AND- THE EXTENSIVE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE AND I
ACCEPT TO COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS-
THE BILL THEN USED TO BUILD ON
THE WORK. THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DON TO ADDRESS. FLAYED STATION
AS YOU WELL KNOW MORE RECENTLY
S. B. TWENTY SIX M. S. RETOOL
SIR DEATHS SKINNER. DOING WHAT
NAME IMAGE TO LIE THAT. ON-
FORTINO ONE AT. THAT GENERATE
MASSES MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
REVENUE AND WHERE ATHLETES
RECEIVE ONLY THEIR SCHOLARSHIPS
IN RETURN A SMALL FRACTION OF
THE TOTAL REVENUE. AND AS YOU
KNOW COLLEGE FOOTBALL BOWL
DIVISION- FOOTBALL PLAYERS IN
THIS DIVISION ONE MEN AND WOMEN. THE ONLY COLLEGE ATHLETES IN
STATE WHO DO NOT RECEIVE AT
LEAST 50% OF THE REVENUE THAT
THEY PRODUCE. LAST YEAR THE US
SUPREME COURT RULED UNANIMOUSLY
THAT. IN THE IN SITU ES VERSUS
AUSTIN. RULING THAT THE INSITU
INSITU I WAS ACTING IN VIOLATION
OF ANTITRUST LAWS BY LIMITING
EDUCATION RELATED COMPENSATION
THAT ATHLETES RECEIVE INTO TO A
STILL RESTRICTS COMPENSATION THE
SCHOOLS CAN PROVIDE DIRECTLY TO
THEIRS. ATHLETES ON RELATED TO
THEIR EDUCATION. AND- THE-
CLIENTS ARE MY PHONE AT ME AND-
IS A ERRING OPINION ON THIS CASE
JUSTICE GOVERNANCE STATED INTO
TO A IS A MEMBER AND ITS MEMBERS
ARE COLLEGE OF SUPPRESSING TO
PAY OF STUDENT ATHLETES WHO
COLLECTIVELY GENERATE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN REVENUE FOR
COLLEGES EVERY YEAR BUT THE
STUDENT ATHLETE TO GENERATE
THOSE REVENUES MANY UP AND WE
GET OUR AFTER MEREKA FOR MORE TO
COME BACK IN WHAT. ARE NOTHING
TO SHOW FOR THE AND STATION.
BRIEF COMPENSATION FUNDED
INSURANCE 50% OF THE REVENUE
GENERATED IN SPORTS GOES BACK TO
THE ATHLETES INCENTIVIZE
GRADUATION ASSIST WITH COST OF
LIVING DURING COLLEGE AND GIVE
BACK A FAIR SHARE OF THAT
REVENUE HAT THE GENERATED.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS AND THERE IS
A MOUNT THAT'S- DEPOSITED INTO A
FUND AND ITS CALCULATED BY
SUBTRACTING THE AMOUNT. OF THE
GRANT IN AID SCHOLARSHIP IN THE
SPORTS FROM FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
REVENUE GENERATED IN SPORTS. A
DIFFERENCE THEN IS DIVIDED AMONG
EACH ATHLETE IN THAT SPORT. AN
ATHLETE HAS IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
UP TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER ACADEMIC YEAR AND
SHE RECEIVED THE BALANCE OF
THESE BONDS WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF
GRADUATION. AND IF THEY COMPLETE
THEIR BACHELOR'S DEGREE. AS LONG
AS I SHOULD SAY THE COMPLETE
THIRD BACHELOR'S DEGREE WITHIN
SIX YEARS. THERE ARE SEVERAL
ISSUES POINTED OUT BY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSTS ANALYSTS THAT
ON I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS AND
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK IF
THIS BILL MOVES TOWARD- FOR AN
FIRST REGARDING OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL AND CONTRACTING
AGREEMENTS DONE NOW ALSO STATES
THAT. WE SHOULD CONSIDER WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND AN
APPROPRIATE MECHANISM TO THAT
PROPERLY. COMPENSATE STUDENT
ATHLETES WHILE ENSURING
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION'S ATHLETIC PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO BE SUSTAINED AN
OPERABLE AND TO NOT DISRUPT
CURRENT AND FUTURE CONTRACTS OF
STAFF AND COACHES IT IS NOT OUR
INTENT. THAT THESE FUNDS- ARE
GIVEN TO ATHLETES BE TAKEN FROM
WHAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE USED TO
SUPPORT A FLAT PARTS OTHER
ATHLETIC SPORTS AGENTS. AND
WE'VE HEARD FROM SAM SEVERAL
INSTITUTIONS- THAT EVER- REVENUE
GENERATING SPORTS BY ONE POPULAR
SUPPORT ON THEIR CAMPUS AND IS
OFTEN USED TO FUND OTHER SPORTS
THAT GENERATE LITTLE OR NO
REVENUE WE DO NOT WANT TO CREATE
A SCENARIO WHERE THE SPORT. IN
SIMILAR ALSO ONE TO REMIND OF
STAFF SALARIES AND PAY.
INCREASES AND THAT- THAT HAVE
BEEN NEGOTIATED AND WE SHOULD
ALSO BE CONSCIOUS OF JUST HOW
MUCH MONEY IS SPENT BY
INSTITUTIONS ON COACHES RATHER
THAN ATHLETES AS WE ALL KNOW
MOST OF THESE COLLEGE COACHES
ARE MULTI MILLIONAIRES. WHO
BELONG TO EXCLUSIVE COUNTRY
CLUBS AND USE PRIVATE CHARTER
JETS TO COME TO THESE
COMMUNITIES A RECRUIT THESE
ATHLETES AND THEY CAN'T EVEN GET
ON THE PLANE TO GO BACK HOME.
DURING OFFSEASON. AN EXAMPLE OUT
IN TWENTY ONE ACADEMIC YEAR U.
S. C. SPENT TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ON STUDENT. AID ACROSS
ALL SPORTS. AND ALSO SPENT
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS ON
COACHES SALARIES OF ALL SPORTS
DESPITE THAT THEY'RE BEING TEN
TIMES MORE. ATHLETES AND COACHES
ANOTHER ISSUE ADDRESSED IN
ANALYSIS AND DEFINITION OF
REVENUE STATING THAT WE SHOULD
SHOULD CONSIDER WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE BUT THAT
UP. AT THE PURPLE RUBBER TICKET
SALE APPAREL TELEVISION
CONTRACTS ETCETERA IS CAPTURED
WHEN CALCULATING ON. RECEIVES
AND THEIR- CURRENTLY REVENUE CAN
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE ATHLETES
FEES PAID BY GENERAL STUDENT
BODY AND WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE SIMPLY CAPTURING THE
REVENUE THESE ATHLETES GENERATE
FINALLY THAT ANALYSIS STATES
THAT WE CONSIDER WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND ON DETERMINING
THEM OUT OF STUDENT AID CAN
WITHDRAW FROM THEIR DEGREE
COMPLETION FUND BRACKET ACADEMIC
YEAR CURRENTLY THE MOUNT AS
STATED WAS TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND.
HAS DROPPED INTO COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AT WE LOOKED AT THIS
AMOUNT TO ASSIST ATHLETES WHO
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH FOOD
AND HOUSING INSECURITY AND OTHER
LIFE EXPENSES AND ENSURE THAT.
WE CAN FOCUS ON THEIR STUDIES
AND ATHLETIC RESPONSIBILITIES
WITHOUT FINANCIAL WORRIES THE
BILL IS NOT PERFECT WE STILL
MUCH WORK TO BE DONE SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE. AS YOU DO. IT COMES
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY HERE
TO TESTIFY. IS WERE MUGGY- HUM
THE HOMA THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF NATIONAL COLLEGE PLAYERS
ASSOCIATION WILL ALSO READ
TESTIMONY FROM STANFORD FOOTBALL
ATHLETE ELIJAH HIGGINS REMOTELY
IS ALSO AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ARE IS
REQUEST WE ARE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR EFFORT AMANDA
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PULL UP A
REMOTE KEY HOME AND YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A MOBILE
NUMBER. I'M A FORMER UCLA
FOOTBALL PLAYER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NPA NATIONAL
BECAUSE PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
KEITH COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES ON
SB FORTINO ONE. BECAUSE SPORTS.
IS A FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR A
YEAR INDUSTRY THAT LEAVES MANY
ATHLETES WITHOUT DEGREES. IN
ABOUT HALF PROJECT IS WITH
COLLEGE PLAYERS AND- ALL CALLED
OUT HIS RECEIVER COMPENSATION.
IT FACT APPOINTED IT THIS BILL-
OUT THE SIMPLE COMPLEX AFTER
MARKET RATE WHAT DO NOT ENTER MY
PAY TO ALL AT THE SAMBADROME
SPORTS. PHYSICAL VIOLATION GET
UNDERSCORE FACT COUPLE BY CALL
AT THE STATE THE MY SHARE OF.
REVENUE AND SO THE WORST
GRADUATION RATES. CAN CLOUDESLEY
PROGRAMS RECRUITING IN THE BLACK
. PROMISING DESPONDENCY
REGULARLY BROKEN. IN CALIFORNIA
FEDERAL GRADUATION RATES AMONG
BLACK FOOTBALL PLAYERS AND
BASKETBALL PLAYERS WITH 64% AND
43% RESPECTIVELY. AB FIVE
DIVISION ONE CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
BLACK MEN'S BASKETBALL PLAYERS
GRADUATIONS RATES WERE 0% LAST
SUMMER THE U. S. SUPREME COURT
UNANIMOUSLY FOUND OUT THE
COMPENSATION THAT IS TO BE IN
VIOLATION OF ANTITRUST LAWS.
COLLEGES CONTINUE TO VOTE ANTI
TRUST LAWS BY ILLEGALLY
COLLUDING TO LIMIT AFTER A
CONVERSATION. CALL THIS FALL THE
CLAIM THAT THEY HAVE TO CUT
SPORTS PAY US BEFORE TO NO ONE
THE SPORTS WE PAID FOR WITH
REVENUES AMOUNTS THEY WERE SO
PASSED LONG AGO. AND THE MISUSE
OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW ANNUAL ATHLETICS REVENUE
FROM 200-018-2000 EIGHTEEN.
EXPOSES THE COLLEGES PARTIES
DURING THIS PERIOD CALLED AFTER
PARTICIPATION DROPPED BY SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR OUT THE-
WHAT WHICH MONEY WAS SPENT
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY ON LAVISH
SALARIES AT THE CITIES. AND
HIRING ADDITIONAL COACHES AND
ATHLETIC ADMINISTRATORS OFFER
FEWER ATHLETES. COLLEGES
CONTINUED TO IMPOSE SECOND CLASS
CITIZENSHIP ON CALIFORNIA'S
ATHLETES HAS BECOME RACIAL
EXPLOITATION. AND STIFLING
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. SB FORTY
NO ONE WOULD. THE A- OF
ATHLETES. GRADUATE RATES WOULD
SKYROCKET INSTEAD ASK FOR YES
VOTE. AND I WAS ASKED BY YOU
LIKE YOU CAN STANFORD FOOTBALL
PLAYER TO REACH HIS- STEVEN IF
THAT'S OKAY SINCE THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE ON A IN THE OPPOSITION
YES YOU CAN HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO TO THE LARGEST AGAIN
STATEMENT. AS A HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETE WAS ALWAYS MY DREAM TO
PLAY BALL THE NEXT LEVEL. IT WAS
DURING THE QUARTER OF COLLEGE
FOOTBALL RECRUITING THAT I
REALIZED HOW SPORTS WITH THE
BUSINESS. THE BUSINESS. YOU
ROLES. IS WITHOUT MUCH
SUBSTANCE. IN HOPES THAT THESE
KIDS SKILLS WOULD WIN BIG GAMES
AND WIN BIG MONEY. THE CARD IS.
MAKING A TOP ONE HUNDRED RATED
PLAYER COMING OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
I THOUGHT ALL. COACHES PROMISES
QUICK GLAMOUR ANY LEGAL BRIBES
DESIGNED WITH THEIR SCHOOL. I
MADE MY DECISION TO ATTEND
TEMPLE UNIVERSITY TO BE PART OF
A COMMUNITY PROGRAM. THAT LIKE A
MAJORITY OF BIG TIME COLLEGE
FOOTBALL PROGRAMS PLACED A HIGH
PRIORITY ON EDUCATION.
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE LEARNED THAT
PROTECTING EDUCATION IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT EVEN AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF TAILORED FOR
ACADEMIC SUCCESS. IS THE FACT
THAT THE ACCUMULATED HOURS OF
TRAINING PRACTICES LISTEN
MEETINGS ARE SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH
TO BE COMPARED TO THAT OF A FULL
TIME JOB. SURVEYS SHOW THAT
pDESPITE THE INTO TWENTY HOURS
PER WEEK LIMIT CONFLICTS
ACTIVITY. PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY EXCEED THIS LIMIT AND I
THINK SPEND UP TO FIFTY HOURS
PER WEEK. FOR A LOT. RUBIO THAT
CALLS FOOTBALL IS A BUSINESS AND
AS BUSINESS HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE NEGATIVE AFFECT
ON BOTH PLAYERS. THE MAJORITY OF
WHOM ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN LIKE
MYSELF. THE SYSTEM IS SET UP TO
RING UP THE TOWNS OF EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD AND MONETIZE
BILLIONS IN THE PROCESS. 98% OF
THESE ATHLETES WILL GO PRO. AND
MANY RIGHT ABOUT HALF OF THEM
WILL HAVE CHRONIC BECAUSE SPORTS
INJURIES BUT NONE OF THEM WILL
RECEIVE A PROPORTIONAL WRITTEN
IN THE TO CREATE ON THE FIELD
WITH THE JUSTICES TAKE PLACE NOT
HIGHLY PRAISED INDUSTRY WHICH ON
ITS OWN WILL NOT ADDRESS THE
NEGATIVE ASPECTS BROUGHT BY THE
INTERSECTION AUDI OF BEING A
COLLEGE FOOTBALL PLAYER AND THE
STUDENTS. I ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES AND AS YOU
KNOW WILL PROVIDE MUCH A MUCH
NEEDED STRUCTURE FOR CREATING
SOLUTIONS KEEP PROBLEM. OKAY
BECAUSE WITHIN THE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR IT WILL
COME BACK HERE TO ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO ONE MADAM MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS. THEIR FOR
SB FORTINO ONE PLEASE. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN ZERO ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME. AND
FIRST. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO WE CAN HELP THEM. OKAY HI-
ALEX GRAVES WITH THE ICC ILL- WE
OUR MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION FOR
PRIVATENONPROFIT COLLEGES IN
THE STATE- WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL OF THOSE POSITIONS THE
MOMENT DO THEY GOT THEM AND
COMPLEX POLICIES PROPOSED THE
RECOGNIZE THEIR NUMBER OF-
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
YESTERDAY WE DO REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CREATION THE FUNDED
OUTLINED IN THE BILL AND HOW
THAT WILL IMPACT OTHER NON
REVENUE GENERATING SPORT AND
WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS ARE FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS AS WELL AS FIVE
TITLE NINE THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTINO ONE NOW IS
THE TIME TO CALL IT BACK TO YOU
MADAM MODERATOR. THANK YOU HAVE
LINE. BEFORE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HOUSTON UNITED STEELWORKERS
DISTRICT TWELVE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF FIFTY FOURTEEN NOW
WHAT THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE
NEXT LINE TWO SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ABOUT
ENSURE MEMBERS TYLER I YOU ARMY
AFTER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA- WHY WE DO NOT HAVE
AN OFFICIAL OPPOSE POSITION ON
THE BILL AT THIS TIME WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH THIS BILL AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR IT VERY
CLOSELY AS IT MOVES INTO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND I DO NOT. WISH TO I DO
. ONE MOMENT.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS TO ENSURE YOU FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY WE
ALSO DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL THE
THING ON THE BILL BUT ALL. ALSO
HAD CONCERNS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO MONITOR THAT MONITOR THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND I DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION I DON'T
SEE ANYONE HERE ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. META MODERATED WE'RE
GOING BACK TO YOU ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO QUEUE UP IN OPPOSITION
TO IT TOO SB FORTINO ONE THIS
WOULD BE THE TIME. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FORTINO ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ON YOUR PHONE RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO. AND I
HAVE AND WINNING YEAH THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR ART WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SENATOR VOTE AND THEN CENTER
GLAZER. HELLO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- SENATOR BRADFORD I
HAVE. A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR
YOU- THE FIRST ONE BEING HOW ARE
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
EXPECTED TO COMPLY WITH TITLE
NINE GIVEN THE PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL AND SECOND PART
PAYMENTS WOULD BE DIRECTED
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY TO MALE
ATHLETES WHAT ABOUT FEMALE
ATHLETES THAT'S NOT THE CASE YOU
WOULDN'T BE DISTRIBUTED THROUGH
ALL ATHLETES WITH BROMLEY. OF
BOWLS ITS STATE FOOTBALL IS A
LARGE REVENUES ALSO FIRST TAKING
CARE OF THOSE BUT ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT OFF ATHLETES BUILD
PARTICIPANTS PROGRAM- IN
PROPORTION TO THE REVENUE THAT
THEY GENERATE THE GENERATE
SHOWED AND SO FAR EVEN WITH THE-
BLACKENED. INDIVIDUAL TAKEN
GREATEST BALLAD OF OUR THE WOMEN
ATHLETES OF FOR THEIR THE WANT
TO SIGN MORE CONTRACTS- SINCE
WEEK PASSED THAT BILL THAN A
MALE ATHLETES BUT WE'RE ALSO
WORKING ON THE MOMENT THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE TITLE NINE
QUESTION THAT YOU'RE ASKING SO I
WILL LET REMOTELY ANSWER- IT
PROVIDE. ANY OTHER TECHNICAL-
ADVISOR. TO JUST INJURE IT.
RESELLING CLOCK. DID THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION SARATOGA WOULD YOU
LIKE HIM TO ANSWER WE WOULD LIKE
HIM TO ANSWER HOW CAN I HAVE A
COUPLE OF OTHERS OKAY. PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. SURE SHOWS NOTHING
ENOUGH BEFORE TO NO ONE. WOULD
BE IN VIOLATION OF TITLE NINE
AND IT ASSURES THAT ANY ATHLETE
THAT FALLS UNDER THE- 50%
THRESHOLD RECEIVING REVENUE-
WITH IT WAS NOT DISCRIMINATE-
ENOUGH TO KEEP PART OF TOTAL
NINE THAT. ANY KIND OF- YOU KNOW
POLICY OR ACTION THAT
DISCRIMINATES BASED ON SEX WOULD
BE A PROBLEM BUT THIS ASSURE
THAT ALL ACTRESS OR RECEIVE. 50%
OF REVENUE IN THE SPORT. OKAY
AND- SO FOR THE RECORD CAN YOU
WALK US THROUGH HOW THE FUND IS
SUPPOSED TO BE CALCULATED IN
DISTRIBUTED. GOT A QUESTION FOR
ME YES YOUR SEAT. SURE SO-
BASICALLY YOU NEED SUPPORT- IT
IS IT IS STUDENTS THAT. WORK
TAKES THE POOL REVENUE OF THE
SPORT AND AS THE TRACKS WITH THE
COLLEGES ARE PAYING THE PLAYERS
THE COLLEGES ARE CURRENTLY
PAYING PLAYERS IN THE FORM OF
SCHOLARSHIP WHICH IS A FORM OF
COMPENSATION THAT'S BEEN. A VERY
MUCH BETTER IN THE FEDERAL
COURTS SCHOLARSHIPS ARE
COMPENSATION FOR COLLEGE
ATHLETES- ANY ATHLETES THAT AS A
GROUP ARE NOT RECEIVING AT LEAST
50% OF THE REVENUE. WOULD
RECEIVE A SUBSIDY FROM THEIR
FROM THEIR SCHOOL- PURSUANT TO A
BILL LANGUAGE IN AT FOURTEEN
ZERO ONE WHICH WOULD MEAN THEY
WOULD HAVE ACCESS IMMEDIATELY
TOOK TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE YEAR. ON
ANYTHING IN EXCESS WOULD BE WITH
A CONDITIONAL UPON ULTIMATE
COMPLETION UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE
AT THAT POINT THE SCHOOL WOULD
BE- TO VERIFY- IMPROVE AND
PROVIDE THE FUNDS. SO HAPPY TO
FOR INSTANCE WERE THEY'RE
RECEIVING. 50% BURKE AND REVENUE
AT THE TIME BEING THERE WOULD
NEED UP THERE WOULD BE NO.
DEGREE COMPLETION ALLOCATION
THEY HAVE THEIR ARTERIES. MARKET
VALUE FOR THEIR- FOR THEIR WORK. THANK YOU IN ONE LAST-
QUESTION AND COMMENT THERE HOW
WILL OUR ATHLETIC PROGRAMS BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT DO NOT GENERATE ANY REVENUE
THIS BILL WOULD DIVERT CRITICAL
RESOURCES FOR ALL STUDENTS TO
JUST A SELECT FEW YEARS. REVENUE
GENERATED BY MEN'S FOOTBALL AND
BASKETBALL IS USED TO SUPPORT
ALL ATHLETIC TEAMS AT THEIR
RESPECTIVE CAMPUS FOOTBALL AND
BASKETBALL SEDGLEY SUBSIDIZE
OTHER SPORTS. AS STATED WE MADE
SURE THAT WE WOULD NOT
JEOPARDIZE HE OF THE CURRENT
FUNDING OF THOSE OTHER SPORTS
IT'S ABOVE AND BEYOND THOSE.
COSTS THAT WOULD GO INTO THE
FUNDS SO IF YOUR SOCCER TEAM IS
GETTING A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THEY WOULD STILL
CONTINUE TO GET A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SCHOLARSHIPS
OR SUBSIDIES OR WHATEVER THAT
AMOUNT IS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
TOUCH THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTRO CHAU BOOKS CENTER GLAZER
. AND A BRADFORD AYE I KNOW YOUR
HEARTS IN THE RIGHT PLACE ON
THIS AND YOU HAVE GREAT
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE
HONESTLY I'VE HAD A LOT OF
TROUBLE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY HOW THIS BILL IS GOING
TO WORK IN PRACTICE. WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
ACCEPTED YOU KNOW MIGHT
CONFUCIUS CLASSICALLY DIPS LEMME
SEE IF I CAN WORK THROUGH IT.
AND WE CAN FIGURE IT OUT. THIS
BILL APPLIES TO BOTH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC CULTURES RIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA. OKAY BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW I KNOW OF FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE UNIVERSITIES HAVE A LOT OF
FAMILIARITY WITH THE STATE
UNIVERSITY- SO MAYBE WE CAN
START IN THAT SPACE BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY THINK. EFFORTS TO GO
AFTER HE LEADS. EXCEPTIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT EXPLOIT.
THAT'S LIKE OVER HERE. BUT THE
BROAD SWATH OF WHERE THIS BILL
APPLIES WHAT I'M REALLY TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER. THAT THAT
IT SHOULD BE APPLICABLE IN THAT
SPACE SO- WE HAVE TWENTY THREE
CSU CAMPUSES. I CAME FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE AS YOU. BELIEVES THE
- THEY IT'S THAT LED TO IN A
POSITIVE WAY- ONE OF THE
OUTSTANDING MOST OUTSTANDING OF
THE STATE UNIVERSITIES- AND I
DID HAVE TO USE IN EUROPE ONE OF
THE LEAGUE'S. I DID HAVE
FAMILIARITY WITH THEIR ATHLETIC
BUDGET BECAUSE IT WAS VERY
INVOLVED IN THE FUNDING OF TITLE
NINE AND- WOMEN'S ATHLETICS WHEN
I WAS ON THE CAMPUS. AND AT THAT
POINT IN TIME AND I DON'T KNOW
IF IT HAS CHANGED- BUT BUT-
THERE WERE ONLY TWO SPORTS THE
GENERATED ANY REVENUE. THAT WAS
FOOTBALL AND MEN'S BASKETBALL.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS
CHANGED SINCE OUR YEARS. HAVE
GONE BY AND I DON'T IMAGINE
THERE ANY DIFFERENT THAN ANY OF
THE STATE UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES.
SO IF PART OF THE CRITERIA IS
THAT YOU'RE ELIGIBLE. THAT IS
THAT YOU GET YOU HAVE A SPORT
THAT GENERATES REVENUE WILL MOST
SPORTS. DON'T GENERATE ANY
REVENUE- AND SO WE REALLY JUST
TALKING ABOUT THE EXPLOITATION
AND COMPENSATION OF BASKETBALL
AND FOOTBALL PLAYERS REALLY IF
THAT'S IF THAT'S HOW YOUR BILL
IS APPLIED IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S THE HEART OF IT IS
THE IS THAT THAT SPACE MIGHT
NOT. THEY ARE THE LARGEST
GENERATOR BUT THIS IS TO BE
APPLIED UPLIFT POLITICALLY
ACROSS THE BOARD TO ALL SPORTS
ABOVE THAT THRESHOLD IF THERE'S
NO MONEY ABOVE THAT 50%
THRESHOLD OR YOU WANT TO
CONSIDER PROFIT THEN NO ONE'S
IMPACT IT'S NO MONEY TO BE GIVEN
OUT IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE GOING
TO PAY SOMEBODY IF THE REVENUE
IS NOT THERE. IF THE YOU HAVE TO
FIRST BREAK REVENUES STILL RIGHT
WELL GETS IN PLACE STATE OF
FALSE PROMISE THAT REALLY UNDER
THE L. AS YOU TO EXPLAIN IT
UNDER THE TERMS OF THIS BILL 95%
OF THE ATHLETE BY NUMBER ON A
CSU CAMPUS IS NOT GONNA BE THIS
BILL IS NOT COMPLIED OF. LIKE
NAY MITCHELL I THIS I'M GONNA
APPLY TO EVERYBODY BUT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE FOLKS
WHO CAN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT
AND IT BEATS THE SYSTEM THAT OUT
RIGHT NOW I CAN'T EVEN AND- IF
YOU- COLLEGES. YOU HAVE. COACHES
MAKING. WERE SIX FIGURES ME- OF
pATHLETIC DIRECTORS WHO WERE
MAKING HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
PLUS SO- THERE'S REVENUE FOR
THEM SO WE'RE JUST SAYING. RIGHT
AND I KNOW WHAT YOU SAY IS TRUE
AND I THINK THAT IS AN
INTERESTING. CONVERSATION ABOUT-
COLLEGE SPORTS CENTER CAMPUSES
IN HOW WE PAY COACHES AND
ATHLETIC DIRECTORS I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THAT. AND I
THINK THAT'S A WORD. VERSION OF
BECAUSE AS- INTAKE GRADE HISTORY
TEACHER A GREAT IN TEACHER
CLAIMED RESEARCHER. MANY
PUBLICATIONS AND THEY'RE JUST
GETTING BY AND WE HAVE COACHES
THE TACKETT GET ME IN THE
MILLIONS SO I HEAR YOU THERE-
BUT I'M NOT SO SURE THAT'S AN
ISSUE OF THE ATHLETES BEING
EXPLOITED. AND THAT WE NEED TO
FIND A WAY TO CREATE THIS
REVENUE GENERATOR WHICH YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE I DO THINK
THAT ONE OF THE COMPONENTS THAT
I LIKE ABOUT THIS BILL IS THAT
IT FOCUSES ON GRADUATION.
BECAUSE THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF
EXPLOITATION OUR SYSTEM WHERE WE
GET THE KIDS TO GET AT YOU KNOW.
STUDY HARD GET INTO UNIVERSITY
BOB. AND WHATEVER THEY NEED.
FIVE GET THAT. I DO TO GET TAE
THOSE CLASSES AND THEN BY MOST
OF MANY OF THEM DON'T GET A
DEGREE. AND THEY HAVE DEBT AND
HAVE NOTHING THAT'S A BROADER
ISSUE THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
AS YOU MAY KNOW IN THAT SPACE
YOU'RE- IN THE SENATE PRIOR TO
THAT THE- AT THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES. LEVEL SO I SEE THAT AS
A GENERAL PROBLEM BUT YOU'RE A
IT SEEMS LIKE IN THIS BILL. YOU
FOCUS ON THAT GRADUATION ELEMENT
THAT THAT EVEN. AFTER IS NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR ANY MONEY OR A PART
OF THIS MONEY AND LESS ACTUALLY
GRADUATE IN SIX YEARS RESERVE
THEY'RE NOT. ELIGIBLE UNLISTED
GRADUATED SIX YEARS THAT THE COP
IT ALL THE WAY. BASED ON THE
FACTOR OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND.
PER SEMESTER BUT THE RESERVE
THAT'S PUT INTO GRADUATION POOL
THEY CAN'T TOUCH THAT UNLESS
THEY GRADUATE THEY HAVE TO
GRADUATE WITHIN A SIX YEAR.
PERIOD GOT IT WELL I WOULD SAY
THIS THAT THAT I THERE'S A LOT
ABOUT THIS BILL THAT I THAT I
THINK IS GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I WOULD REALLY I THINK
WE WOULD BENEFIT. FROM HAVING
THESE REAL PRACTICAL EXAMPLES OF
THE UNIVERSITY A HERE'S HOW IT
WOULD WORK. UNIVERSITY BE HERE'S
HOW IT WORKS. I THINK THAT WOULD
HELP ME AND I YOU KNOW THIS IS A
FOR. THE LAST WEEK I HAD A REAL
TOUGH TIME GET MY HANDS AROUND
THIS. AND I KNOW WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO KNOW EVERYTHING HERE BUT- WE
DON'T I DON'T. AND I JUST RUBBLE
WITH THIS ONE BECAUSE I KNOW
YOUR HEARTS IN THAT DIRECTION
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
BUT I. I STILL STRUGGLING TO SEE
THE PRAGMATIC AFFECTED. SAN
DIEGO STATE OR CSU DOMINGUEZ
HILLS. L. LET. I CAN I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT USC. HE
LEADS- BUT AT THIS BILL IS GONNA
BE APPLICABLE TO A BROAD ARRAY
OF PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES WHICH I
CARE A LOT ABOUT AND I KNOW YOU
DO TOO. AND I STRUGGLE TO SEE
EXACTLY. HOW THIS IS GONNA COULD
COME INTO PLAY UC DAVIS
SACRAMENTO STATE CETERA. BUT IF
THERE'S NO. PROFIT GENERATED IT
DOESN'T IMPACT ME IN A WAY YOU
GOT A FIRST EVER PROFIT. IF
YOU'RE NOT GENERATING IT. IT'S
GOING TO BE LEAVING THE PLAYING
FIELD AS IT IS TODAY THEY'LL
JUST. SHIP BUT IF IT'S NOTHING
ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT
SCHOLARSHIP THAT. IT'S
PROFITABLE IT'S NO MONEY TO BE
GIVEN OUT ANYWAY. RIGHT SO
PRAGMATICALLY THAN TAKE SACKS
STATE HOW DOES THAT WORK WITHIN
THEIR ATHLETIC BUDGET TODAY I
WOULD REALLY HELP ME TO SEE WHAT
THAT'S WHAT THE UNIVERSE IS
GOING TO DO THIS THING BECOMES
LAW THEY'RE GONNA SAY OKAY HOW
DO WE MAKE THIS WORK IN OUR
BUDGET. HOW MANY ATHLETES DO WE
HAVE AND WHAT SPORTS AND WHAT
REVENUES GENERATED AND WHAT WILL
THIS MEAN FOR THE SET ASIDE AND
YOU SAY THE MONEY CAN'T BE TAKEN
FROM PROGRAMS OKAY WHERE IS THAT
MONEY. GOING TO COME FROM
BECAUSE THAT REVENUE GENERATION
I DON'T THINK YOU KNOW EVERY
UNIVERSITIES DIFFERENT BUT A LOT
OF THE STATE UNIVERSITIES
THEY'RE NOT PROFIT CENTERS ARE
TRYING TO BREAK EVEN I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE CUTTING
SPORTS BECAUSE THEY CLAIM AT
LEAST. THANK AT BREAK EVEN THAT
WE HEAR ALL THE TIME ON THE
CAMPUS WHEN THEY START PLAYING
BASEBALL AND SOCCER AND YOU'RE
NOT MAKING ANY. SO SENATOR
GLAZER IT I CAN. MAYBE HELPFUL
HERE. WE'VE HEARD YOU SAY A
COUPLE TIMES. THAT YOU WOULDN'T
WANT SOME CONCRETE ANSWERS.
MAYBE YOU AND THE AUTHOR COULD
SPEAK OFFLINE ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE HE HAS IT
RIGHT HERE. AND YOU CAN. YOU CAN
MAYBE CHOOSE TO. LET THE BILL GO
ON ITS CURRENT FORMER OR LAY OFF
BUT I DON'T THINK THE QUESTIONS
ARE ANSWERED. ASKING RIGHT NOW
ARE GOING TO BE RESOLVED RIGHT
THIS MOMENT. OKAY THAT'S FAIR
ENOUGH BUT IT'S A PART OF THE
REASON THAT. IT ACT I TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION VOTING FOR A BILL.
I GREE AND I JUST THINK THAT
WE'VE HEARD YOU SAY THAT SEVERAL
TIMES AND I JUST DON'T THINK WE
CAN GET THAT ANSWER FOR YOU
TODAY. I WILL GIVE ME AUTHOR THE
CHANCE HE DOES WANT TO ANSWER
FURTHER THAT'S NO PROBLEM. WELL
I WOULD ALSO IF REMOTE HE WANTS
TO. EXPAND UPON IF BRING.
GREATER CLARITY TO YOUR QUESTION
I WOULD. IOTA FROM YET DIEM
RIGHT NOW. PLEASE FOR THE HAPPY
TO ADDRESS YOUR LAST QUESTION.
YOUR QUESTION FIRST FOR
SACRAMENTO STATE WE BROKEN DOWN
ALL THE NUMBERS IT WOULD COST
ABOUT 3% OTHER TO LET ATHLETIC
REVENUES SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE IT'S ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
BUT THAT WOULD BE. SENATOR
BRADFORD AND THIS COMMITTEE OR
DECIDING WHERE THIS MONEY COME
FROM A FOR SUSTAINING OTHER
SPORTS. NEW REVENUE SO THERE'S
NO NEW REVENUE THEN THERE'S NO
OPPORTUNITY- UNDER THE COUNTER
TO WHAT THE CANADIANS ARE
BRADFORD ARE DISCUSSING- TO PULL
EXTRA MONEY SO- AND JUST TO PUT
THIS IN PERSPECTIVE OUTSIDE OF
THE RICHEST SCHOOLS OKAY THE
SEVEN FBS FOOTBALL SCHOOLS. YOU
HAVE A- LCS FOOTBALL GAME AND
SCHOOLS WITHOUT ANY QUOTE ALL
THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS THE
REVENUE HAS TRIPLE TRIPLED IN
SIZE AND YET THEY DECIDED TO DO. BE FIVE THOUSAND
ADULT PREFERENCE OF THE NEEDS-
THERE'S ALWAYS NEW REVENUE
COMING IN FOR. YOU KNOW IF THE
WEATHER THE RECESSION THEY STAY.
AND COLD IT. THERE'S TO BE NEW
REVENUE COMING IN AT ALL TO SO.
THERE IS A WAY TO DO THAT WHICH
SUSTAIN THE SPORTS- BY BEGINNING
TO TAP INTO THIS INTO THE NEW
REVENUE THAT'S GOING TO BE
ULTIMATELY COMING. IN AT ONE
LEVEL TO THE YOU KNOW IN TERMS
OF THE SAN JOSE CITY WHICH HAS
THE LEAST REVENUES OUT OF THE AT
THE ESPYS AND- THEY JUST GAVE
THEIR CODE. THANK A MILLION
DOLLARS. ONE DOLLARS. YOU KNOW
IN CONTRAST. YOU KNOW IF YOU
JUST LOOK AT HOW MY WOULD COST
TO FILTER BILL WOULD BE TO PAY
EIGHT MILLION- INDIRECT BUT
WHEN. IN PAY RAISE FOR THAT ONE
COACH. IS OVER A THIRD OF AN
EXAMPLE OF JUST TO KIND OF MAKE
THINGS RIGHT- BUT- BILLS- YOU
WITHIN A RANGE OF- COLLEGES
THERE ARE STILL. PLENTY OF. NEW
REVENUES THAT CAN BE TAPPED INTO
FOR THIS BILL. OKAY AND THEN FOR
THE FOR ME AT LEAST I THINK
THAT. THAT THE HEART IS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE AND I THINK WITHOUT
HAVING A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL
ABOUT EXACTLY HOW THIS WOULD
WORK IN PRACTICE- THE SPONSOR
JUST INDICATED THAT. THAT THEY
NEED NEW REVENUE FOR SAC STATE
TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL SO THAT
SOME INDICATION THAT. THIS IS
NOT GOING TO REALLY AFFECT SEX
STATE SO WHAT IS IT REALLY DOING
I THINK THAT THAT. ISN'T FOR ME
TO TAKE A POSSIBLY. QUESTIONING
IN AB HOPE THAT. AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON TRYING TO GET THOSE
ANSWERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS CENTER DOLLY. I
TOO AM GONNA JUST TO. I HAD I
HAD A SON BUSTER THAT WRESTLED
IN D. ONE SCHOOL CAL POLY.
PRESLEY- HARVARD WAS GONNA DO
AWAY WITH THEIR WRESTLING
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MAKE
MONEY AND THAT'S THE SPACE THAT
YOU. I VOTED WITH YOU ON ALL THE
LAST BILLS BECAUSE THIS IS A
BUSINESS LET'S FACE IT IS A
BUSINESS AS A BIG BUSINESS. AND
ATHLETES ARE AT THE EXPENSE OF
THE BIG BUSINESS SO I I'M ONLY
OFF I THINK YOU'RE ON THE YOUR
MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I'M
GONNA BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. IT DOESN'T AND IT DOESN'T
JUST. BUT MORE OF A VISIT. JUST
FOCUS ON THOSE TWO SPORTS TO
REALLY MAKE MONEY. AT THE END OF
THE I THINK THAT'S GOING TO.
DIVERT AWAY FROM OTHER SPORTS
AND I THINK- ON THE GENDER SIDE
OF IT I THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE.
MEN'S FOR PROBABLY OUT WAY IN
THIS. IN THE MONEY MAKING
DEPARTMENT. THAN THE WHIMS OR
MAYBE NOT FOR THE- FOR THE- LAST
BILLS WE DID WHERE THEY WERE
BASICALLY. YOU KNOW
ADVERTISEMENT BILL- SO I'M I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AS WELL SO
I'M IN THE OFFICE WHAT THEY'LL
SAVE A LOT OF TIME. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WITH QUESTIONS YES
CENTER CORTESE. QUESTION A
MINUTE. WILL BE SUPPORTING. THE
BILL TODAY BUT- I THINK. THERE'S
A LOT OF DIFFERENTIATION HERE
THAT. MAYBE ISN'T IS A- FULLY
APPEAR EXCUSE ME FOR THAT FULLY
APPARENT. OF DIVISION TWO
DIVISION THREE SCHOOLS VERSUS
DIVISION ONE SCHOOLS- ED THE-
FAMILY EXPERIENCE OF A BROTHER
WHO PLAY BASEBALL SEAMERS CALLS
ON A FULL RIDE OPTED TO LEAVE TO
GO TO SAC STATE- IN GIVE UP A
SCHOLARSHIP- TOOK TO PLAY IN A
DIVISION TO SYSTEM THAT WAS.
ACTUALLY MORE PROMINENT- FOR HIM
BUT- IN MUCH. TO THE SO THE
PEOPLE MAKE DECISIONS BUT HIS
DECISION WASN'T PREDICATED ON-
YOU KNOW SURVIVAL- ECONOMICALLY
SO. I THINK. I GUESS WHEN TRYING
TO SAY IS I'M TO SUPPORT IT BUT
HE I THINK. PEOPLE ARE ASKED FOR
THAT SPREADSHEET WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO THE U. S. C. WE'RE ST
MERRY'S VERSES THE SACK STATE
VERSUS THE- AND PART OF ST
MARY'S COLLEGE'S DIVISION THREE
NO AND NEVER. THE ROOT THERE WAS
ANYWAY EVEN HELP SCHOOL REVENUE
I DON'T THINK- AT ANY LEVEL. TO
DIVIDE UP. IN AND I GUESS I FIND
THAT COMPELLING. PRINTERS WITH
THE AUTHORS SAY IN IN THE WITH
THE WITNESS IT ISN'T GOING TO
MATTER AT. IT MOST OF THESE- A
SCHOOLS THAT ARE DIVISION TWO
DIVISION SPORTS SCHOOLS- THEY'RE
NOT COULD BE IMPACTED BY THE
BILL WHO'S GOING TO BE IMPACTED
ARE THE ONES WHO ARE RUNNING
THE- BIG F. WILL PROGRAMS THAT.
ARE NOT GETTING A HUNDRED FIFTY
BUCKS FOR YOU THEY'RE- UP FOR
THE BANNERS- HERE THE
SPONSORSHIP BANNERS BUT-
GETTING- YOU KNOW MAYBE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR TWO THOUSAND
OR THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
THAT BECAUSE OR MORE BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN A IN A MAJOR SPORTS
FACILITY AND- THEY'RE NOT.
DISTRIBUTING THAT REVENUE.
EQUITABLY AMONG THE ATHLETES
THEMSELVES THE ATHLETES DON'T
REALLY HAVE A WAY TO EVEN THAT
UP SO ALIVE IT'S GOING BUT-
HOPEFULLY. HOPEFULLY AS AS A YOU
CAN HELP PROVIDE. YOU KNOW SOME
MORE THAT INFORMATION TO THE
FOLKS AS TO WHO'S IMPACTED AND
WHO'S NOT AT THE END OF THE DAY
. IT A I'M AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU CENTER COURT. ANY
OTHER COME COME. I DO HAVE A
MOTION THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE CENTER BRADFORD
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
AND I HEAR LOUD AND CLEAR ALL
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
REYES AND THAT'S WHY WE TOOK
MANY OF THE MEMBERS TO TRY TO
PAIR THIS THING DOWN AND I THINK
YOU ALL TOUCHED UPON. REALLY THE
GENESIS OF THIS FOR THOSE SCREWS
ARE NOT GENERATING REVENUE THIS
WILL HAVE NO IMPACT ON
WHATSOEVER IT'S GOING TO BE THE
SAME AS IT IS TODAY THE NUMBER
OF COLLEGE ABOUT FLEETS TO. THE
HOWEVER THE SCHOOLS SCHOOLS ARE
FUNDING THESE PROGRAMS IT'S FOR
THOSE GENERATING REVENUE
GENERATORS THAT. EXCEED THAT
SCHOLARSHIP MONEY THAT WE ASK
THAT IT BE EQUITABLY EQUITABLY.
DISTRIBUTED AMONGST ATHLETES IN
INCENTIVIZE GRADUATIONS AGAIN
IF. YOU'RE IN A DIVISION TWO OR
DIVISION THREE SCHOOL THAT'S NOT
GENERATING REVENUE. WILL HAVE AN
ABSOLUTELY NO IMPACT. ON THEIR
CURRENT OPERATIONS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE MAKING SURE OF
ANYTHING OF THOSE HIGH REVENUE
GENERATING SHOES AGAIN WE'RE
SEEING THOSE PROGRAMS ARE BEING
FUNDED TODAY WILL CONTINUE TO BE
FUNDED IT'S ABOVE AND BEYOND.
THAT FUNDING LEVEL THAT THOSE
REVENUES ARE. THE NEW REVENUES
AS A AS A OUR WITNESS SAYS IT'S
FOR NEW REVENUES IT'S NOT. WORTH
WHAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY PAYING
OUT AND SCHOLARSHIPS ARE-
OVERALL- BUDGETING SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK I HEAR YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
ADDRESS- THOSE ISSUES IF IN FACT
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
THE BILL OF A MOVE BY STATE OR
MCGUIRE MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS SB
FOURTEEN ZERO ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. LEYVA HI
LEYVA I WILL TROUBLED NOT VOTING
. PARTISI COURTESY IDOLING.
GLAZER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PENCE
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT SENATOR
RUBIO IS UP NEXT WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
READY SAID IN A RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- TODAY I'M- HAPPY TO
KEEP BEARD TO PRESENT TO UP MY
BILL SB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
WHICH ADDS AN ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVE TO THE GREAT SPAN
ADJUSTMENT TO ENSURE MOST
STUDENTS RECEIVE INDIVIDUALIZED
ATTENTION AND INTERACTIONS WITH
THEIR TEACHERS THIS BILL
ENCOURAGES SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO REDUCE THE
CLASS SIZE. AND BY ADDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING INCENTIVES AS
A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS I CAN ATTEST
FIRST HAND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
WHEN YOU HAVE TO MANAGE A REALLY
LARGE CLASS SIZE IT TAKES THE
ATTENTION AWAY FROM EACH CHILD
WHO SOMETIMES NEEDS SO MUCH
ATTENTION AND THEY DESERVE
CALIFORNIA IS BEHIND THE NATION
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS PER TEACHER. SOME
CLASSES ARE OVER THIRTY STUDENTS
AND YET CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENTS HIGHER THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE EVERY CHILD IS
DEFINITELY AND SMALLER CLASS
SIZES ALLOW THE TEACHER TO GIVE
THAT PERSONAL INSTRUCT
PERSONALIZED INSTRUCTION TO
STUDENTS TO INCREASE THEIR
ACADEMIC AND PERSONAL
ACHIEVEMENTS MEMBERS I
PERSONALLY KNOW BECAUSE I'VE HAD
CLASSES OF OVER THIRTY STUDENTS
. IT MEANS IT DOES MEAN LAST. UP
ATTENTION FOR EACH STUDENT YOU
CANNOT GIVE THEM THAT INDIVIDUAL
ICE- ATTENTION LAST TIME TO
TUTOR AND CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP. BUT ALSO MORE IMPORTANTLY
LESS TIME TO COMMUNICATE WITH
PARENTS AND CREATE THE NECESSARY
PARTNERSHIPS AND RELATIONSHIPS
THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENTS SUCCEED. AND STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN CALIFORNIA AS A
CLASS SIZE REDUCTION PROGRAM
PERFORM BETTER THAN STUDENTS
REMAIN IN LARGER CLASSES
ESPECIALLY AMONG LOWER INCOME
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR. STUDIES
ALSO SHOW THAT TEACHERS FEEL
MORE POSITIVE AND THEIR ABILITY
TO ASSESS AND MEET THE THEIR
SPECIAL NEEDS I CAN SHARE FOR
AGAIN FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE TEACHING. THAT I HAD
TWENTY STUDENTS THE AVERAGE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY STUDENTS IN
MY CLASS AND AFTER THE CRISIS IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. MY CLASS WHO WENT UP TO
UP TO THIRTY FOUR STUDENTS WHICH
REALLY IMPACTED THE WAY I WAS
ABLE TO INSTRUCT MY CLASS I
DEDICATED PRIOR TO THE CRISIS I
DEDICATED MOST OF MY TIME TO
TUTORING BEFORE SCHOOL DURING
RECESS LUNCH AFTER SCHOOL. THAT
WAS ABLE TO REALLY CLOSE THE
TREATMENT GAP SOMETIMES UP TO
TWO GREAT LEVELS AFTER MY CLASS
WENT UP TO THIRTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR STUDENTS AND REALLY MY TIME
WAS SPENT. GRADING MORE PAPERS
SIDE. HOW TO SOME PLANS REALLY
INDIVIDUALIZED INSTRUCTIONAL
INSTRUCTION FOR ABOUT THREE TO
FOUR LEVELS THAT WE HAD IN OUR
CLASSROOMS AND SO I THINK IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE TIME THAT TEACHERS FAMILIES
STUDENTS IS CRITICAL THE ONE ON
ONE TIME TO JUST SEE WHERE
THEY'RE AT AND REALLY GIVE THAT
PERSONAL TIME IS VITAL BUT AGAIN
AFTER THE TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT CRISIS THAT PERSONAL TIME
AND ABILITY FOR US TO- CLOSE THE
TREATMENT GAP REALLY DID THAT
INITIALLY. AND SO TODAY WE ARE
HAVE TO CONSIDER HOW DO WE
PRICES STATE SURPLUS LEAVE THAT
THIS INVESTMENT IN OUR CHILDREN
IS CRITICAL AND I THINK THAT-
THE FOUNDATION S. AS BUILDS FROM
KEIICHI THROUGH THREE AND IF WE
MAKE SURE THAT OUR CHILDREN
LEAVE K. THROUGH THREE BOB WITH
A STRONG FOUNDATION AND MAKES IT
EASIER FOR THEM TO MOVE THROUGH
THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AND BE.
OR LIKE. CAN ONLY HELP THE
CHILDREN BUT IT ALSO HELPS THE
TEACHERS THAT ARE STRUGGLING
ESPECIALLY WITH THIS PANDEMIC
WILL WITH SUCH. A LEARNING LOSS
THAT WE'RE SEEING AND SO AGAIN
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TWO GREAT
ADVANTAGES WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
BILL NUMBER ONE IS THAT CLASS
SIZE REDUCTION HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED BEFORE. SO THERE IS
A MODEL WE KNOW HOW. SECOND WE
DO. BUDGET SURPLUS TOOK TO IT
ACHIEVE THIS. SO FURTHERMORE I
YOU KNOW I ALSO AM WORKING ON
COMPLEMENTARY LEGISLATION THAT I
KNOW- HAVE BEEN RAISED AS
CONCERNS AND- AND THAT IS
REMOVING BARRIERS FOR. OUR
TEACHER CANDIDATES TO WANT TO
COME INTO THE PROFESSION AND
ALSO PRETTY WORKING ON
ADDRESSING THE TEACHER SHORTAGE.
BUT AT THE ACADEMIC OF PROGRESS
AND SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS IS
REALLY CRITICAL TO ESSAY
REQUIRES TO FOR US TO DO THAT.
THE WORK INTO IT TO GET IT DONE
AND SO- NOT ONLY FOR THE FUTURE
OF THE STATE BUT I THINK IT'S
ALSO OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO GET
OUR CHILDREN WHERE THEY NEED TO
BE. SB EIGHT FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
JUST SIMPLY ADDS THE INCENTIVES
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS. SO THEY CAN RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BUT I REALLY
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THIS IS
VOLUNTARY NOT MANDATORY. SO THAT
THIS IS FOR- SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT THEY WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
THAT. THE ROOM CAPACITY THE
TEACHER CAPACITY TO GET THIS
DONE- ON THE- I MAY I WANTED TO
DO MIGHT MEAN WE I AM MARK SAID
IN A SPECIAL FROM A UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I ALSO HAVE
EDGAR CABRAL WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE JUST FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO OF MS MARTINEZ YOU
ARE UP YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE- GOOD
AFTERNOON. MISS CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANGELA
MARTINEZ AND I'M A TEACHER
EDUCATION SPECIALIST AT ABC
UNIFIED SCHOOL EXPECTSTO FIND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE. I HAVE BEEN A
TEACHER FOR SEVEN YEARS WORKING
IN EDUCATION IN THE CLASSROOM
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS AND
THAT CAN HELP CRITICAL SMALLER
CLASS SIZES ARE NEEDED TO HELP
ADVANCE THE ACADEMIC SUCCESS AND
WELL BEING OF OUR STUDENTS. IT
IS EXTREMELY DIVERSE. STUDENTS
WITH DIFFERENT. WITH DIFFERENT
ACADEMIC LEVELS IN OVERSIGHT
CLASSROOMS. NO MATTER HOW MUCH
YOU ALL TO YOUR LESSON PLANS IT
IS IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF ALL OF YOUR STUDENTS. I HAVE
SEEN STUDENTS GET LOST IN THE
SHUFFLE WITH OVERSIGHT
CLASSROOMS STUDENTS LEARN HOW TO
FADE INTO THE BACKGROUND AND DO
NOT RECEIVE THE ATTENTION AND
THE FOCUS THEY SO DESPERATELY
NEED. THIS CAUSES LOW SELF
ESTEEM AND STUDENTS AND IN MANY
CASES STUDENTS AND GIVE UP
BECAUSE THEY HAVE FALLEN BEHIND.
AS A TEACHER I STRIVE TO MAKE
SURE MY STUDENTS ARE. THE
SUCCESSFUL BUT BECAUSE OF THE
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS IN MY CLASS
LIST THIS IS DIFFICULT TO
ACHIEVE. THERE ARE SO MANY.
MINUTES I HAVE TO READ
EVERYTHING FOR EACH SUBJECT.
ACCORDING TO PROVIDE ALL
STUDENTS WITH AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN TO RECEIVE
SPECIALIZED ATTENTION AND TO
PROVIDE EVERYONE WITH THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED. INTO THE
STUDY IN THE JOURNAL OF POLICY
ANALYSIS AND MANAGEMENT. STATES
THAT ATTENDING SMALL CONCRETE AS
THE PROBABILITY OF EARNING A
COLLEGE DEGREE AND TEACHES
STUDENTS TOWARD EARNING DEGREES
AND HIGH EARNING FIELDS SUCH AS
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
AND MATHEMATICS BUSINESS AND
ECONOMICS. WE TEACHERS DO OUR
BEST ALREADY NOW BUT IT IS
DIFFICULT WHEN THERE IS A
LIMITED TIME BECAUSE WE HAVE SO
MANY STUDENTS WE NEED TO ATTEND
TO. BECAUSE WE ARE STILL COMING
UP. TEACHERS NEED TO BE
COGNIZANT THAT PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH NOT JUST THE ACADEMIC
SUPPORT BUT ALSO THE SOCIAL
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORT TO
ESTABLISH NURTURING
RELATIONSHIPS AND HELP THEM
SUCCEED LATER ON IN SCHOOL. SB
FORTY THIRTY ONE WHAT DO THAT.
IT WILL ALLOW STUDENTS TO
RECEIVE CRITICAL INDIVIDUALIZED
ATTENTION AND INTERACTION WITH
TEACHERS. I INTERRUPTED BY THE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY TO LOWER
THE STUDENT TO RATIO TEACHER TO
TWENTY ONE AND K<c.cyan> THREE</c>
CLASSROOMS. SENATOR MENTIONED
THIS BILL AS AN INCENTIVE FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND ADJUSTMENT OF THIRTY
TWO POINT 5% OF THE BASE GROUND
THEY MAINTAIN AN AVERAGE
POSSIBLE MEANT OF LESS THAN
TWENTY STUDENTS. IT AFTER. MALL
AND- TO. WELL BUT PLEASE. THANK
YOU AGAIN YOUR TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
TERRIFIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SINCE MR CABRAL IS HERE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND LOOK FOR ANYONE IN
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AND SUPPORT
SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MADAME MODERATOR FEW
QUEUE UP ANYONE IN. OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE PLEASE.
THANK YOU THINK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GET OUR LINE
NUMBERS.
I'LL GO TO LINE TWO TWO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN. OKAY MY NAME IS I
THINK THIS YEAR- I WORK AS A
COMMUNITY SERVICES SPECIALIST IN
MY LOOK BEFORE DISTRICTS- WHAT
AUTHORED BY AND MY STUDENTS AND
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I'M HERE
THANK OF ORDER SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE THIRTY THE CARD FOR
YOU NEEDED SIXTY FIFTH EXPRESS.
I MEAN THANK YOU AND WITH THE
TEACHER THANK YOU MA'AM WE'RE
JUST CALL FOR NAY AND SOME.
PLEASE THANK YOU NEXT CALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THAT IS ALL
I HAVE Q. ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD WE
HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITE. AND I SEE
NO ONE HERE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
MATTER MODERATE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES WISHES TO- BY IN
OPPOSITION TO IT. CAN THIRTY ONE
PLEASE. HE WISH YOU CAN
OPPOSITION SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THAT IS ONE NINE
ZERO IN YOUR PHONE. AND I HAVE
NO ONE IN CARE GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BY THE MODERATOR WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED THE SENATE REVIEW
WHICH I TO CLOSE. AT THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY NOT JUST
YOU KNOW WANT TO POINT OUT
REALLY QUICKLY THAT COME BACK
FROM A ALONG PANDEMIC AND HAVING
TO STAY HOME AND SOON OUR
STUDENTS WILL NOT ONLY COME BACK
WITH. EXTRA NEEDS IN TERMS OF
EDUCATION BUT A LOT OF EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT GOING TO NEED IT NEEDS
KLOPP SORT JUST CAN. BY THAT
EMOTIONAL AND I ASK FOR YOUR
THANK YOU THANK YOU RUBIO THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
DOLE IN. PALM CALL THE ROLL FILE
NUMBER EIGHT SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE MOTIONS TO PASSED THE FIRST
RIVER. YEAH TIONS LEYVA I LEYVA
AYE OTOBO. AYE WHICH WILL. DALY
HI PLEASE. REQUIRE YOUR THREE
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT THANK YOU CENTER OF. WELL
I GUESS I CAN GO UP MEADOW VICE
CHAIRMAN A HAND TO THE GAVEL.
I'LL BRING IT TO YOU. THE.
HI. WELCOME SENATOR LEYVA YOU
MAY PRESENT BILLS YOUR BILL SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR ROACH HOBO
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBER I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON
PAGES FOUR AND FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
HELP TO IT SURE AND EVERY
TEACHER CALIFORNIA HAS
RETIREMENT SECURE. FIRES SEVEN
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL NEW
EACH CREATE CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
CALPERS AND THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEM CALPERS. ACCORDING TO CAL
STIRS 2240% OF NEWLY CREATED
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE OPTING FOR
AN ALTERNATIVE RETIREMENT
SYSTEM. BY NOT ALLOWING TEACHERS
TO ACCESS THE DEFINED BENEFIT
SYSTEM TEACHERS ARE LEFT WITH
RETIREMENT OPTIONS THAT CAN
DEPEND FAR TOO MUCH ON THE STOCK
MARKET. EMPLOYEES AT CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHICH ARE FUNDED BY
PUBLIC. DESERVE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE SAME RETIREMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AS ALL OTHER
EMPLOYEES ALL TEACHERS SHOULD
HAVE THE SAME OPTIONS REGARDLESS
OF THE PUBLIC SCHOOL THEY DECIDE
TO TEACH AT. TEACHERS ALREADY DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS THE CITY
SHOULD NOT BE FURTHER HAMPERED
FINANCIALLY EVEN MORE BY NOT
HAVING ACCESS TO CAL STIRS IN
CALPERS. SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
ALSO PUT SAFE IN PLACE POOR
TARMAC PAYMENTS WHEN A CHARTER
SCHOOL FALLS BEHIND OR SHUTS ITS
DOORS COMPLETELY. WHEN THIS
HAPPENS COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WHICH PART IS
CHARGED LOOK. HAS BEEN HARD TO
PAY THE BILL. THE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION WITH TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AN
UNEXPECTED AND UNWARRANTED
RETIREMENT PAYMENT OBLIGATIONS
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY. THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE CORRECT THIS BY
REQUIRING COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO WITHHOLD A
REASONABLE PORTION OF A CHARTER
SCHOOL FUNDING DISPLACEMENT AND
PAY THE RENT. CATIONS SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE IS ABOUT
PROVIDING ALL PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SECURITY THAT THEY
DESERVE TEACHERS GUIDE SUPPORT
AND EDUCATE OUR NEXT GENERATION
LEADERS THE LEAST WE CAN DO IS
GIVE THEM ACCESS TO A SECURE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. WITH ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS TRISTEN
BROWN CALIFORNIA CAN OF TEACHERS
MEMBERS AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH S. LEYVA WE
WILL NOW BEGIN WITH. DO IN
PERSON HERE YOUR PERFECT PLEASE
RECEIPTS ARE RECOMMENDED SHARE
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS STRESSING
RENDON CFT YOUR SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL- WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS- REALLY DO SOME REPAIR
WORK AND HOLD OUR RETIREMENT
SECURITY SYSTEMS HARMLESS FROM
SOME OF JUST THE- ISSUES THAT
HAVE COME UP CHARTER SCHOOL.
BEING SOME AND SOME OUT OF THE
STATE RETIREMENT SYSTEM- THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
TO PARTICIPATE AND STARS- WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT EDUCATORS KNOW WHEN TEACHER
TO TRADITIONAL OR CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT THEY ARE PUBLIC EDUCATORS
AS WE ALL KNOW THEY WORK IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL WHICH BOTH
CHARTERS AND TRADITIONAL DARK.
AND SO THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE AND BE MEMBERS FOR
THEIR- PUBLIC RETIREMENT SYSTEM
THERE ARE SOME OF THE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES FOR TEACHERS THEY
DO NOT. AND TYERMAN IF YOU DO
SPEND SOME TIME. IN YOUR
TEACHING PROFESSION TEACHING AT
A CHARTER SCHOOL WHO'S NOT A
PARTICIPATING STORES TODAY.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE LOSING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
YOU OTHERWISE WOULD BE ACCRUING
CREDIT IN YOUR SISTER'S-
PENSION- OBLIGATION. AND SO WHAT
WE WANNA DO IS LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD MAKE SURE THAT ALL PUBLIC
EDUCATORS HAVE A SECURE PUBLIC
RETIREMENT AS ANY TRADITIONAL
SCHOOL TEACHER HAS. I AND OF
COURSE FOR THE CLASSIFIED AS
WELL THAT IF THEY ARE WORKING AT
CHARTER SCHOOL THEY ARE STILL
MEMBERS OF PURPOSE JUST AS THEY
WOULD BE IN ANY OTHER
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL. THIS IS
REALLY ALSO IN REACTION TO
CERTAIN SCHOOLS THAT HAVE CLOSED
DOWN. LEAVING UNPAID BILLS THE
SYSTEM IN WHICH WE THE TAXPAYERS
THAN HALF BACK FILL IT PAY THOSE
BILLS. COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ARE WHERE THE BUCK
STOPS FOR THESE SORT OF ISSUES.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS CREATE
AN AUTOMATIC PAYMENT PROGRAM SO
THAT WHEN A CHARTER IS-
ESTABLISHED WE WILL BE MEMBERS
OF THE SYSTEMS THEIR WORKERS
WILL ACCRUE THEIR CREDIT. IF
ANYTHING HAPPENS DOWN THE LINE
AND THE SCHOOL HAS TO CLOSE BY
THEIR ENROLLMENT HAS CHANGED OR
THE FCUS IS CHANGED. THE
PAYMENTS. AFTER AS THEY FLOW
DOWN FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF ADD
TO THE CHARTER SCHOOL COUNTY
OFFICE WE'LL SEE WHAT THE
PENSION OBLIGATION IS.
AUTOMATICALLY DEDUCT THAT
AMOUNT. EVERY PAYMENT AND SEND
THE REST OF THE MONTH. IN HAVE
TO MANAGE. TYERMAN PLANNED IN
THIS INSTANCE IT IS ALL
AUTOMATED FOR THEM AND THIS
AGAIN IS ALL ABOUT SECURITY FOR
THE SYSTEM AND THE RETIREMENT OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE WORKING
AT THOSE SCHOOLS. WE THINK THIS
IS A VERY GOOD COMMONSENSE
MEASURE TO HELP PREVENT SOME OF
THE THINGS WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST. IT'S NOT A OF RAPID
PROBLEM BUT IT IS A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM WITH SCHOOL SHUT DOWN
LEAVING UNFUNDED LIABILITIES FOR
THE REST OF US HAVE TO PAY FOR
IT IN STORES LAST ANALYSIS OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS WITHIN THEIR
SYSTEM HAVE NOTED. THAT EVERYONE
ELSE. BECAUSE OF THE SLOW LEAK.
OF CHARTER'S NOT PARTICIPATING
IN THE SYSTEM SO. AGAIN IF
YOU'RE PUBLIC EDUCATOR. YOU WORK
IN A PUBLIC EDUCATION FACILITY.
YOU ARE IN A PUBLIC RETIREMENT
SYSTEM. AND THERE'S NO. OTHER
WOULD NEED TO COMPLICATE THE
SYSTEM SO WITH THAT WE ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE NO. BE HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TRISTEN- WE WILL NOW
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. WELL
CENTER BOROUGH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SEEN NO OTHER WITNESSES WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. AT THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE WE WILL WEEKEND.
BEACON SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. LET'S
START WITH LINE TWO TWO FIVE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD- HELLO THANK
FROM BOTH SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND- I DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN HERE RIGHT NOW.
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD WILL WANT
TO CHECK. HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY ONE HAS LEAD OPPOSITION SO
WE WILL NOW MOVE. WE DO. I
APOLOGIZE YES WE DO HAVE AT.
OKAY SO WE HAVE ERRANDS STUTTER-
DR AARON SNYDER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CHINE CHARTER
SCHOOL ON THE LINE- AND YOU.
MISTER SUTTER ARE YOU ON THE
LINE HERE IS YES I AM I'M HERE
PLEASE OF RECEIPTS ARE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU SO MUCH- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TERRENCE TO THEIR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF TIME
CHARTER SCHOOL LOS ANGELES. I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN CHARTER SCHOOL IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE. CHANTERS SCHOOL WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
WE SERVE SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
STUDENTS WITH THE PHONE BEING A
NATIONAL DEMONSTRATION SITE FOR
FALL INCLUSION. OF ALL LEARNERS
IN THE GENERAL EDUCATION
CLASSROOMS AND ACTING AS A
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SCHOOL
FOR THE COLLEGE OF EDUCATION AT
CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE REPORTER
THE TEACHERS AND A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR EMPLOYEES. WHEN
TIMES ARE STEP WHICH STIRS IN
PERSON NOT A LOT. SOME. SIX AS A
FIVE ONE THREE OPERATING A
CHARTER SCHOOL THEREFORE CHINA
STEP ITS OWN GOT PENNED PLAN
CONSISTING OF MATCH EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS AND LIKE
PERSONS STIRS CHIMES PROGRAM
OFFERS A DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION
TO ITS RETIREES WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR STATED INTENT TO
AMEND THE BILL HOWEVER CONCERNS
STILL REMAIN CURRENTLY DRAFTED
SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE COULD
JEOPARDIZE THE RECAP PLAN TO
MANY OF OUR EMPLOYEES EMPLOYEES
AND THEN POSE MANDATE ACOSTA
GREATLY DIMINISHED THE HIGH
QUALITY SERVICES FOR STUDENTS
THAT ARE AT THE CORE OF
TRANSMISSION. BUT EVEN WITH THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WE NOW GO TO
SCHOOL LIKE TIME COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO START UP IF WE
COULD NOT HAVE LOCAL CHOICES
ABOUT OUR INVESTMENT IN STUDENT
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. OPTION
EMPLOY WHICH- WOULD ELIMINATING
THIS DISC FOR SCHOOL WILL IN THE
- IN A BAY. NEW CHARTERS.
FURTHER MANDATING AND- YOU TRUST
GRAY THE COP THE OPERATION. AND
THE LEGAL STRUCTURE OF EXISTING
SUCCESSFUL SCHOOLS BY TRYING. WE
WERE ABLE TO REPLICATE THE
PROGRAM WITH NEW SCHOOLS WITHIN
OUR ORGANIZATION. FOR THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS CHARTER SCHOOLS
HAVE BEEN OPERATING WITH THE
OPTION TO PARTICIPATE IN STIRS
AND CURSE WHILE BASS MAJORITY OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE PLANS.
SOME OFFER ALTERNATIVE PLANS FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS. WE SEE NO
COMPELLING REASON TO ELIMINATE
PENSION OPTIONS LIKE PROGRAM
THAT OUR EMPLOYEES. HAPPILY
PARTICIPATED IN FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. UNFORTUNATELY SCHOOL
FUNDING IS NEVER SUFFICIENT AND
WE MUST CONSTANTLY BALANCE THE
NEEDS OF OUR STATE. AND THOSE
ONE PLEASE WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES. FOR THESE REASONS WE
MUST. BE THIRTEEN FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THESE ISSUES AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SOUDER ALSO
HAVE COLIN MILLER- ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. IS A IS IN PERSON. AT
THE BACK OF. OKAY PERFECT SO
JUST AS A BACK UP AND WE DID
HAVE MISTER SCOOTER SO HAVING
HEARD FROM OUR LEAD AT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE
WILL NOW BEGIN TO WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED. SEEING NONE THANK
YOU. AND TWO WITNESSES WHEN TO
TESTIFY TO THE TELECONFERENCE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE WE WILL
BEGIN. YOU CAN OPPOSITION OF
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. AND WE'LL START WITH LINE ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ALEX AND THE OTHER ON
THE FOUNDER ENVIRONMENTAL
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND AYE OPPOSED
SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR IF YOU- WELL WHEN I
THINK OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOW BE BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CALL. CONSIDER
GLAZER. ATTY THANK YOU- CENTER
LED BY HE WAS USING THE RESTROOM
SO I MISTER OPENING DID YOU TAKE
THE CANADIAN AND THAT'S IT THANK
YOU FOR SHARING THAT AS A PART
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT YOUR
BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY TO NEW
CHARTER SCHOOLS IS THAT CORRECT
OF. CLARIFY AND I HEARD FROM OUR
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT EARLIER
THAT THERE WAS SOME PROBLEMS
WITH SOME CHARTER SCHOOLS NOT
BEING ABLE TO PAY THEIR
RETIREMENT DO YOU HAVE ANY MORE
DETAILS ON ON THAT IN TERMS OF
HOW MANY CHARTER SCHOOLS PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT THAT HAVE.
IN A REFER TO MY WITNESS. MR
TRISTEN ARE. US SENATOR OF YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS
OCCURRENCES WITH THE ALLOW THE
TRI VALLEY CHARTER SCHOOL FIASCO
IN THE- TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS UNPAID- THERE IT'S HARD
TO COLLECT QUANTITATIVE DATA
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE THERE
AREN'T ANY MANDATES TO SHARE
IDEAS THE RETIREMENT SYSTEMSON
THAT WHAT THEY CAN TELLS THAN
WHEN SOMEONE IS ON THE BOOKS
AND- THERE'S NO LONGER COME FOR
THEM THEN THAT'S WHAT GO TO THE
OFFICE. BUT WE- NUMBER LET'S SEE
THIS MIGHT BE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH SOME FIGURED OUT ALSO HOW
MANY PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
THERE IN CALIFORNIA TODAY LAST I
CHECKED I BELIEVE WERE AROUND
TWELVE TO THIRTEEN HUNDRED OKAY
AND I AM FROM THAT WITH THAT ONE
CASE THAT WAS I DO. MORE FROM
THERE THAN MOST MIGHT BE BUT YOU
KNOW MOST OF THE TIME WHEN THAT
THESE THINGS IMPLODE THERE'S A
LOT OF NEWS ABOUT IT THAT JUST
ABOUT WE'RE STIRS INFO.
OF THE TWELVE OR THIRTEEN
HUNDRED CHARTER SCHOOLS YOU TELL
ME HOW MANY OVER THE LAST. TEN
YEARS HAVE. BEEN CREATED A
RETIREMENT CRISIS AS YOU
DESCRIBED. I DON'T HAVE A HARD
NUMBER FOR YOU BUT I CAN WORK
WITH STORES TO TRY TO FIGURE
THAT AND COME BACK TO IT OKAY NO
I APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE I'M
NOT VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE AD
THAT BEGAN AT A CRISIS AND WE
HAVE- WE HAD BAD LAWYERS WE HAVE
BAD DOCTORS WE HAVE BAD
LEGISLATORS DOESN'T MAKE SYSTEM
ALL BOND SO. I THAT APPLE YOU
GAVE IT. GOOD EXAM OF. YOU KNOW
BEUST REAL ABUSE OF OUR PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS AT THAT MAKES
ALL THIS DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED- I
GUESS IS I LOOK AT THIS BILL I
THINK THAT IN SOME WAYS ARE KIND
OF REAP FIGHTING AN EXISTING
AGREEMENT THE- PATTERNS FOR HOW.
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS WERE TO
CONDUCT THEMSELVES INCLUDING IN
REGARD TO BUT THE RETIREMENT.
CIRCUMSTANCES SOMETHING THAT.
WERE VISITING IN THIS BILL AND
LET ME JUST SAY THAT I. I
SUPPORT- YOU KNOW A I WANT A
ROBUST. THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM
FOR ALL OF OUR- SCHOOL TO. AND
WHEREVER THEY ARE WHETHER IT'S
IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL COMMUNITY
WHETHER IT'S ENOUGH SCHOOL. THE
BILL EITHER. PUBLIC THAT. THE
METAL TAG WE'RE ALL. EIGHT GUARD
. ARTIST THE STAFF PUSH ONE OF
THE SCHOOL. I CHARGE AT LEAST
THAT THEY PER. AND ALTER EVERY
BENEFIT AND THEY HAVE CHOICES
AND THAT COULD BE SOCIAL
SECURITY. AND YOU KNOW THERE'S
SOME ISSUES OF SOCIAL SECURITY
BUT WE WON'T GET INTO THOSE HERE
TODAY. AS WELL AS A- A FOUR OH
ONE K. PROGRAM- AS WELL AS AS
CASTERS SO IT SEEMS LIKE AND
LESS THOSE ARE FLAWED SYSTEMS.
THAT THOSE CHOICES ARE
LEGITIMATE CHOICES HAPPENED- IT
RAISES QUESTIONS AS TO WHY WOULD
WE REVISIT THAT CHOICE YOUR DAY
AND THE ONLY THING THAT I CAN
SEE ON THE RECORD. ABOUT THE
REASON TO PUT IT OUT SEVEN
ANECDOTE ABOUT OF A CHARTER
SCHOOL FAILING IS THAT. SOMEHOW
IT'S IT SUPPORTS THE SYSTEM THE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. I DON'T THINK
THERE ARE ENOUGH CHARTER SCHOOLS
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE AS YOU
**** WILL BE PROSPECTIVE SO I
DON'T THINK WE AND OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS OPEN. PRESS IT BUILD UP
THIS WHICH THE SYSTEM FOR ME
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE A DEFINED BENEFIT
PENSION THAT TIRE IN DIG UP THE
BIGGEST GROUP OF PEOPLE LIVING
IN POVERTY TODAY ARE WOMEN OVER
SIXTY FIVE MOST OF OUR TEACHERS
IN ANY SCHOOL SETTING OUR LIMITS
SO THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WOMEN AND TEACHERS OF UP TO
HAVE A SECURE RETIREMENT I WOULD
SAY THAT I DON'T LOOK AT A FOUR
ONE K. AS A GREAT RETIREMENT
FROM THE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY AT
THE- RECEIPT OF THE- MARKET. THE
TO. PUT PENSION YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO RECEIVE EVERY
SINGLE MONTH AND YOU CAN PLAN
YOUR LIFE AROUND US SO FOR ME
THIS IS A- BILL THAT IS ABOUT
THE SECURITY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING AND MAKING SURE WHEN
THEY RETIRE. THEY CAN BE SECURE
IN THE RETIREMENT. IT IS NOT
GOING TO PROP UP CAL STIRS ARE
CALPERS AT. THAT ALTHOUGH THERE
WAS A- IN THE IN HOUSE TO TALK
ABOUT HOW. A NEW FOLKS COME IN
THE SYSTEM WOULD PROVIDE GREATER
CAPITAL THAT WOULD. IMPROVE THE
THAT THE STABILITY IS CERTAINLY
PUT MORE MONEY INTO SOMETHING
IT'S GOING TO IT'S GOING TO HELP
BUT IT WILL NOT IT WOULD NOT
PROP UP THE SYSTEM THERE'S JUST
NOT ENOUGH MONEY. THERE WOULD
NOT BE ENOUGH PEOPLE
PROSPECTIVELY TO DO THAT. THINGS
IT'S PRETTY COOL. THAT OUR
ATTENTION SYSTEMS BOTH CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS HAVE BEEN UNDER
WATER FOR QUITE SOME TIME AND-
AND THEY'RE SUBJECT TO THE STOCK
MARKET TO. IN TERMS OF THE GOING
UP AND GOING IN A VERY DIFFERENT
WAY I WILL NOT A PENSION FUND
FOR TWELVE YEARS AND- WHAT HOW
THEY NEGOTIATE HOW AN INDIVIDUAL
HAS A FOUR ONE K. VERY DIFFERENT
. IT ALL THAT SET UP PRIVATE
OCEAN FRONT RIGHT DID RIGHT AND
SO YOU HAVE ACTUALLY MORE
FLEXIBILITY- THEN OUR PUBLIC
PENSION FUNDS IN TERMS OF
DEALING WITH THAT TYPE OF A
CRISIS THAT IS CORRECT AND- BUT
IN IN THE CASE OF OUR PUBLIC
PENSION FUNDS- IF WE DON'T.
AREN'T ABLE TO MEET. THE DEFAULT
BENEFITS- YOU KNOW OUR OPTIONS
ARE A LOT MORE LIMITED WE CAN'T
GO TO. THE EMPLOYER ITS IT'S- IT
. SHE ALSO ASKED. HER COMPLETELY
ON US IN A PRIVATE PENSION PLAN.
YOU CAN MAKE SOME CHOICES IN
THAT SPACE AND I'M SURE THAT
YOU'RE PROPERLY HAVE DONE THAT-
BUT IT IT DIED. I GUESS FOR ME
THIS IS A THIS IS A BILL THIS IS
A THIS IS ROUTE RE FIGHTING
SOMETHING THAT. I DON'T. KNOW
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO RE FIGHT
THERE'S NO CLEAR EVIDENCE ON THE
RECORD THAT WE HAVE A REAL
PROBLEM OUT THERE. THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO OF. THAT THE BEAUTY OF
THE PUBLIC CHARTER MOVEMENT IS
TO BE GIVE GIVE THEM THANKS FOR
THE IN CHOICE. I AM SURE THAT
HOW THEY WANT TO DO THEIR THING.
THEY'VE BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
SUCCESSFUL. THE NUMBER OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAS BEEN PUT ON
THE RECORD IS. HAS BEEN GROWING
FOR A LONG TIME AND PARENTS SEEM
TO BE PRETTY PLEASED. THAT IT
SHOULDN'T MATTER. CREATIVITY IN
THOSE CHOICE. HIS ROOMMATE AND
THEN THERE MAKING PARENTS. SELF
I PUSHED. THE THOUGHT THE
INTENTIONS OF THE AUTHOR I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU AND JUST TO BE CLEAR
THIS IS NOT THIS BILL'S NOT
LITIGATING WHETHER WE SHOULD OR
SHOULDN'T HAVE. CHARTER SCHOOLS
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THE
PEOPLE. THE TEACHERS HAVE ACCESS
TO A SECURE RETIREMENT. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH WE SHARE THOSE GOALS.
I DON'T THINK MANDATING A ONE
SOLUTION. THE PUBLIC CHARTERS IS
THE ANSWER TO THAT- GOAL THAT
YOU THE STATE YOU'VE IDENTIFIED
AND I SHARE I SHARE WITH YOU.
HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM OUR MEMBERS. I'M
I WANT TO ECHO THE CONCERNS THAT
SENATOR GLAZER WE SEEN THIS IN
IN IN LABOR AT THE COMMITTEE AND
SO FORTH AND I WENT HOME AND I
WAS YOU KNOW LIKE I GO HOME IN
THE EVENINGS AND I THINK ABOUT
MY VOTED I THINK ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE FURTHER TO TRY TO. SEE
WHETHER OR NOT I WAS ON THE
RIGHT TRACK OR NOT RIGHT TRACK
OR WHAT WE COULD DO BETTER ON
THAT I'M ALWAYS THINKING ABOUT
HOW TO YOU KNOW CREATE GOOD
POLICY I'M AND I WAS HOPEFULLY
WE ALL ARE. ALSO THINKING ABOUT.
M. THE CHOICE AND I THINK YOU
KNOW I AM A- I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR
INSTRUCTION BECAUSE I THINK THAT
IS CONCEPTUALLY THROUGH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IT'S
OUR DUTY TO DO THAT AND MAKING
SURE YOU KNOW THEY HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
THE CONCERN CARE- ARE BUT
SENATOR LEISURE HAS ALSO HAS
CONCERNS BUT ALSO IN ADDITION TO
THAT IS THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
THE RETIREMENT IN THE CHOICES-
ONE. OUR TEACHER. WILL TEACH
HAVE OPTIONS AND CHOICES
THROUGHOUT MAKING TEACH AT A
PUBLIC SCHOOL THEY CAN. TEACH AT
A CHARTER SCHOOL. ANALYZING HOW
MUCH THE PAY WILL BE THE
FLEXIBILITY THE SUBJECT MATTER
HOW MANY STUDENTS- RETIREMENT
BENEFITS THEY ALL TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AS FAR AS THE
PACKAGES GO TO DECIDE THIS IS
THE BEST A SITE OUT FOR ME OR
THE BEST PACKAGE FOR ME SO THEY
HAVE OPTIONS AND I THINK. AB
WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOLS IN WILK
AB REALLY SAID WITH MY FROM MY
COLLEAGUE IS THAT HAVING OPTIONS
AND CHOICES FOR OUR TEACHERS TO
CHOOSE FROM WHAT BEST SUITS THEM
I THINK THAT IS WHAT IS SO- IT'S
VERY MUCH AN AMERICAN IDEAL TO
HAVE CHOICE. FOR THE STATE
LEADERS OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
SAY THIS IS HOW OUR TEACHERS ARE
GOING TO- CONTINUE OR ARE HAPPY
THIS RETIREMENT- WITH THE- IN
SECURITIES THAT WE MAY HAVE
THERE IS NO SECURE SYSTEM IN IN
THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM BECAUSE
AS- MY COLLEAGUE STATED. THEY
ARE DEPENDENT ON ON ON THE
CHOICES THAT WE MAKE INVESTMENTS
CASTERS ANSWERS SO I. SO I AM.
AYE AYE A- I WAS GRAPPLING WITH
THIS BUT I BUT I WANNA JUST MAKE
SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE THERE TO
PROVIDE OPTIONS AND CHOICES THE
STATE COMING IN AND TELLING THEM
THIS IS HOW YOU'RE GOING TO DO
IT. LIMITS THE CHOICES FOR BOTH
pTHAT CHOOSE TO FOLLOW AND I
PACKED UP ON THAT MATTER AND-
SLEEVE THERE WAS ONE OTHER POINT
THAT OUT TO MAKE- AND THAT'S
WITH REGARDS TO- SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE SEEN THIS PAST
YEAR SINCE BEEN ELECTED. IS THAT
OUR SCHOOLS ARE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE SOMETIMES EXCLUDED FROM
CERTAIN FINDINGS- THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS-
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF CHARTER
SCHOOL THAT THEY HAVE SO THEY
HAVE TO GRAPPLE. IN MY IN MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS PAST YEAR- IS A
LITTLE BIT OVER A YEAR THAT.
THEY HAVE GREATER FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES TO OVERCOME BECAUSE
OF THE POLICIES THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE CHOOSES
TO PURSUE WITH REGARDS TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS SO. BY LIMITING
THEM AND HAVING CERTAIN
PARAMETERS AS TO YOU KNOW WHAT
FUNDING THEY CAN AND CANNOT
RECEIVE UNLIKE OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND THEN TO COME IN AND
SAID THIS IS THE- THIS IS YOUR
PATH. TO WITH THEIR RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS YOU YOU YOU HAVE TO TAKE
I THINK IT'S A BIT UNFAIR. TO
OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS AND- THAT'S
THE LAWSUIT HI. THAT'S ALL I
HAVE TO SAY A BIG THANK YOU
SENATOR TOBER WHEN DID YOU FIRST
LEARN WHAT IT DEFINED BENEFIT
PENSION WHAT THIS PAST YEAR OKAY
SO HOW OLD WERE YOU THIS PAST
YEAR AFTER MY DEATH. NOT AT ALL
FORTY NINE FORTY NINE SO WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT FORTY EIGHT OKAY
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TEACHERS
COMING IN AND HAVING THESE
CHOICES AND HAVING A MENU OF.
MAKING THAT DECISION OF WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO- IF YOU JUST
LEARNED ABOUT WHAT IT FIND
BENEFIT PENSION BUYS AT FORTY
NINE YEARS OLD IF I'M
GRADUATING. FROM COLLEGE AND I'M
GONNA BE TEACHING AND I'M TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD I
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION AS- IS
REALLY BY CHOICE THERE FOR MAYBE
I DON'T KNOW HOW. MANY PEOPLE
ARE VERY ENAMORED WITH FOR ONE
CASE WHEN I WAS IN THE- WHEN I
REMEMBER ONE OF. MY MEN PERCENT
. HI D. KNOW THAT ONE OF FRIENDS
IS RE. FOR MERVYN'S AND SHE HAS
A THOUSAND. FOUR ONE K. WHY
DON'T I HAVE THAT. I SAID
BECAUSE WHAT YOU HAVE IS YOU
HAVE A DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION
THAT MEANS YOU WILL COLLECT. THE
SAME AMOUNT WHATEVER DOES DEPEND
ON THE AMOUNT OF YEARS YOU
WORKED FOR THE REST OF YOUR
LIFE. WHEN YOU HAVE A FOUR ONE
K. THEORETICALLY YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO LIVE OFF THE INTEREST OF
THAT. SO LET'S SAY THAT YOU CAN
GET A 10% RETURN WHICH IS
UNHEARD OF NO ONE'S GOING TO GET
A 10% RETURN. ON THEIR
INVESTMENT THAT WOULD MEAN YOU
TO. TEN THOUSAND. A YEAR IF YOU.
HAVE ON THAT TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR BECAUSE YOU FOUND
THAT 10% RETURN. THAT YOU
WEREN'T PULLING AWAY AT YOUR
NEST EGG AND IT'S GETTING
SMALLER AND SMALLER EVERY YEAR.
SO MY POINT IS YOU DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT IT DEFINED BENEFIT WAS INTO
YOUR- A LITTLE BIT OLDER IN
LIFE. WE'RE ASKING YOU'RE A
THREE YEAR FOR EXAMPLE WERE
TELLING THESE YOUNG PEOPLE MAKE
A DECISION MAKE A CHOICE. THEY
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
CHOOSING SO MANY OF US WANT TO
HELP THEM. TO MAKE A CHOICE THAT
WILL HELP THEM IN SECURE TO BE
SECURE IN THEIR RETIREMENT. BUT
YOU'RE SO CENTER GLAZE I THINK
WE JUST HAVE SOME. FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCES AND AGAIN. THIS IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE. PEOPLE CAN
RETIREMENT RETIRE. AND BE ABLE
TO PAY THEIR BILLS WHEN I TALK
TO YOUNG PEOPLE- I WAS SAID TO
THEM. WHO KNOWS WHAT RETIREMENT
IS WHO KNOWS WHAT IT IS TO HAVE
A PENSION. MOST OF THEM DON'T
KNOW. WHAT I TELL THEM IS WHEN
YOU RETIRE YOU WANT TO BE ABLE
TO EAT. SO YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU HAVE A JOB. THAT HAS A
PENSION. MAKING SURE. TEACHERS
WHO ARE TEACHING OUR FUTURE
LEADERS HAVE A SECURE
RETIREMENT. I PERSONALLY THINK
THAT THAT IS A LAUDABLE GOAL AND
SOMETHING EACH AND EVERYONE OF
US. SHOULD BE PASSIONATE ABOUT
BECAUSE- WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
PEOPLE CAN'T PAY THEIR BILLS
WHEN THEY'RE OLDER. THAN THEY GO
ON THE END UP ON THE STREETS OR
THE END UP LIVING WITH FAMILY.
IT'S ABOUT DIGNITY IT'S ABOUT
RESPECT IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE
PEOPLE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES AND
RETIREMENT AFTER THEY'VE WORKED.
FOR AND- CLASS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY NOUN IT'S APPROPRIATE I
WAS GOING TO BE QUIET AND JUST
VOTE NO BUT I WANTED I FEEL I'M
SOMEBODY WHO'S ABOUT DEFINED
BENEFITS. AND BECAUSE I SERVED
ON THE CALIBER SERVERS WE HAD AN
UPSIDE DOWN DEFINIT AT WHICH
WOULD PRE BOARDS ALREADY SET SO
I JUST WANT TO FOR THE RECORD.
THAT EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM KNOW
THAT IF YOU ARE IN PERSON.
FIRSTERS YOU HAVE A DEFINED
BENEFIT. IT IS BASED OFF OF THE
STOCK MARKET AND WHO'S THE
COMPANY YOU WORK FOR IS THE
STATE OR SCHOOL BOARD OR ARE IN
SCHOOL OR- LOCAL DISTRICT AND IT
IS ALL BASED OFF OF. IF THAT
DEFINED BENEFIT GOES UPSIDE DOWN
ON THE INVESTMENTS. THE
TAXPAYERS ON THE HOOK FOR THE
UTILITY DISTRICT OR WHOEVER THIS
IS ON THE HOOK SO. MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT. YOU'RE GETTING
A DEFINED BENEFIT ONLY IF
THERE'S A BENEFIT THERE TO BE
HAPPY. AND IN PERSON. NOT STIRS
THAT PERSON IS VERY UPSIDE DOWN
RIGHT NOW AND A LOT AND THEN THE
OTHER WE ALL OVER THE STATE
BECAUSE EVERY YOU KNOW EVERY-
MUNICIPALITY HAS A DIFFERENT
SYSTEM SO. TRUST ME WHEN THE
STOCK MARKET TAKES A DIP IN IT
WILL WE WILL BE TALKING. THOSE
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN NAY AND
THOSE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE IT
BECAUSE IN MY DISTRICT WAS THE
FIRST COMMUNITY THAT WE SAW. A
RETIRED WOMAN WHO HAD A DEFINED
BENEFIT AND SHE WAS GETTING SET
FOR. SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR AND WENT TO NINETEEN
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY BASED OFF OF
WHAT'S IN THE FUND. AND SO.
REMIND YOU. YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
IT BUT IT IS TIED TO THE STOCK
MARKET AND THE COMPANY WORK FOR
IS THE STATE OR THE CITY OR
COUNTY WHATEVER IT IS. AND
THEY'RE ON THE HOOK FOR AND
THAT'S A TAXPAYER. AND SERVED
ALL I AGREE WITH YOU THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. CALPERS AND
SING IN THE STOCK MARKET IS IT'S
AMORTIZED OVER A MUCH LONGER
TIME AND OVER MANY MANY HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF MORE. THE FOUR
OH ONE K. SO ARE THEY BOTH
DEPEND ON THE STOCK MARKET YES
THEY ARE BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS
ONE IS MUCH BIGGER AND CAN TAKE
LOSSES. CAN TAKE KIDS. IF I HAD
A FOUR ONE K. AND THERE'S A HUGE
HIT MY LOSE HALF OF MY FOUR ONE
K. I MAY NOT MAKE THAT. UP IN
TIME FOR WHEN I RETIRE. THAT'S
STILL A CHOICE THAT SOMEBODY CAN
MAKE. LIFE IS FULL OF CHOICES
THAT ARE OCHO I AGREE. I AGREE I
AGREE I JUST THINK THAT PEOPLE
HAVE CHOICES AND THEY CAN DECIDE
AND BE EDUCATED ON THE SYSTEM
LET'S HOPE FOR EDUCATING OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHAT IT Y. A. R. I.
DON'T THINK WE ARE. I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE- THANK YOU SO MUCH AT O
WE HAVE YOUR CLOSING THAT IS MY
CLOSING OKAY. PERFECT- SO- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION TO- DO PASSED AS
AMENDED BUT PERSON MAN AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. OKAY I'M SORRY
MOST. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR- CORTESE HE'S THE I'M
SORRY. THEY'RE CURRENTLY USING
THEM CONSULTING WOULD YOU MIND
CALLING THE ROLE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA. AYE LEYVA
AUDIO TROUBLE BUG NO UNTIL ABOVE
NORTH FUSE ME- TOWBOAT NO
COURTESY COURTESY I'D DELI DELHI
KNOWS GLAZER GLAZER NOTE.
MCGUIRE AND- THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
GLAZER EUROPE NEXT.
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT SENATOR GLAZER IS HERE
TO PRESENT FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
SB TWELVE THIRTY SIX BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU AT CHILE
THAT AND I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR ON THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL I SCHOOL
BOARDS ARE REQUIRED TO CREATE A
STUDENT A STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
POSITION IF THEY RECEIVE A
QUALIFYING PETITION FROM HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. SB THIRTY SIX WOULD
GIVE LOCAL. IN THE GRANT THEIR
STUDENT. BOARD MEMBER FULL
VOTING RIGHTS. THE OPTION GIVE
THEIR STUDENT FULL VOTING RIGHTS
CURRENTLY STUDENT. BOARD MEMBERS
ARE RESTRICTED TO PREP THE
VOTING RIGHTS THAT ALLOW THEM TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPINION WITHOUT
THEIR VOTE ACTUALLY COUNTY.
GIVEN THIS OPTION A LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS CAN FURTHER EMPOWER
STUDENT VOICES TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE INPUT INTO THEIR OWN
EDUCATION. RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT STUDENT GAGE EVAN AND
THROUGH THE YEARS OF IN SCHOOL
STARTS OFF. AT IN THE IN
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH ELEMENTARY
AND- DROPS IS THEY GET A LITTLE
BIT OLDER- AND WEWANT THEM TO
STAY ENGAGED AND INFORMED ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING. FURTHER ALL
THEIR- THE STUDY WAS CONDUCTED
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE SCHOOLS ACROSS FOURTEEN
STATES THAT REPORTED THAT
INCREASING THE STUDENT VOICE
HELP STUDENTS EXPERIENCE SELF
WORTH ENGAGEMENT AND PURPOSE- IT
LEADS TO LOWER DROPOUT RATES AND
IMPROVE LEARNING OUTCOMES-
SEVERAL SCHOOL BOARDS IN. I
ALREADY GRANT FULL- VOTING
RIGHTS THEIR STUDENT MEMBERS
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS- IN MARYLAND
OF GRANTED FULL VOTING RIGHTS
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY AND I
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL THAT WE
GIVE OUR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT RIGHT TO GIVE STUDENTS THAT
OPTION. SO WITH THAT I HAVE CHEN
TRANICE TO MEMBER OF THE GARDEN
GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD OF IT ATION. HERE TO
TESTIFY AND THE POLICY DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER ASSOCIATION- HE IS ALSO
THE POLICY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA. STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS JAMES
AGEE WILL OUR PRESIDENT OF THE
SAN LEANDRO BOARD OF EDUCATION
AFTER CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION HERE TO TESTIFY AS
WELL DID YOU CENTER GLAZER.
GOING TO YOU WE- JENNIFER
BRANDON. THANK YOU ALL ON THE
LINE- MISS TRANSHUMAN BEGIN YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. I THINK WE
SURE CAN. ACTUALLY YOU'RE YOU'RE
VERY IT'S WE CAN BARELY HEAR YOU
MAYBE YOU COULD SPEAK UP OR TURN
THE VOLUME UP. NOW WE CAN'T HEAR
YOU AT ALL MISS TRANS. ALL WHICH. THIS IS. TWENTY SEVENTEEN HIS
TRANSFER MISTRANSLATED WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO CALL BACK IN
BECAUSE WE CANNOT WE CAN CAN'T
HEAR YOU CAN'T MAKE OUT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. BURKE DESPITE
THESE EFFORTS AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OKAY I'M NOT. AT THE
POINT BURKE IT IS TRULY A
ALLOCATE TO CORNERBACK TO THE
WITHOUT. AND FOR. KEEPING. TO
LEARN. I WORK WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH ACT I WORK FOR THE
CURRENT WITH THE NETWORK THAT I
WANT. GET BACK WITH ME HE DID
THIRTY I THINK. RIGHT NO BURKE
THE MOBILE BUT IN I NEED TO
WRITE. THAT INFORMATION
CORRECTLY EDUCATION. IN ORDER
FOR IT. FOR IN THE POOL OF THAT. THANK YOU. FOR THAT YOU CAN
GET THE ABILITY OF THE.
OKAY THANK YOU COULD TAKE IT.
WHAT PRESIDENT. ANYTHING ABOUT
THE MISSION I MEAN. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO MISTER AGUILAR. PERCY WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU HEAR ME WE
SURE CAN. PERFECT EVENING
CARROLLTON THEY'VE AND MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE I GIVE A LOT AND I
THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
FAMILY UNDER UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF TRUSTEES AS A
REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND AS A DIRECTOR AT
LARGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
BOARD MEMBERS. THAT THEY-
OFFICER BUSINESS STUDENT TRUSTEE
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO I SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AS I SHARE WITH
YOU THE URGENT NECESSITY TO
EXPAND THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS
AND ALLOW SCHOOL BOARDS THE
OPTION. THAT THEY NEED TO MOVE
BEYOND SURFACE LEVEL PART
PATIENT PUBLIC SCHOOLS CONTINUE
TO FACE INEQUITIES AND IT IS.
THE STUDENT TO OUR IMPACT.
INJUSTICES F. DAY TODAY IT'S NO
SURPRISE THAT STUDENTS ARE
SPEAKING UP AND CHALLENGING
THEIR DISTRICT CHALLENGING US TO
DO BETTER AT GOVERNING. THE
REALITY IS THAT NOTHING STOPS
BEFORE STUDENT ACTUALLY HAVING A
SAY IN THE EDUCATION SYSTEM
RECEIVING FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
REPRESENTATION. AFTER ALL IT IS
IF YOU DIDN'T. THERE ARE THERE-
R. D. NUMBER ONE IN AS- AT THE
SCHOOL WHAT PRESIDENT I THINK
EXCITED THE OPS THAT B. TWELVE
SIX PROVIDE EXPAND THE WORLD
BOARD. OPTIONS THE PROVIDE
OFFICIAL AND RECORD BOY YOU IT
IS MYTH THAT YOU PEOPLE THAT
BOARD WHO ARE EITHER BUT PEERS
ARE APPOINTED BY THE BOARD
CANNOT HANDLE LARGE AND COMPLEX
ISSUES BECAUSE THEY ARE QUOTE
TOO YOUNG OR NOT IN THE KNOW
STUDENTS CAN ABSOLUTELY HANDLE
COMPLEX ISSUES WORK FACES. TAKE
ABOUT THANK BETWEEN. THE TACKLE
THEM EVERY DAY AT HOME IN THE
CLASSROOM AND. BERMAN AND THE
BREAKING UP OF EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLDS ARE ELECT OFFICIAL YOU
IMPRESSED. AT THIRTY OPEN THE
DOOR TO A NEW ERA DIRECT
REPRESENT. MANY STATES HAVE
ALREADY GONE THAT ROUTE FOR
GIVING THEM A FULL VOTE ON THEIR
BOARD AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IN A
STATE WHERE LESS THAN 30% OF
STUDENTSSUPPORTED MEANINGFUL
PARTICIPATION ON THEIR SCHOOL
BOARD- AND IN THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. SB TWELVE PREFIX
FINALLY OFFERS A PATHWAY TO
CREATE. THIS GREAT SCHOOLS FOR
STUDENTS AND- ALLOW THEM TO HAVE
A WEIGHT. THOSE DECISIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR.
WELCOME TO ROOM. OF TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME IS
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. YES HI
GENEVIEVE HUNDRED SHOW FIRST
STUDENT AT UC SAN DIEGO
FOREMAN'S FORMER STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER AT CAPISTRANO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND REPRESENTING
GENERATION UP IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE. ROOM TWENTY ONE. IN A
MODERATOR YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY SIX. IF YOU WISH TO
THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL
FIRST START WITH LYING TO TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO ON A
REMEMBER MINE IN THE WAY OF
COURSE OF COURSE I'M A STUDENT
FROM THE BAY AREA AND- FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ON THE OPEN
UNIFIED BOARD OF EDUCATION
COMMUNE IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF
ANTI THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINE TO THIRTY SIX- HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMUNITY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS VERY SIMPLE KUMAR I
LIFTED IT FROM DESTRUCTION A
DIVISION FOR THE SENATE AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE TO
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ON CON AND I'M
A HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR TEACHING
HIGH SCHOOL FROM SENATE DISTRICT
TEN I'M A FORTY FOUR YEAR SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER AND A CURRENT
STUDENT BY THE BOARD CHAIRPERSON
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
. LINE TWO FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO IN PART BECAUSE I
ALREADY IN THE CURRENT BOARD
MEMBER FOR PUBLIC UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT LOCATED IN SENATE
DISTRICT SEVEN I'M STRONGLY FELT. AND NEXT LINE TO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO TWO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR
NUMBERS MEAN INTER HENNESSEY AND
I'M DOING A LOT OF I WILL BE
SERVING AS A PORTER HIGH SCHOOL
SCHOOL REPRESENTED NEXT YEAR IN
THE POULTRY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT NAME IS TRANSPORTABLE
INVOICE IN THIRTY ONE HUNDRED
GLOBAL DIVISION GETTING A CHANCE
TO VOTE WILL DO MORE TO DRINK
WITH REPRESENTATION. HOW OFTEN
SHOULD. TO BACK UP THERE ARE ARE
DUE TO PASS THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE'LL HAVE LINE Q.
FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
MORNING TO ME IN A CANNABIS MY
NAME IS EMILY AND STUDENT FROM
THANK YOU AND I WOULD ALSO STRIP
AND THEN- WHAT BY SHIPPERS NEXT
YEAR A NUMBER OF US TO FORTY AND
I'M TRANSPORTED THIS THE- AND-
WE HAVE LINE. TWO TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEN PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER ASSOCIATION AND THE
STUDENT CORPORATE THE TECHNICAL
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
CALIFORNIA'S SECOND LARGEST
CALLING IN WITH STRONG SUPPORT
TODAY. LINE TWO THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS I CARE COST THAT'S
CURRENT STUDENT BOARD
REPRESENTATIVE FOR FOLLOW UP THE
HIGH SCHOOL IN THE POLICY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO
SCHOOL BOARD DECISIONS AND THE
PASSING OF THIS BILL WILL GIVE.
IT MORE REPRESENTATION WHEN IT
COMES TO THE IMPROVEMENT OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AT THE END OF
THE DAY SCHOOL DISTRICT'S MAIN
GOAL IS TO MAKE THEIR SCHOOLS
THE BEST THEY CAN BE FOR THE
STUDENTS AND ALLOWING THE
REPRESENTATIVES TO VOTE IS A BIG
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TOWARD ACHIEVING THIS GOAL.
CONSIDER PASSING A CELL. WE HAVE
. TO TWENTY THREE PLEASE AHEAD.
HI MY NAME'S ANNIKA GRANNY I AM
THE STUDENT REPRESENTATIVE FROM
GUNN HIGH SCHOOL AT THE PALO OF
THE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I AM
VERY STRONG SUPPORT SYSTEM THANK
YOU. AND NOW WE HAVE LINE TO
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE WILL NOT A
CONSEQUENCE FOR SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY NINE AND IN FULLER TIME I
AM STRONG SUPPORT OF AT LEAST
TWELVE THIRTY SIX. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE TO FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LED IN THE GAME AND
DINNER FROM SENATE DISTRICT TEN
AND THEN THE FOR THE PEOPLE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AYE
MITCHELL SUPPORT THE. AND NEXT
WE HAVE LINED CHIU FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JAMES DURAN AND FROM
SENATE-DISTRICT THANK I'M OFF TO
BE STUDENT BOARD MEMBER FOR-
BROKE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. WE HAVE LINE THROUGH
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CAROL MCCARTHY I'M A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER FROM
PLEASANTON UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I'M ALL FOR IT THE FDA
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
STOLEN WOULD LIKE RECOGNIZED ALL
STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS WHO HAS.
WORKED WITH HIGHER THE HELL OF
PRESENT BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINED
CHIU FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS PRANAB CHOWDHURY AN
ID NUMBER OF THE FAIRFAX COUNTY
SCHOOL BOARD SERVING AMERICANS
ELEVENTH LARGEST SCHOOL SYSTEM
AND AS A PRESS THREE TO MORE
THAN A HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
WILL BE CENTERED I WRONGLY
SUPPORT AT. TWELVE THIRTY. THANK
YOU FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. EXACTLY COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME JOINING A LAMB
I'M A STUDENT AND SENATE
DISTRICT ELEVEN I SERVICE IN
BOARD MEMBERS OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND AS THE TECHNOLOGY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER FOR YEARS
AND- I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE- AND- WE HAVE ONE. TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOOKING AT
ME WE CAN. I'M DANNIELYNN IN
UPCOMING- THE NEW I'VE DONE
QUITE WELL AND IT'S WRONG WE
COULD PUT THE. AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINE- WE HAVE LINE TO FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN'T. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS EXTRA CAREER- I AM
FROM AND INCIDENT DISTRICT NINE
OUR OFFICE IN BERMAN FOR ON THE
OPEN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY FELLOW
NUMBER NUMBER OUT DANA AND WE
ARE BOTH IN STRONG SUPPORT
SYSTEM. THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SANDRA
BARRERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR STAFF FOR REACHING
OUT AND BEING PROACTIVE TO
ADDRESS MY QUESTIONS. WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL- NOT
BECAUSE WE DISAGREE WITH THE
IDEA THAT STUDENT INVOLVEMENT
IMPROVES OUTCOME. OR THAT
STUDENTS. CAPABLE OF MAKING
DECISIONS ON COMPLEX ISSUES WE
HAVE HOPES BECAUSE IT UNDERMINES
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AND THE
REASON WHY PUBLICLY ELECTED
SCHOOL BOARDS EXIT. PLACE WE'RE
MAPS WHO ARE ELECTED ARE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE VOTERS
WHEREAS ON APPOINTED MEMBER IS
NOT. SO WE HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR
WILL CONSIDER OTHER WAYS TO
INCLUDE STUDENT VOICE VOICES IN
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS THAT
DON'T UNDERMINED THE RIGHTS OF
VOTERS IN HE'S JUST. CAL WESTERN
ABOUT. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
HERE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED C. NO
ONE META MODERATOR WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO YOU AND ASK ANYONE TO
QUEUE UP WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE SB. TWELVE THIRTY SIX. AND SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT IS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I HAVE
NO I THINK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR ALRIGHT WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN PROJECT
CLOSE CENTER GLAZER THANK YOU
SURE LEYVA. I WANT TO THANK AT
JENNIFER AND JAMES FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY I ALSO WANT TO THANK
ALL THE STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS AT
FORMER STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS WHO
WHO CALLED IN ND- CREATE THEIR
ENGAGEMENT AND ARE THEY ARE
SENATE PUBLIC HEARING PROCESS
IT'S A ONE. AT WE APPRECIATE IT
. IT TWO THINGS- IN IN CLOSING
NUMBER ONE- THIS BILL- MAINTAINS
LOCAL CONTROL IT'S OPTIONAL- THE
ELECTED LEADERS OF THESE
DISTRICTS ELECTED LEADERS CAN
MAKE THE CHOICE TO DO IT- TO NOT
TO DO IT I WOULD NOTE THAT A
STUDENT MOST OF THE STUDENTS ARE
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO RUN I BET IF
THEY WERE THEY WOULD LIKE TO RUN
AND MAYBE SOME HAVE- SO IT'S A
CLASS OF PEOPLE THAT. OBVIOUSLY
HAVE A AN IMPORTANT INTEREST AND
INSIGHT THEY CAN'T REALLY
DESERVE BECAUSE OF OUR ELECTION
RULES WHERE YOU HAVE TO BE
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE- AND
FINALLY I THINK THAT- SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE ALL. WHY GAUGED IN
INVOLVED THAT THAT YOU FEEL THAT
YOUR VOICE MATTERS- THE STUDENT
VOICE DOES MATTER HOW ADAM AND
IT'S MY HOPE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL EXERCISE THE
RIGHT THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED IN
THIS BILL IT MOVES FORWARD TO
WHAT TO ALLOW STUDENTS TO BE A
FULL VOTING MEMBER OF THEIR
COMMITTEE WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I THOUGHT YOU CENTER
GLAZER DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU THE BILL'S REMOVER
CERRO CHAUBOTH. MEN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB TWELVE THIRTY SIX
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS. LEYVA HI
LEYVA HI- TROUBLED I. GO TO A
VOTE HI CRITICIZING. DALY NO
DALY NOW GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN. ALL
RIGHT THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS OKAY MEMBERS-
AND TO THE PUBLIC SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY ONE FILE ITEM SIX WAS
JUST PULLED BY SENATOR ALAN SO
WE WILL NOT BE HEARING THAT BILL
TODAY- AND WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
JUST GIVE A COUPLE MINUTES TO
OUR MEMBERS WERE NOT HERE WE'RE
HOPING CENTER PANCAKE COME FROM
HEALTH. TO VOTE ON BILLS HE HAS
BEEN UNABLE TO VOTE ON A CENTER
DOLLY HAS VOTED ON EVERYTHING SO
HE COULD LEAVE BUT WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE- GIVE A COUPLE MINUTES
FIRST TERROR CORTESE TO COME
BACK AND HELP THE SENATOR PAM.
FORTY SYSTEM THIS CALL- I CAN DO
THAT THIS IS A YES OKAY LET'S GO
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. YOUR
DID YOUR WELCOME SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE MEDIC CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING I
BRAIN AYE COURTESY. EITHER
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I AM
ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER.
WE DO THE ONES THAT I'VE
RESTORED TO INNOVATE. ONE SURE.
ONE MOMENT OKAY AND THEN THEY'LL
- WITH THAT PERFECT. THE FOR.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND THEN
I'LL BE HEADING OVER YOUR
COMMITTEE SIT DOWN THE OTHER
SIDE ALL RIGHT MADAM CONSULTANT
LET'S START AT THE TOP WITH S.
B. ONE EXCUSE ME WITH SB EIGHT
THIRTY FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING NO VICE CHAIR HAS
NOT VOTED MENTAL CONSULTANT I'M
SORRY ONE MOMENT. SO I CLARIFY
SO- BECAUSE I WAS HE WAS HE HE
AT THE COMMITTEE MET WERE NOT.
BUT OKAY SORRY. MA'AM CONSULTANT
. FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB EIGHT
THIRTY. MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING NOW VISSCHER HAS
NOT VOTED UNTIL ABOUT HI THE
TROUBLED BY. DALY MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI PAM I. SINCE
THE BILLS OUT. YES PLEASE THANK
YOU. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
NINE ZERO SIX THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR HAS
NOT VOTED OCHO BOTH. MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE PAN ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S ENOUGH TO DO THAT BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
NINE ZERO FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I VISSCHER VOTING
NOW. MCGUIRE WHERE I PAN HI
HANNAH BILLS ALSO OUT. NUMBER
FOUR S. ELEVEN SIXTY MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING AYE VICE CHAIR
VOTING ONLINE DAILY. MCGUIRE I
PAN HI PAM HI THAT BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. SB
THIRTEEN ZERO EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING ON AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI CAN
I THAT BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB FOURTEEN ZERO
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. SHARES VOTED AYE VICE
CHAIR. HAS NOT VOTED ACTUAL
BROKE. DALY GLAZER. MCGUIRE
VOTED I'VE ALREADY PAM HI PAM
THAT BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THAT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
VENTURE VOTING ON A COURTESY. M.
HI CAN I. THE BILL'S ALSO OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY SIX THE MOTION IS
THE PASS CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE
YOU'RE VOTING I COURTESY PAM HI
PAM HI. FILE ITEM NUMBER TENS OR
THAT PULLS OUT AS WELL. TO ME.
IT. I AM GONNA WAIT FOR CENTER
CORTESE THANK YOU. OKAY SO WE'LL
LEAVE ON FILE ITEM EIGHT AND
FILE ITEM NINE OPEN. THESE WITH
PERCENT FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN S.
B. THIRTEEN FORTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIRMAN I VICE YOU'RE VOTING NO
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN. ALL
RIGHT HI. AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU JOHN ARE YOU SENATOR
DAISY STAFF REPORTER NO SHE
THOUGHT THAT SUCH AS YOU KNOW IT
BECAUSE HE'S WAITING 2% AND
HEALTH THERE'S ANOTHER BILL WE
CAN DRAG HIM OVER HERE KIM
CLOSER ROLE AND THEN I'LL TELL
MYSELF I'LL BE SURE HE'S THE
NEXT PERSON. OKAY HELFELD GET.
WE ARE BACK ON THE RECORD HERE
CENTER CORTESE I BELIEVE YOU
NEED TO VOTE ON FILE ITEM EIGHT
AND NINE MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM EIGHT
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIRMAN I VICE YOU'RE VOTING I
CORTES A- COURTESY. THAT BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
PLEASE FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
TWELVE THIRTY SIX THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED YOUR VOTING I'D VICE
CHAIR VOTING ONLINE CORTESE- TO
THE AYE. THAT BILLS OUT AS WELL.
THANK YOU CENTER COURT. THANK
YOU EVERYONE WE ARE NOW
CONCLUDING THE EDUCATION THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTSAND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU ALSO
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA OF THE SENATE EDUCATE
ME EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.